so so you can go live
there three two where do I go here this
yep what up Facebook live you're first
Super 8 and that's on so that's
Periscope Periscope is not looking at me
but now it
is do I want to go like that very nice
scope off and running Facebook off and
running
mircat
super now the one thing I would say
India is what's up guys Super Eight is
starting one thing I would say is
um somebody might want to sit behind me
like and read and like read a little bit
show you tried to hit the screen I was
trying to show you go go you're like
Xander cast is pre oh here we go eight
seven six all right spreecast haven't
been on that in a minute I'm excited
about that Jeff lur will be pumped about
that good
morning I don't I know what what is that
about okay cool wait a minute why is
thecast not
on it is it's live but I don't see it
um can you guys see I mean spr cast is
not on
the camera's on
but okay you can figure that out all
right I'll let these guys work on spre
cast is super fun Super Eight Is Here
Steven dollar is here good morning my
man [__] sleep tooski I agree oh I like
going back and forth did you see my
Snapchat question not yet Drew Larsson
but I know you're looking for me uh
sorry I've just been a little head down
and uh but I will be back in motion but
right right now we are focused on Super
Eight Switzerland is in the house Lord
have mercy I made it yes you did
heartlink
Laura hi Gary who loves you in Arizona
you do Ruth you always do I appreciate
all your support always you always are
coming through for me glad I refresh the
page bring it Gary Alicia I will so
we're going to really focus on um on Q&A
today I'm going to go hardcore Q&A and
try to answer all your questions I love
it shows that it's live hit refresh I
just did and that didn't happen spree
cast you're making me sad now if people
can check out my links on spreecast and
let me know if they can actually see
this because we can't see it and I'd
like to know this is going to be fun and
interesting and Miha that is correct Q&A
baby wow you know this Periscope big
screen is pretty awesome I do you know
what we only got Facebook live on the
small screen these two big screens are
awesome these little things I like them
we need to we need to Fig I need to
figure this more out like this is
something there we go and spr cast what
up Andy's here he fixed it he did it
Andy you did it yo Brooklyn we did it we
did it we did it oh spr cast says the
eight bucks these posters are legit I
like it oh who's that look there she is
there she
is amazing she's actually Brooklyn we
did it all right so we've got I mean
look there's a lot to do today
there's only 7 hours and 56 minutes
left of focusing on this right so let
let let's set the tone because first
couple minutes were a little clunky here
just kind of getting settled in um what
I'm trying to do here is the Super Eight
raffle right so if you buy eight books
right now on Amazon or Barnes & Noble
Barnes & Noble has the signed books for
the same price as Amazon but I heard
last night from the publisher there's
only a couple hundred left so only 30 or
40 people that are watching right now um
are going to be able to
enter um during this time um and so send
in your receipts to Super8 vainer
media.com Super8 vainer
media.com um now are you guys producing
over here Andy and you're so you're so I
want to move as many people you're on
handheld devices but as many people as
possible toast that link is on Oh India
you texted me right so I'm going to
tweet that right now it's on my Facebook
down a yeah you want you want a better
look what do you want you can't do you
can't you can't really adjust all right
hold but I do like them seeing I do like
them seeing that which is 1,000 books
for the 101 session we can move it
forward too I do like I like I like no
no you know what I'm going to give me or
cat this is fun this is fun NOP stay
back Andy go ahead you guys get to be a
big part of today since there's eight
hours guas on the right get over here
and get over
here and you guys are clunky all right
this going to be fun I feel you know
what I like I like that I'm feeling
super patient that I'm not like you know
oh my God I got to you know get
everything in right now so I like that
go ahead an you talk while I tweet out
the Spree cast on the right hand side
there's chat that's for all of you guys
to talk this is about spree cast well
we'll going to be looking at the chat we
can add people on camera things of that
nature but also if you want to submit
certain questions um you can do that
below the
video right now we're allow allowing all
questions to be shown and I want you
guys to try and upvote questions that
you like smart um and then take it from
there if if there's if it's getting too
fast we can eliminate till I like it
fast and I like it fast all right let's
do it okay good um that's it cool did
you tell everybody I like the fast he
likes the fast he likes game winners too
oh I had a good game winner today all
right let's do this this is for
Instagram India's here Andy's here
drock's here and sprc which is I'm what
I'm linking mircat Periscope Facebook
live the books Super Eight Is
Here do this this is for
in all right I know it's a little boring
everybody trust me I will make it I will
make it way better in a
second I will make it much more fun in a
second Super 8 is here watch on
desktop here this is for the insta sorry
to be boring don't be mad at me I'm
usually not
boring can you give me a [__] pass
Jesus Christ I get it all right you guys
need to be in charge of getting me some
questions I'm going to be interacting
here but let's get to the call to
actions we're going to have now what's
happening where's my bucket and are they
bringing receipts what's happening with
the receipts guys I want receipts here I
want to throw them in I want to pull
them out somebody at the end will be
flown to now by the way I've made this
Global now I've decided to make this
Global this is not a us only thing
anymore anywhere in the world I will see
you either in
London maybe I'll see you in Australia
so if you're in the Asia area I'll pop
you to Australia uh Europe I'll go to
London uh the Americas you'll come to
New York uh there's also the LA office
I've got offices I got [__] offices
and I travel so we're going worldwide
eight hours buy eight books and you're
entered by 16 you're entered twice by 24
you're entered
Thrice thcy Rock so super excited about
it um now here's the first question I
want to see it all come through all the
different chats this is what I need to
feel who's who's womaning or Manning the
inbox right now I my juices are going to
get going based on the receipts coming
in now we're going to have some guests
stop by AJ vaynerchuk has committed to
stop by this is big news AJ doesn't make
too many appearances we'll get the talk
Viner people can ask their family
business questions AJ said around 3 p.m.
Eastern he'll become a little more
available so uh you're maxed look at
this you must find questions we're maxed
here and can you must free up space in
question Q click bring question and
we're maxed over there so let me I'm
going to focus a little bit right now on
on Periscope now Periscope there's only
657 of you looks like everybody's kind
of migrating to Facebook I need you to
hit the share button I want explosion on
Twitter I want to I want to explode on
Twitter's face with every one of you all
658 going down below and clicking it and
sharing it up who can bring that value
to me Big Ups Mexico let's go there we
go now I'm seeing the sharing coming I
don't have a problem buying a thousand
but I don't know who to give that many
to there's a there's a thousand people I
can tell you to give it to if you want
to buy a thousand and you know a th cool
right because that comes you get to come
and do a one-on-one session with me or
or eight books get you a one-on-one
session if you win today and that's the
big thing we're doing today if you win
today so I'm going to focus a little bit
on Periscope for a second I see you
Facebook live Periscope says full
Periscope is probably full to type
because that's what happens on the scope
so a lot of you that want to talk you
need to go to spreecast or you need to
go to Facebook live go to my
facebook.com/ Gary mircat I got you see
you I love you uh company I'm an
investor in I'm having an update call
with Ben great CEO it's Johnny Miller
Gary eight books let's go let's go
Johnny let's send in those receipts
Super8 vainer media.com get in I like
alarm alarm fan is on all three spree
cast good to see you I like this I like
the Spree cast people coming in just
ordered another my three sign copies Lev
I love you for that like the Spree
better than the Perry I like PE David
wolf using spre short Perry scope short
sent in 16 already thank you Remy I
appreciate that stepen M The Stylist my
man Jersey Boy I love him he's got his
eight appreciate the hustle I appreciate
you golf 20,000 is for Armen what up
what up thigh side I want 999 other
people to join a cartel with me and then
I can have one 1,000 I love it I got my
eight books in confirmed you rock AR
thank you zero friction put up some
thanks Doug Bennett now Community I need
you and this is very important
throughout the day actually how many
people are stepping up going ludicrous
and hanging with me for all eight hours
because I'm going to appoint them stream
captains right now because we're only 11
minutes in to an8 hour day millionaire
talk is in I'm going to definitely try
mihi appreciate you thank
you Gary always unfollower thank you Sam
thank you mighty CBU
um yes I'm in okay so all day Vincent is
in all you all dayers I'll try trying
sucks took the day off epic a wiser
woman and she is India she is a wiser
Woman by taking today off brilliant I'm
here Thomas bass is in Trinidad's in the
house I am bringing my girlfriend too
Kyle stepping up and bringing the
girlfriend as well I like that not Kylie
from sou dck this is the ask scary B
show super eight India I don't know what
happened there like I I thought the
isn't the number one rule of Super 8
sessions to only talk when you're being
spoken to you know I didn't know that
this was an established thing but what
you want me to answer Remy's question
email your receed to Super8 Vayner
media.com Remy Super8 Vayner media.com
and that's the big thing right now I
really need this from you guys a lot of
people are going to ask what's going on
as they come in a lot of people are
going to ask you know what what are they
supposed to do you need to go with the
email in the Super8 bner media.com email
address with your receipt and uh let's
get into answering some questions we'll
push the books later um though if you
buy the books now eight Barnes & Noble's
running out if you want the sign ones
email in the receipt eight copies if 16
will print two Super8 bner media.com all
right Facebook freezes on Periscope the
video is much better watching with the
kids Rob I'll try not to curse ship to
Sweden absolutely Allan and remember one
more thing something that we didn't
promote the whole time we are going
worldwide with the contest now no matter
where you are if you're in Iceland if
you're if you're in uh South Africa if
you are in Thailand if you are in
Detroit you're eligible and you can get
flown in to a location where I am for
one hour I will be pulling that at the
end and I've decided to do some side
things as a matter you know what I'm
going to do something super random right
now first person I see here we go I'm
just going to go right into it I'm just
going to look it's just going to happen
it's just kind of what I'm doing all
right it's Miha bab me Miha You' just
won a sign book
Miha I love you email me Mi I think I
spelled your name wrong but that's just
kind of you know that's it you won
brother done email India India is it do
you have India at the
intermedia I know Nate ating Miha one I
think I spelled his name wrong uh no ma
a c a ma damn it Miha I missed it I feel
like it's spelled Misha m m c ah m c ah
there's the X out and look Miha look how
legit this is Miha come on Miha is that
funny I mean look this is a rare I could
Miha you could probably sell this easily
on eBay for 20 bucks a dollar more it
goes for Miha congratulations to Miha
big win for him email
India vayer media.com that reminds me
that this contest is worldwide and if
you live in India the
country that you can come and enter buy
eight books and so uh Andy uh please
start asking me some questions India
let's you know what India that's a good
point you're much better at asking
questions than Andy no that's not true
no no you're a professional question
asker like do you tell your friends
that's what you do for a living you ask
questions no I figure I fig I fig Ben do
you notice how I went off screen can uh
Andy look what I did I went off screen
they hate it hi spre cast there's my
hand put people on camera with you
obviously we're GNA put people on camera
on spree cast we will do that you could
do that right yeah as a producer see the
first one from Ben yeah so he may not be
there but let's try is there a second
camera for Stefan to be filming that
angle um we don't have enough batteries
got it not enough batteries that's what
happens when you go for eight straight
hours and we are now 15 minutes in 7
hours and 45 minutes to go on this
session India let's go in my mom my mom
just texted me she said wow looking good
where's Facebook live I'm sure she's
probably watching here Mom I love you so
so much Mom they don't know as much as I
say to them as much as I try to tell
them they don't know they don't know
they don't know that you're the real
Guru all right let's do
it um just asking Indie let's go okay if
your phones are TVs and TVs are not
radios totally hold on let's go you're
going very fast if the phone is now TV
and the TV's radio which has been a big
Spiel of mine lately which Ben really
agrees with do you have advice on what
should be on your website and can you
please mention a few examples well first
of all websites are interesting to me
one of the things I've been thinking
about I'm going to give a tidbit right
now one of the things I promised myself
last night I was about to go to sleep
and I said you know what tomorrow is a
very important day tomorrow is a day
that many will look back on and decide
was that a good use of their time was
that a bad use of their time why do they
have seven random books laying
around and and I want to really make
sure that I bring enormous value so one
of the things I really want to do in
this episode is separate myself with
tactical advice not just the normal rah
rah motivation and I think the askar V
show has allowed me to do tactical
advice I think that's why this book is
better than any book I've written and
and it's got the mix of the motivation
and the Tactical so it's all you know
what this is actually this is the love
child of jab jab and thank you economy
and crush it if you really think about
it like that's really it's like the 2016
version of those three books in one
anyway so let me give you something
really cool I'm going to give this now
recognize that with the thousands of
people that are watching across all
different platforms a lot of different
things are going to happen all of you
are going to do this though what I do
know even though there's four or five
thousand people watching uh that only
seven of you g to do it but it will take
a little oomph out I was going to do
this but I'm giving it to you my
community and that was the big thing I
promised myself seven to 15 tactics that
I'm going to do for myself that I am
going to give away right
so is this oh my God what is this I'll
tell you what it is it is a bucket full
of receipts I am fired up right now
bucket full of receipts we're going to
be pulling look oh look oh my God this
person could you imagine they almost you
know what I can't do it we're going to
do something here for this person right
now cuz this would be unfair this person
is getting 10 sign books because that'd
be unfair if like no
actually I don't know what to do do
something random that's fun okay fine
yay I love him super
pum look this got this got cut off but
we have it all in a database right so
Eric good news bad news actually you
know what no I was going to say good
news you got 10 signed books bad news is
you can't win the trip to New York wait
I need his email sorry got it all right
Eric WR you got you got Greg on with you
okay Greg Greg now listen real quick a
lot of you are not on only 500 and
there's thousands on on the other
platforms please head over right away to
spree cast I linked it on my Twitter my
Instagram and my Facebook on spree cast
we live where Greg looks handsome he
looks really handsome by the way he's
got a great [__] Jean shirt on he's
killing it I'm super pumped and A lot's
going to happen here so let's let's make
sure you get over there as well you
don't want to miss out but it's nice and
loud so people can hear them Facebook
live that wasn't bad right can we switch
Facebook live can you guys work on that
while I do this
Greg how are you mate I'm doing super oh
mate well tell me where you're from
Greg uh just outside London love it we
spoke like a couple of years back now
when you were uh releasing jab jab jab
right hook um we done a little um Google
Hangout yes and uh it cut out halfway
through our conversation so I had a f
fantastic conversation with do in the
world didn't get to see it godamn it how
are you things are super well what's
going on with
you uh you know much of the same mate
like I'm still just pounding away trying
to get the the business up and running
off the ground it's uh it's 5 years in
now I've made a lot of mistakes along
the way I listen to what you're doing
day in day out and and try and take it
away that part about putting our website
as mobile only would be really
interesting interesting right whether
I've got the testicles to do that yet I
don't know but I like the idea behind it
I get it I get it yeah it's all good
man are you really good man so you got a
question for
me um I mean I guess one of the things
I've been asking for a little while now
I'm trying to set up another little
thing um which is really trying to uh it
would be selling to the teenage
generation is trying to get English kids
out to an American Summer Camp the
summer camp I used to work with years
ago okay and I think there's a real
market for that but it's how you
actually um Pitch to that P specific age
group via social media like that you
know 14 to to 16 year old age group the
ethics behind trying to Market to that
age group as well without you know
trying to ramp too much stuff down their
throat and the right Market I think I
think it's an Instagram Snapchat World
Greg even in the UK Market obviously
we're opening a London office soon um I
don't know if you've heard but I'm
excited about that I I offered up my
services to you I said if you need any
help setting up you give me a shout
thank you I'm going to bring on Eric
full wire who's running the London
office at some point today so make sure
hopefully you can stick around and uh
say hey and I'll put you guys in touch
send me an email at Gary of Vayner media
um yeah look I think it's an Instagram
Snapchat world and you just you just put
out the content there they're going to
find it because um they're going to find
it because that's where they live and so
I think that you need to figure out how
to story tell authentically not by
putting Flyers you know like the Super
Eight Flyers that I put up on Instagram
for this those were hardcore right hooks
on Instagram just for this but that is
not my normal go-to move that is not my
jabbing that is not my whole thing so I
really highly recommend that you uh that
you find a way to produce content that
is interesting to 14 to 16-year-old that
entices them especially through video
form like really the way to market the
camp is really to collect an enormous
amount of content this year in
microbytes and use that as marketing
material going into 17
season sure yeah absolutely no that's
good advice I like that well good man
you know we're doing Vayner world in in
London I don't know if uh I'm I'm
already signed up I was um I reached out
to Raj about trying to look at some
sponsorship on it I don't know if it's
speaking to them my market person I
don't know if it's quite where we should
be with it I'm going to be there mate
I'll see you again I can't wait to high
five brother thanks for being on the
show this is fun thank you thank you
thank you so much all right here's
Facebook I'm a little crooked but I will
fix that to the best of my ability Mir
see Periscope talk to me agreed
landscape I don't know what Richard's
I'm just jumping into random
conversations Cameo me I got him Matty
crane we'll get you in in a minute good
to see you mircat uh landscape turn
camera oh they want to go land with the
camera like that way right put Dan on
the screen what's that you're put Drew
oh Drew L my man I need he's looking for
something uh when are you in London guys
in Facebook live lot of questions coming
through would love your help answering
some of these questions do we have Brit
or Garrett or Alex D Simone actually may
be answering questions on Facebook live
Drew check your audio something weird is
going on I'd love to answer there's so
many questions going on on Facebook live
uh Gary back us up too close all right
cool back you up a little is it working
yeah you're working you're good
brother um hey what's going on uh things
are good brother it's good to see you
cool ceiling that's funny I had a quick
question um let's fix this my chamber
chamber of commerce is doing a annual
Summit thing they do and this year's um
theme is digital Market Drew before you
go anywhere I love Drew before you go
anywhere I love what you're doing with
the hair these days brother
man yeah I like it yeah super cool so
the theme of the whole Summit is digital
marketing hold on hold on hold on Drew
Zach that Eric oh that was Eric again
Eric now what every time a super eight
comes in you're G to come in and throw
some in there yeah someone's gonna come
in and throw some in there it's so fun
yeah hold on I'm very excited about this
hold on I'm going to stop it right now
now look at Zach's face look at this
face look at this put him right like he
really he really wants receipts like
he's just sitting there all all by
himself doing nothing true like normal
right and he just wants some eight
receipt you know 16 16 books would be
phenomenal for him because then he could
print it twice he could bring it in here
uh we are doing an absolute Telethon
today eight books buy eight books on
Amazon or Barnes & Nobles right now send
in the receipt to Super8 vainer
media.com we will print it we will throw
it in a bucket one of you will fly and
meet me somewhere in the world
when I pull the name out one hour with
me anywhere in the world ask me anything
we will break down your business we'll
hang out we'll play books Heart Link
Laura thank you so much for sharing the
address who's in I mean uh like I want a
massive Collective peer pressure on spre
cast mircat Facebook live and Periscope
I want massive peer pressure peer
pressure Le we've never seen before kind
of like that first party you went to in
junior high when you were scared to
drink beer or
kiss I was scared to
kiss you think that's funny yeah it's
just a funny way to say it I was glad I
didn't play that last game in basketball
even though I thought I was getting peer
pressured by I was peer pressuring you
to play you're like a broken ankle this
morning I'm like just play it's bad yeah
try to make him play all right do it
people it's worth it Jacob's right plus
there's got to be seven people that you
can help in the world
Drew your patience has been incredible
thank you for allowing me to rant
fireway brother just want to let you
know Drew before you go anywhere we are
now fully 33 minutes in which means we
have 7 hours and 27 minutes of live
streaming to go
true are you ready like you would not
believe cool so like I said my Chamber
of Commerce is doing Drew hold on one
second I just thought Drew I'm sorry I
apologize guys I'm the worst Periscope I
don't like the number I don't like the
number everybody on Periscope right now
share it up I want to see 442 people
share it up I don't like the number
share it up a audiobooks is fine share
it up share it up there we go alarm fam
share it up hard it up share it up share
share share share I want to
share
share Drew share yes share now
Drew let's go got you let's go
Drew okay sorry hey uh so my local
Chamber of Commerce is doing their
Summit and it's over digital marketing
and they've asked me to do the keynote
so I'm really excited about it you know
for our small business local agency it's
a pretty big deal um but they have a lot
of sponsors that are in the traditional
media world so newspapers sponsor of the
Chamber of Commerce Radio sponsors of
the Chambers of Commerce how can I fully
Tout The Power of digital and social
without really talking poorly about
traditional because they've told me not
to because they have sponsors in that
area lesson number one drew the truth is
always undefeated if you believe that
newspaper and radio is dead or is in
trouble you need to say it and if you
never get invited again then so be it
and you should forewarn them you should
never ever ever do a speech where you
can't share what you actually want to
talk about now you may want to just
focus on the positives of Social and not
reference radio print and things that
nature but I know you've been following
me a long time and you know that's a
very important context point to have the
real business conversation so I would
respectfully go ahead our whole business
really what we're going with lately is
the whole idea that you have you know
that you've inspired in a lot of people
is just mark it in the year that we're
living it so we're really just latching
on to that statement and to do that and
to do that for our clients and hopefully
people that you know might become our
clients from this event you can't really
do that and then talk well about those
mediums so it's really it's just an
interesting thing and like I'm in a
pretty smaller Community right so you're
worried to become the bad guy in town
right in a way I kind of already have
because you know I'm the only agency
marketing company in my town my city
that's doing what I'm doing so it's kind
of like 80 verse one right now you know
there's like 80 sales reps for the
newspapers go out there and then there's
Drew larrison with the larrison company
touting the digital who Garrett hold up
Drew I'm sorry you screwed up Garrett
when we drop things in the bucket we
need to make a huge deal about it it
needs to inspire the others that are
holding out and breaking my heart how
many no don't ask them how many cuz I
don't even want to know now Andy all I
know is that I lost out on a good moment
a real happy moment and it's all Garrett
green at Garrett Green's
fault you took away my happiness Garrett
and that's it you took my [__]
happiness away get out out of here where
it go so
pissed a hand I don't saan don't don't
end up in Garrett category Drew Drew
here's the bottom line 80 to one 80 to1
forget 80 to one go you know 8,000 one
being historically correct is the only
thing now have your facts don't
regurgitate my quotes don't regurgitate
other quotes know what you're talking
about but listen as ask the qu you know
how I like to roll in the Keynotes ask
the questions ask that audience how many
of them are reading the newspaper ask
how many of them are listening to the
radio now they're asking you not to do
that you don't want to be disrespectful
you're a good kid but you should call
them and say look for me not to
reference this in my talk you're
censoring me and you tell them that my
buddy Gary and his family left Russia
because censoring is
bad yeah
yeah I mean cuz like I said it's tough
because don't tough me I I no I mean
it's tough because I don't want to be
looked at as like the jerk what are you
worried about somebody's gonna throw
milkshake at you at
friendlies maybe maybe but you're tough
Drew I've seen you I think you can
fight do you want me to send do you want
me to send muscle mik to
you I'd love that
Mike Mike you're going on a trip
true listen I look listen without we're
having a little fun now cuz I'm in a
good mood because I've got you know I've
got 7 hours and 22 minutes more of
streaming I really really really think
that you should call them and say listen
I'm uncomfortable with not tell talking
what I truly believe in my heart can you
give me a little air cover I'm not going
to you're not going to say the things
that I say that like [__] radio you know
you're going to do it your way and I
think that you should ask for some air
cover they should know where your heart
lies yeah you know and even like just
letting you know a preface at the
beginning of the talk hey this isn't
what the Chamber of Commerce May
believes but this is what we believe
yeah exactly know the type of and be
like look I know I'm an yeah that's
right I'm on an island by myself respect
but this is truly in my
heart yeah all right love you brother
good to see you
Periscope your sharing capabilities are
limited Facebook live good to see you hi
Jordan do a panel Doug we can do
multiple people drew this is an awkward
scene I Drew I said goodbye I love him
he's my man and we gave him good advice
there we go thank
you um other question I want to hear it
coming from you sorry Gary I have no
friends Seth you're my
friend right yeah I want to hear you
India okay yeah this guy mirat what's up
539 nice what he can't be on screen
because he's at work he's can't be on
screen because he's at work respect but
um his question is I would like to hear
about your very first big account at V
media when you were just
starting what's that Tyler Tyler did
Tyler buy eight
bucks probably well that's not the right
answer India is it ask yeah ask him if
you want 16 and if you bought eight ask
them to buy 16 and ask the really sweet
way I just said that you buy that didn't
sound super sweet can't you say like
please sweet do you not consider
yourself sweet not really do you like do
you have pride in like being kind of
like snark no it's just how I am just
deep down you're not a sweet person I
mean who do you think the sweetest is in
our team
oh it's like it's you think right yeah
down Alex you think Alex I would say
sweetex what do you think an he says
he's going to buy eight books right now
and and sending the receipt to super
eight and send the receipt to Super
Eight what do you think uh
Andy Alex is the most proper he's notet
why didn't I get any votes I find like
I'm pretty sweet I thought you not
including you did we were the same color
again
Jesus Christ start texting you so
weird did did you even Stefan I feel
like you didn't even consider me for the
most sweet I thought you me outside of
yourself all right thank you all right
he said his receipt thank you Ty guy our
first there's a couple different ways
that AJ can come here and cl uh campaign
very early on before we even started the
company AJ was still in college this is
a great story AJ and I went to Vegas to
do a Gillette activation we did a little
social it was like a live event it went
really well but we had nothing to do
we're like this is going to be free
money this is easy industry we loved it
we got paid a lot of money we we don't
feel like we had to do that much we
stayed at the pal in Vegas and Travis
Calin the CEO of uber who's now worth
like8 billion at the time was just doing
Angel investment and was my good buddy
he flew in to Vegas flew
in and Andy and I think you're going to
want to hear this so while you're
working on your thing he flew
in and we watched Antique Road
Show in the hotel room for like 4 hours
guessing how much the merchandise was
and competing AJ and I because of our
extensive garage sailing capabilities
were dominant Travis was lost there'd be
like a rug he'd be like 20 bucks he'd be
like 40,000 there'd be like a spoon he'd
be like 50,000 it'd be like four bucks
he was lost stunned by AJ and I's
amazing ability to diagnose trash yeah
it's really funny anyway uh so Gillette
was our first thing our first big ones
our first big one was Pepsi Bon and ba
big executive now at mandes came to me
after a speech he goes look I've been
following your stuff I think we should
do some stuff we we got together and we
did a huge huge deal for us at the time
which was a million dollar deal that was
like and we did a bunch of stuff on
brisk 11 days after Instagram came out
AJ put together a deal for Instagram and
brisk to work together we had a Brisk a
Brisk can at South by four months after
they came out and it was incredible and
it was a lot of fun and and it kind of
got us on our way um and that's kind of
what
happened what is his net worth I wonder
if they're asking me about my net worth
I like this question about net worth
because because there's that website
that says it's 10 million which is funny
it's of your top search results yeah it
is one of my top search results I mean
look I'm I'm comfortable talking about
my net worth right I you know got the
only interview that ever went there was
Kane yeah Kane went there and said how
much am I going to make this year yeah
you know and a lot of people ask me
about net worth because a lot of other
people run around you know talking about
their net worth and people trying to
quantify let me let me let me make this
statement anybody you compare me to it's
net worth outside of five or six people
that own massive companies like uber and
Facebook I feel very confident that I'm
going to win that game in a lifetime
game that's number one um but I'm really
sad for a lot of people that think my
net worth is $10 million when they see
that result from a site that put that up
like 15 years ago because it just means
you're stupid and really there's no
other thing to say I mean it just means
you're not smart um I mean I don't I
don't know how I don't know uh I don't
know how to quantify that for everybody
you know I don't want to be mean um but
you know it is what it is so anyway
um questions let's go get get somebody
on the screen here's Kyle Kyle oh like
Kyle's beard yes
sir thank you thanks for doing this I'm
excited to be with you all day today
thank you brother thanks for getting
cozy your ass is going to get tired you
gonna get up a couple
times maybe maybe to make some coffee
we'll see cool man what's cooking I want
to know I want to know first like does
this count as a question on the askar
show
no ah okay fair enough uh my question
for you is this my wife and I um have
started a business two years ago we own
two clothing boutiques tilt they don't
want to have all that and we're getting
some success with the doing well uh and
lately we've been a lot of people have
been kind of hating on us whether it be
some friends some other business owners
kind of saying you guys are working too
much or or when we kind of like Hey
we're not available to hang right now
cuz we're it's 11:00 p.m. or we're still
working and they're kind of like pull us
back I want to know what are they saying
what are they saying what what are they
saying exactly Kyle are they saying like
you've changed or you care about money
too much or or they saying like or they
being more like friends and me like come
on man you can go out this one night
like what how's it really going higher
get something else yeah it's some of
that it it's a lot of it's like business
owners and like the location we are
they're they're kind of upset that we're
like 10 Xing their sales every day okay
so we bring all the traffic and so they
don't like that um and then on top of it
like some of the friends are like hey
can you guys hang out and we're like no
and they kind of are like you know you
guys are working too much really and so
it's just weird cuz like they it's cool
like I would love to hang out with them
and I get it they want to grab coffee or
drinks but right now like this is our
child this is our friend this is
everything we're doing is this and so
I'm just curious like have you ever
experienced that life how did you how
did you handle that did I ever
experience it it's my entire life like
you know and I started for me at 14 and
it started with me on any random Summer
Weekend day sophomore year of high
school let alone when I was a grown ass
man um I handled it really simply which
was I have massive empathy for my
friends and I'm flattered that they want
to spend time with me and it made me
love them even more but it didn't deter
me from what my focus was on what made
me the
happiest it you know it makes me happy
to build things it makes me happy to
build my businesses it's made me happy
to work hard um and so I can't change
that and uh and I communicated with them
the Garrett van fleets and the T Adam
blums and the Joe minawa these people
that are super dear and near to my heart
they they accepted it they they look
they had other outlets there was other
friends that they could hang out with
and they you know it just became our
relationship and so you know I'm not I
hate when people are like oh they're
just jealous and stuff like that I'm not
worried about jealousy or people jinxing
me like my grandmother used to think or
like all this stuff like it is what it
is man it's life and I would tell you
that if you and your you're so lucky you
have your you know your wife as your
partner and your partner in your
business I I wouldn't get into a cocoon
of me against the world because these
are your friends
right yeah you know you just tell them
like listen man like I I responded the
few times I had to in my life to address
it was with just other like literally
love I was like listen I am so thankful
that you want to hang with me I'm so
sorry that I'm in this place but I can't
get out of this place in the same way
that somebody's an alcoholic or a drug
addict or you know lazy 247 like I need
this it's my oxygen and this is where
I'm at right now and you know look I
mean at the same
token listen nobody hustles harder than
me Kyle you can find time if you want
but you probably just want to sleep
right you're tired like you know but you
know you know invite them to your house
have some coffee you know I don't know
like like what I would
say oh I was just saying that's what we
we try to do like Sunday brunches like
try to fit them in when we're kind of
chilling for the day but uh but most of
the time yeah they they don't understand
and it's hard to explain um but we're
very focused I would I I would just tell
you and I I would tell all of you I
would tell all of you please you know I
talked about it literally in yesterday's
Daily V don't try to tell them how to
live their lives don't try to think just
cuz it's going well for you right now in
your business that you're better don't
try to make it that we're better and
they don't get it you know make it about
look we're on we're doing different
things right now we're equals and you
know what's so funny I roll with so much
a and ego but the scary thing that I
think a lot of people if they didn't
really know me would be blown away with
is I don't think I'm better than anybody
man I really don't I really don't you
know or I'm pulling so hard from both
directions I think I'm better than
everybody and I don't think up better
than anybody I think it's very important
that you stay confident with a good dose
of humility and empathy for what your
friends are dealing with you're they're
your FR how long have you been in this
hustle
Zone uh for what the business for two
and a half years right they hung out
with you three years ago they remember
when you weren't in this hustle Zone
they liked when you drank beer with them
at six o'clock in the afternoon on a
Thursday they missed that yeah Miss yeah
it's true you're their friend Kyle well
I appreciate it yeah my wife yeah my
wife is a little more empathetic than I
am I'm a little more like screw them
let's let's just keep working but it's
good I'm I do I am glad I have her as a
partner so that does definitely help but
awesome brother good luck to
you thanks you're welcome Kyle that was
fun that was an interesting kind of
thing all right what's going on
Periscope how are you I can finally say
something here yes you can Sharie comedy
TV tag or trade Mo Wilkerson I think we
that's a tough one CU I want to see what
happens with snacks Damen Harrison we
got to figure out those two guys it's
tough our D Line's the only thing we got
and we got to really really figure it
out so [__] awesome thank you bless
future all right what's going on
Facebook live I I need to see some more
action in these comments I need it and
everybody Periscope Facebook live mircat
let's get over to Super Eight the live
stream I've up where my super eight
[__] receipts they're not coming in
right how many how many you think are
over there how many have come in the
last couple of
minutes can you yes thank you Barn &
Noble sold out Barnes & Noble sold out
wow sign books lookn Blake is a good
looking dude and he and he he's on here
because he said he bought 16 books 16
books for Blake 16 books Andy I like
your style you're putting you're giving
people exposure that are buying a lot of
books that's the game right yeah I
really like your business
savvy
India who do you think has the best hair
in our group besides
you besides me Ro right dck dck right
Andrew Andrew yeah Andrew has nice hair
why does Andrew win everything and I
don't even why does Andrew win
everything and I don't even remember
he's on our
team big deal what's going on hey
friends Doo take a seat oh no y Dio
Blake I'm sorry give me a few minutes
hey Blake good news is you look great
still Dio get in here get over here this
is nickd tell everybody who you are I'm
we're you know listen you've been
crushing it on Tinder yeah no that's not
true yes it is no no no no no that's not
true I'm serious you're not crushing I
gave up Tinder uh
December
2014 now how would you say your Tinder
career went oh it was miserable really
yeah you know what you know you have a
bad personality no no no I had a great
personality I just I didn't enjoy
hooking up the the
superficialness that was the most PR all
right d That's you're out that was this
is all that authenticity that opening
line you're out that was ludicrous that
was such such [__] literally I feel
like I'm covered in
[__]
please please I'm so sad I hated hooking
up just for no reason Blake as a
good-looking dude that's hooked up like
you didn't believe a word he said
right oh I can't really say one thing
about that
man all right Blake what do you got man
what's your
question he man um yeah I uh my question
was how do you figure out your strengths
um what your strengths are and how to
sort of follow your passion in
Dominator um two things real quick
somebody check Facebook live it doesn't
seem like there's been an update on the
chat in a while it seems like it's live
but an hour the chat oh it cuts looks
like it's right it's working yeah okay
good great so I don't know what so
Facebook live questions I um Blake I
this is a very tough question I think
finding your strengths is difficult um I
I think there's a couple different
things you can do number one this is
weird as [__] I've been thinking about
this lately India pay attention um I
actually think more people need to try
more
things about 400 in the last 40 minutes
400 books or 400
receipts I'll take it though that's
pretty good I'm excited about that it's
not bad um Blake I think people have to
try more things for example I would tell
you if you really backed me into the
corner Blake and said what do you best
at Gary it'd be difficult for me to
admit this cuz it doesn't make me happy
cuz I fancy myself as a great business
operator I fancy myself as a lot of
things but the truth of the matter is
the thing that I might be best at are
you seeing me Blake I know you froze for
a second and I see your F you hear me
yeah keeping yeah but you're good you're
better um if you push me into the corner
and asked me what am I best at I would
sadly probably admit that it's public
speaking something that I
didn't even do until I was 31 years old
right so I I would tell you number one
try more things if you don't feel like
you found your groove to me it's all
upside you got to keep trying new things
to figure out what you're good at things
that you've never done before keep
hustling keep hustling try new things
number two asking the people around you
Blake I think one of the most
interesting things is can you talk to
the 10 people closest to you make them
feel comfortable to tell you the truth
that's the key it's on you Blake to tell
them listen tell me what you think I'm
best at and worst at because you're
trying to build you know one of the
things that a lot of people need to hear
that are watching right now is actually
what you're bad at because you continue
to try to be good at it because you want
to be a good singer you want to be a
good model you want to be a good
entrepreneur you want to be a good
growth hacker so I think most people
don't try enough different things to
stumble on what they're actually good at
because they think at 20 30 40 50 or 60
years old it's too late it's just not
it's just not and number two I think
they don't give up on things that
they're bad at too soon soon enough
excuse me and I think one of the reasons
we do is we hear about people saying
don't ever give up keep trying I [__]
gave up on school when I was a 13 12 11
year old kid even though the whole world
told me to keep going I just knew I just
knew I just knew and so I actually think
giving up on things cutting bait to give
you more time to do other things is
actually quite important I think some
people do give up too soon because they
don't have intestinal fortitude and they
haven't given enough patience and I
can't I need every single example to
figure out if it's true or not but I'm
very very focused on this issue Blake I
truly believe it's the biggest unlock
it's the number one thing that I want to
drive home to people that are watching
your strengths are
absolutely the quickest path to a
happier life because you're putting
yourself in the best position to succeed
in your craft which either is
financially rewarding mentally rewarding
uh emotionally rewarding and that makes
you just a very happy person there's a
ton of it's not about the money you know
it's not about the money it's about how
good you feel and when you put yourself
in that position um you win and so try
more things Blake and have more honest
conversations with your inner
circle man you got a that's the biggest
thing is like yeah always focused on
like the value you give back to everyone
and then the dollars are just going to
come anyway so as long as whatever
you're doing some sort of value you push
back like it's it's just so true I mean
value is what people need to you know
it's just so true man so listen thanks
for watching thanks for
listening appreciate it awesome question
from did we send an email to the VIP
list that we're on yeah let's do that
let's blast that out let's send a link
to all the above can you do that Bayer
what's up OA thank you tension
Fitness Wide Awake International Big Ups
Richard OT thank you Che 1974 thank you
for the share what up Matty Wright
Sergio Lee thank you for sharing it on
Facebook they don't want us to succeed
what's going on with DJ khed at these
moments I'm curious what how the
momentum is on that Brandon raw good to
see you Blake thank you for having me on
throw somebody back up Mir cat I haven't
given you enough love thank you quote
Gary VE for putting this Super8 Vayner
media I'm going to take a step back
actually before we throw somebody up on
the screen what are we doing here should
we give something
away you every hour I don't know I don't
know if I'm gonna be like that like
here's what's up about what we're doing
we should talk about what we're doing
because I want to sell some books and I
want to answer some questions and I want
to hang out and that's the key Facebook
live listen to me here's what we're
doing we are doing a giveaway buy eight
books send in receipt to Super Eight
this is a receipt from Amazon or bonds
or& Nobles buy eight books send them in
reprint them if you buy 16 we'll print
it twice we throw in this bucket oh that
hurt we threw in this
bucket and one grand prize winner today
I will fly in this is now worldwide I've
changed the rules originally it was us
only then it was North America only then
it was Europe now it is worldwide if
you're in the Asia kind of area
Australia I me it's probably send you
Australia
uh maybe
La I am in Hawaii for five hours
randomly in a layover so if somebody in
Hawaii wins uh maybe I'll fly you to
Hawaii that' be really cool um so Iraq
absolutely all of it worldwide Pitbull
[__] you know so so sending your
receipts Super8 Vayner media.com
everybody in every chat spre cast mircat
Facebook Periscope please put Super8
vainer media.com right now please email
your lists share on your social get
people on these streams we are now
exactly one hour in
seven seven hours to go of
this neim get in here
yes give me this Nim hello hello please
take a seat hello dear yep get in here
we're going to get you on screen
um why don't you tell everybody who you
are how long you've been here maybe one
funny random Vayner media story um I'm n
my account manager I've been here four
and a half years and a funny story is
when I told Gary that I love to gamble
what happened he sent me to
Vegas it's true it's true I love you
nean thanks everything going well yes
cool you excited that you were on the
pumped thrilled pumped are you hoping
like your uncle's watching this and he's
G like yeah I kind of I know are you
busy kind of yes what's going on gotta
jump on a call client yes all right you
better go bye see you have a great day
you too guys this is what I'm telling
you I randomly sent NM to Vegas cuz I
was excited that she loved the gamble
you don't think I'm going to pull your
name out of here and give you something
crazy like you don't think I mean you
don't think Super Bowl next year tickets
is a possibility you don't think it
could be anything but you don't think a
date with Andy K the guru you don't
think you don't think painting with
India I don't
paint I fully believe that India paints
it's unbelievable India you don't paint
no why do I believe that I don't know
may it's cuz like that's what art is and
your
head like uh want take a question for
hold on real quick Selina uh is yelling
at somebody who said a phony you can do
it wow look what's going on here this is
unbelievable people are making signs be
sure to stretch oh me right all
right uh somebody somebody must have
said I'm a phony or what have you and I
just want you to know thank you for
defending me but respect I understand
how people have F negative First
Impressions at first but we will win
them all over in a 60-year period one by
one by one by one because the truth is
undefeated it's just the truth it's just
the way it is right Chicago a wiser
woman tension Fitness is blasting his
URL on the Periscope I wonder if that's
working uh Oto I will do a sh a show uh
shirtless at some point it's coming
together but we're just not there yet
just a little more to go right here just
a little more to go but it's getting
better I mean it's starting to re I mean
guys it's starting to really telling you
super into
myself all right let's get somebody on
the screen Super8 at Vayner
media.com sending your receipts eight
gets you one entry 16 gets you two 24
gets you three 32 get you four who's up
for 40 bucks like actually you know what
I'm going to call somebody I'm going to
call somebody go talk to Super8 vainer
media.com people I want to make a phone
call next person to buy 40 books send in
receipt I'll actually yeah 40 books send
in the receipt 40 books send an receipt
it's five entries into here and if you
buy eight the funky fairy is sharing it
Dublin is happening on March 21st what
company do you suggest to build my app
uh a wiser woman you can send me an
email at Gary ater media.com I will help
you with that Lenny did do that he did I
like it funky fairy she's the best new
industry of old white dudes to upset
commercial real estate in Westchester
New York I like that want to try to get
David W on David might not be
on David's not working let's get some I
just texted get somebody else on whiffle
ball bats oh I did that on Snapchat that
was funny what if you can't afford the
books ow a lease then you shouldn't buy
them like I get it and um book comes out
March 8th uh I have no interest in
anybody stretching themselves please do
not stretch yourself financially um that
is not a good idea somebody's watching
it on every platform that's unbelievable
send me that picture sign copies on
Barnes & nobl are sold
out um you can afford the book it will
make you money it will for some people
definitely will oh Maddie crane eight
books he bought eight books crane man I
appreciate the eight books brother who
are you giving the other seven away to
oh I put someone on screen too oh good
David's joining us
listen I'm giving uh I'm giving one to
my older sister what's her name her name
is Paige Barnes she just completed her
Ms in nursing and uh she's buried into
debt and I want her to read while that
was a dumbass idea okay she got her so
we're sticking at the page understood
yeah I wanted to understand why my baby
brother actually has some sense and went
the entrepreneurial route not the
bureaucratic route Matt do we think that
Paige is disrespectful to
Matt um I think she looked down on Matt
because she was the older sister and had
her life together at five but I also
think that um she appreciates the fact
that big brother knew what he was doing
and uh he chose hustle over the dollar
bill and I think that when she asked me
for advice today she knows that it comes
from a place of the fact that I had to
struggle in order to bust a bubble so
while I'm joking about it she's my best
friend and she's been my biggest
supporter but also think that if you
really want to uh show people respect
for where you made it you got to give it
back to them in ways that they didn't
think was possible so this book for me
is emotional because um I'm the only boy
in my whole family and so you know I was
always told D to get a 40 hour work week
job and getting emotional think about it
but um you know for me to be able to
give that back to her and show her that
um that it's okay to uh to struggle it's
okay to go for your goals and not be
told that you got to get the the
six-figure job I think she'll appreciate
that she'll be better in the long run so
for me to be able to be in this position
cuz [__] man when I started this journey
I had $27 in my bank
and I was worried about that being
overdrawn so um this is very important
for me and uh very powerful thank you
brother where are you
from I'm from uh Tennessee palaski
Tennessee I'm calling you from my my
corporate office in mboro and uh this
right here is why I do what I do man I
love it who's this you say hi to Gary V
camera's not working hey my name's Riley
hey
Riley believe it or not he'll have the
first signed copy in his room so when he
gets to the point where he can read it
man that's that's what it's all about
does Riley like
football yes he he actually does he
actually will be playing football for
the first year and it'll be uh uh
notepad but now his 5-year-old you'll
really appreciate because his 5-year-old
will run through a brick wall let me
talk to Riley for a second
Matt hey Riley got Gary Vayner Chu no
idea how big
put the game there hey Riley I know you
want the game but I got something to say
Riley this is important you ready thank
you for the wave you're adorable Riley
this is very important Riley I want you
to be a New York Jets fan do you
understand do you want to be a Jets
fan say yes sir I love
it such a for the record that's such a
low blow I appreciate
that but my question you first of all
thank hey Matt real quick real quick
Matt real quick there's something going
on with the audio it's gotten a little
bit worse I've been trying to fight
through it
but me now I
can do you have
headphones yeah I'll throw some
headphones I'm not going
anywhere you'll be fine
um knit him a jet sweater Fox my mom
does the knitting around
here yo bless the future good to see you
tried Facebook live now Periscope what's
going on Judy with Facebook live is it
going all right can you guys hear oh
you're way better Maddie this should be
a good lesson for everybody on spree
cast more headphones here we go go ahead
Maddie so first of thank you for taking
time Gary um you're just a true freaking
uh social media philanthropist but my
question is I was reading an article I
was reading an article in Fast Company
about next Netscape
and how they were so fast and how that's
what really catapulted them to success
but I wanted to know from you what's
really important you hear all these
great people talk about speed speed
speed I love speed I love
speed and less on agility so what's
really Matt Matt it means the same thing
you can't be fast without being agile
right people are using it
interchangeable you know semantics of
adjectives the bottom line is it's a
mental game of not ex I said this
somewhere how I basically don't even
accept my losses right like my losses
roll off of me in a way that would blow
your mind now in football you know what
little Riley is about to deal with but
being a Jets fan the rest of his life is
a lot of losing right but in business
and so in football it take you know
everybody here knows m i mean Mondays
are weird when the Jets lose right India
they're pretty weird yeah super weird
but in business I could have million
dollar I mean there was a funny scene
there's a funny scene in yesterday's
Daily V Matt you know have all the
context but it's me talking to Ari have
you been watching the daily
V's yes so I'll watch them all the time
you know how there's that guy arri with
the glasses the really Jewish looking
guy he always like Pops in for a minute
and trying to steal my time he's head of
new business and there's a scene between
us where he goes it's weird and I go no
it's not weird it's bad it's because
we're probably not winning this pitch
that I really thought we were going to
win right but it's crazy like like you
know now I have to watch for editing
purposes so it's weird for me to watch
my stuff but I was like looking at
myself and I was like laughing at myself
like my my God I really don't give a
[__] do I like I was kind of like an it
was like an outof Body Experience I'm
like oh my God I really thought we were
going to get this we we could use it I
and we use it not for Revenue because
there's a couple people I'd like to put
on more business and keep them a little
busier right and like but I'm like
laughing about it I'm like smirking I'm
like like I don't know there's something
amazing about how I was wired I love
losing today Andy and I were playing
basketball AJ's team was strong and they
won the first three I loved it I loved
losing those games when we finally I hit
a gamewinner when we finally won it big
shout out to Max bass who had a big
bucket late to tie it that helped us but
when I hit that bucket it's the best
feeling like you know and so agility and
Speed come out of not recognizing and
respecting your
losses got it that's what's slowing
everybody down that is what's slowing
you down that's what's slowing you down
what slowing you down you are giving too
much credit for that [__] L [__] that
L I'm not I'm not even giving you that L
I'm not even giving that to you L I'm
not giving you anything I'm not giving
you the benefit of even recognizing you
not a second Maddie we're going to make
mistakes we're going to make a lot of
them but as long as we make bigger wins
than the mistakes we make we will win
every time it's moving the football
right it's football baby first and 10
lost two yards second and 12 incomplete
third and 12 13 yard pass first [__]
down so would you say would you say that
it's it's safe to say respect the no but
never accept the no right you know
understand why the no happened as
context so you don't get a bunch of
NOS but don't give it respect you know
like don't give it don't give it to them
I'll never give it to them I'll never
give it to anybody
I have empathy for it I understand why
it's happening I understand why people
might think that when I have a guest on
like I did yesterday I might talk too
much and not give my my guest time to
breathe you know and it doesn't make it
fun I may respect why people if I curse
you know like I'm cursing you got the
three little guy there like you know I
respect it oh you got the headphones
nice I respect it I understand it but
I'm not giving it to them do you know
what I mean I know exactly who I am I
know exactly where I'm going and it
allows me to go whip fast ripping fast
look you saw in episode 13 14 15 I've
struggled with some of the fans not
getting me fully I I can internalize it
I'm human but losses are
not the fundamental truth of the matter
is guys right now is we are absolutely
acknowledging and respecting losses way
too much and it's slowing Us Down Speed
matters Matty C just go just go now the
reason you have to understand them is if
you make too many losses in a row you
know you're gonna be out of
business so you got you got to you got
to understand them but not respect them
I appreciate you brother thank you for
sharing that deep story thank you for
buying eight books I'm excited that the
CIS is getting one I hope Riley gets
he's getting the first one I love that
uh because every time I get a note I
always go and try to sign two more
people up and I actually will send
engagement thank you cards back to those
people that say no% call me eventually
when they realized they made a huge
mistake so I love it man great attitude
I appreciate you how close are you to
Chattanooga uh two hours good I'm going
to be in I'm definitely going to do an
event in maybe April or May for the book
in Chattanooga I fully expect you to be
there I'll be there and I'll bring Riley
so uh in his jet Jersey for you I'll
bring the jet Jersey I'll see you later
take care that's awesome all right I
exed him out that was a lot of fun nice
guy more people yeah let's do more
people but I want to give little give me
a few minutes before I feel the pressure
of somebody on screen let me say hello
to Periscope first as we are now and oh
oh what is that 40s 40 bucks tallest
person wow also this kid just got
detention in class for watching the
live I so the next call bought 40 books
or he just got the tension of class and
you want me to call him he proved it he
sent me the he literally got the tension
today in school for watching this
in okay hold on okay this of AC this is
action oh my God
yeah this is so good I love this this is
Garrett you're redeeming yourself thank
goodness oh my God yes just smell it
smell the value
exchange just smell smell the value
exchange I do good they repay we all win
and we dominate everybody
boom you know what this one's
interesting to me who wants to see who
wants to see what this one is do you
want it do you want it do you want it do
you want it let me see the yeah let me
see give me give me give give me give me
give me the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah give me the
yeses mirat don't slow me down give me
the yeses let's go all right we're going
to do something with this
one we are going to
buy every one of my
shirts that I'm selling right now on Tu
how many are there
India Shir yes look at you go fast I
love when you go fast
fast I'm starting to by the way I'm only
an hour and 17 minutes in and the
crescendo is building friends if you
want to see a human
explode I highly recommend to tell your
friends to get on this right now big
shout out to Mike vcan uh get on there
right now get them on here right now 17
different 17 different shirts
this person is getting one of every
shirt that I have on tuu right yeah can
we put the link on spree cast can
everybody find this just go to tubl
somebody Google in all these chats tubl
Gary B putting it on the screen you're
putting on the screen I see it right up
here Andy above the receipts and
everything that's the current topic very
big spring cast if you're watching by
the way Periscope Facebook live
especially Facebook live mircat get over
to spree cast the link is on my Twitter
right now 17 shirts 17 Chef Lizette
wants it bad and she will have them all
she have the full tubl the link is up
there teepublic.com
user
garve 17 t-shirts all of them Andy give
me a couple of kind of t-shirts give
mear uar U is Big the Almond the one the
AL the one alond that was a class start
investing ideas are [__] the grind
includes Friday leg is greater than
currency what's the RO Legacy Roi of
your mother
penguin just be the give me that give me
that give me that give me that give me
that look at these shirts look at these
shirts look at these shirts you want it
you want these 17 here we go and the
winner
is David W teen t n I'm based in
Singapore [__] that shipping's going to
kill
me David you're about to dominate India
you're happy that I got screwed no I
love surprises all right all right big
shout out to David is David in here is
David in here let's go David Teen Ti
en a beast 17 t-shirts Singapore
Singapore there you go thank
you let's go congrats David hilarious I
Andy I do think we should start Facebook
live again there hasn't been a chat in
my app we'll stop it uh I'll give it to
you I sent out you just did it okay
there you go why you do that and then
we'll start another one um congrats to
David David won Gary zero is Right India
you can throw somebody on the screencast
castcast castcast on screen go ahead
from now why can't Lou be on screen he's
at work he's at work okay um we talk a
lot about HR and creating good company
culture would you ever consider writing
a book book about company
culture yes I would and the book that I
it's what you know I kind of haven't uh
also he bought books Bermuda eight
amazing Bermuda Big Ups uh Gary stay
away from they they I got to figure out
what that means um I uh screencast
quality is brutal really so right to me
love you love you back woohoo I got in
Gary yes you did
uh it's called the human Empire it's a
book that I'll write probably in my 50s
or 60s about how I built Vayner media
into a billion dollar company on HR and
all the human aspects and things of that
nature I'm very excited about a Facebook
live welcome back Facebook live welcome
back Facebook live welcome back
um and so yes I will I will do that uh
I'm excited about it I'm back Daniel t
uh Big Ups UK so it's called the human
Empire it's going to be very detailed
it's going to be my 40-year run as a HR
driven
CEO um and I'm very excited to write it
but there's a lot of lot of work to do
and a lot of other I might actually even
have a co-author on it and more on that
to
come um yes I'm back Ramon I want to
give some huge love to Facebook live as
you guys build up uh I left but I had to
come back number one Gary Salvatore
thank you so much question what type of
content to create for a classic watch
company on Snapchat thank you yolina I
think you talk about you start snapping
kind of the the process of fixing some
of these just bought two books Selina
thank you uh I think you take pictures
of some of the classic watches I think
watches is enormous category uh uh and
so I think uh that's the way to go
Facebook live is back Gary good to see
all of you now Facebook live all of you
please hit the share button let's get
the share Buton I want to get explosion
of share buttons on Facebook live don't
[__] with me Facebook live share buttons
big time um Eric I know people were on
but I wasn't seeing uh the comments
which I want because I want to naturally
jump in uh spree cast excuse me that's
spr cast Periscope Periscope this is
very simple yeah look at Brian from I
social fans he knew that I was coming
for the share he went right to
it uh Brandon raw I need the share bless
the future thank you I need the shares
in here not sure how to share on
Facebook live there's just a button down
below share right there's a share button
there I think you guys should see it can
you guys shared oh there somebody said
shared there we go all right niche
market blogs yes into them done thank
you Urban girl go guys I want books
actually you know what here's a good
time oh look at this Timmy Ferris Timmy
Ferris with the uh with the
text excited about that Tim let's hit up
Tim right now say thanks for him uh
thanks for Timmy little Timmy Ferris Tim
Tim just got back from
overseas this Montana thing I
can't make
it this unbelievable jam session Saka
Ferris I can't make it because family
event Family
First Lizzy running the
auction at the school got a support
but I need to talk to Timmy
okay
what I got it uh shared Frank Lopes my
man sold me the Billboards so sad about
the t-shirts Chef lazette wanted it bad
Audi books yes on fire do you prefer
Periscope to Facebook live I like them
all Gary book will be 50 Shades of Gray
of business books I hope so probably
sold the trillion books um India you can
throw somebody on the screen and or you
can oh aren't you asking me a qu did we
oh oh uh oh look there he is my man
what's up Mr Gary what's up brother how
are you congrats on all your success
lately appreciate oh I got to call Todd
Todd you're Todd excuse me one second
Todd number 40 Books thank you so much
and then we got a call attention and we
got to call the kid that then did you
hear this some kid got detention for
watching this
today that's a that's a really dedicated
kid you know where he's going in life
[__] to the
top
all right all right buddy what what do
you got sh I don't think I've ever told
you this story or I told anyone yeah
tell them the pipe down over there no
they're doing a great job tell the team
they're doing a great job I will uh a
big Andy there's a story that nobody's
ever heard before that's about to happen
and I piped the [__] down all right good
[__] all right Benin Gary I and this is
this takes ball to say I hated you for
the longest time I didn't really hate
you I hated your message for the longest
time
and please don't kick me off Andy I'm I
swear going somewhere it wasn't Andy I
was about to kick you off now go ahead
I'm I'm dying I'm dying to hear how you
define that for you and for others I'm
really excited go ahead you know there's
a lot of people that say Hey I I you
know I can't stand the F bombs or the
messes his old hat there's a lot of
haters out there so you get caught up in
that when you're trying to make your way
into any industry
sure get caught up and coming from an
immigrant family my myself where I've
got uncles that are entrepreneurs 35
plus years my father's an entrepreneur
35 plus years uh these are you know the
things that you say coming from Europe
very similar so for me it was like how
is this guy profiting off of what I've
heard my whole life right and so it like
this selfish almost jealousy and then I
realized go I realized oh [__] you know
what this guy is just doing what like my
dad never was able to do talk about
about it damn it actually talk about it
outside the family and you know I'm sure
your dad was very similar where kind of
kept it kept it in the family and so I
love the fact that you have the guts to
just say it the way it is tell everybody
that because everyone needs to hear it
and what I realize is that not everybody
grew up with entrepreneur parents or
immigrant that with immigrant values
that you know you and I did and many
others as well uh so they need to hear
it I'm I'm just glad and I'm happy that
I woke up I finally saw the light you I
appreciate that you know what you
inspired me to say something that I
think is really a good moment to talk
about this V do you know that that the
Steven Rosses you know owner of the
Dolphins my business partner the the
hedge fund guys the Pepsi and GE CEOs
the do you know that the Jack Welsh's do
you know that the 100 to 500 most
successful most serious people that I
know think it's stupid that I have a
public
Persona do you know you know it's funny
you said something interesting you said
you said um he's profiting off of it and
and it's the right thing and I get it do
you know that there's not a single
person in my ecosystem that is worth
hundreds of millions of dollars or more
that thinks what I'm doing for these
seven hours is a good idea you know that
they they would argue with me and they
do all the time that yeah Gary it's it's
nice that you can make a million or $2
million on your personal brand with the
book or a speech here and there but
every time you do that you built vinor
media from a three to a100 million
business which by the way back to net
worth means it's worth $300 million in
the uh you know three times Revenue
marketing agency World you've done that
in lie of the fact that you're out there
a lot you're giv around all this advice
and they they're not listen they're not
going to listen to you anyway cuz
they're going to go and Chase the dream
and so what's really interesting to me
is when people really broke down my [__]
because I'm an operator and not just a
pundit or an
author most of the most educated
business people I know argue with me
that I'm making a massively wrong move
and I would tell you that the reason I
do this is I'm
selfish for the energy that I get out of
admiration love engagement
talk I like people much more than these
other rich people I know
and and and it makes me so sad so sad
that people think that first of all that
Gary v g being being Gary ve is a
fraction of I make more money because of
Wine Library residual checks and because
of Viner media and because of
investing than I do as being Gary Vee
yet Gary Vee takes an enormous amount of
emotional time and effort and overhead
and um and I'm really trying to figure
out how to get people to realize we got
into this great relationship all of us
where I needed you and thus I can bring
value and it's just an interesting the
whole thing's super interesting you
know it's you know and I I fight on a
much lower level than you do but I I
fight it daily with family and friends
they're like what do you do like why do
you care about your personal Like This
Personal Image you put out there why
does it matter you know just put your
head down work in a 9 to-5 you went to
college big mistake
and like why don't you just do that and
it's it's a daily struggle it's every
day telling yourself and listening to
Gary ve watching Gary ve videos just
listening to things over and over uh you
amongst others to just put your head
down and do work and do you know and I
started my own agency a year and a half
ago I decided I finally didn't want to
work for anybody so my question if if
you will take and have time is how do
you how do you take it from that
entrepreneur solopreneur whatever you
want to call it and scale so I have an
opportunity I can't talk about Periscope
I have an opportunity right
now and I I think I'm too small for the
gig and I know that I want to pitch it
anyway but how do you just go ahead put
your head down and and grow from that
like I don't at first I was like I don't
want to P too small so you there's an
opportunity for you that you think
you're too small for but somebody else
thinks that you can
do I mean I was one of the agencies
offer or you know uh sent an RF Fe so
yeah I mean look the first of all you
should definitely do it because there's
nothing better than experience even if
you crash and burn you got the context
right so first and foremost with no
hesitation please make sure you
understand you have to do it it you have
to take the RFP and even if they laugh
you out of the goddamn room and say what
the hell are you thinking kid like this
is a professional company we're a
Fortune 500 company like what are you
thinking first of all I have a funny
feeling that won't happen second of all
I'm telling you right now the the amount
of learnings from that loss not
belonging in the room the the best way
to belong in a room is by first entering
a room that you don't belong
in got it and so you have to do that RFP
you have
to and and that's it so just you just
have to do do [__] you know you got to
do those things and you got to take the
losses like who you protecting your own
feelings you know that you nett it out
Victorious because you
learned I mean I walked you know the
first meeting AJ and I one of the first
pitch meetings AJ and I had we went to
see Stride Gum and we walk in four
Executives walk in and I just start
making ideas up and it goes really well
and we leave and I look at AJ and I go
bro I go how do other companies do
this right because I'm really good on my
feet like I came up with it like how do
other companies I wouldn't stop why
because there no sound I know but that's
probably you're probably G to have that
happen again start up again I don't
think it's sto and start I think it's
like a click or something um and AJ
looks at me laughs at me goes bro what
the hell are you talking about people
prep for these meetings they make decks
they make presentations and I go oh [__]
you know so I I I think style like and
stuff yeah exactly so so I think you go
and do it which just happened here on
the phone Facebook I don't know what the
password is um Facebook stream said yeah
Facebook stream stuff's going on um uh
go and do it don't worry about being in
the room and uh do your
thing you've got momentum going people
people get you a Steelers game by the
way I'll come I think the Jets play the
Steelers in Pittsburgh this year so you
might you might make that happen I I
think they do would be I'll proba you
know what I'm you want a great you want
a great Steelers Story the Jets are
playing the Steelers in the AFC
Championship game right couple years ago
where you guys won 24 242 246 17 or 227
anyway uh it was 24 nothing and then we
scored like 18 19 points in a row what
2419 um
and so we're me and my buddies get
together in a huddle before uh jet games
and and really kind of just get together
and predict the score right and we're in
a huddle and uh somebody jumps in our
huddle and goes [__] you Jeet fans get
the [__] out of here holy [__] Gary ve
I'm a huge fan and my friends were like
what the hell it was crazy and this was
like before I kind of came back back you
know this was 2010 or 11 this was 11
right so I wasn't doing Ask Gary ve I
was kind of really doing vayer I wasn't
getting stopped as much I wasn't out
there as much it was a lot of fun it was
a story we still talk about a lot but I
I hate Pittsburgh because I've lost both
playoff games that I've been there
for well I guarantee you if you go with
me you the Jets will probably win when I
done man thrilled to go with you yeah
listen Gary yes I uh I have to I'm going
to ask this just to ask it yeah cuz I've
asked you on every platform come on your
show you on my podcast at some point yes
it will out there listen it's GNA happen
now did you buy eight
books I will I have five I will I'll buy
more yeah I I want I want 11 more I'll
buy 11 more how's that what 11 11 dude
you're going to leverage my you're going
to get every [__] guest in the game
by me being on this [__]
show of course do you think I'm a
dumbass do you know what you know what
ready for this 19 books Vin or I'm not
coming on I'm looking for the receipt
brother 19 don't buy a [__] juice
cleanse
today the amount of uh the amount of
wins the Jets will have over 19 all
right I got all right brother stay well
take care good to see that was fun
what's that got's attention but he
doesn't look like he's at school right
now I'm going to put on fre period who's
at free period Conor all right give me
give me the number he's right here oh
Conor oh Connor of course Connor got the
this is my man Connor's always I'm
talking I talk to Conor every day Connor
you got detention
today uh hopefully not later I'm kind of
[__] to be honest with you where are
you are you like in your school's
closet no I'm in the main gym right now
I'm like it's dark I'm like the only one
in here because I can't go on it during
class I love it man how you doing
uh I'm doing well uh how are you I'm
doing super well brother I'm doing super
well what can I answer for you so uh my
my biggest thing was how can I go all in
while still being in high school failure
classes like I did Conor Connor here I
tried
and and like I tried so here's a
scenario uh 8th grade suspended from
middle school starting a homework
selling Network and then my dad's an
entrepreneur too he pulled me aside and
he was like listen like can't be stupid
find a legit way to bring value to
businesses I was like all right so I was
really interested in Facebook at the
time you go Facebook marketing you're
you came up you literally started my
first business in a way so I grew a
social media agency to 60 plus small
businesses in the US and Canada and then
from there I was all in on that like I
was hustling my face off right traveling
missing school all that and I got
diagnosed with ADD ADHD dyslexia my
freshman year and then failed my face
off on all my classes and then put me on
medication no no no no no no no that's
bad that's bad that part's bad the
failing was good yeah I listen I my
number one rule in life my number one
rule in life is not
to not to tell people how to parent so I
don't want to cross a line that I'm not
comfortable oh no no my dad was against
it but it was just like listen Connor
like you can't fail out of high school
when in reality like I'm like you and
this is why I resonate so much with you
over anyone else is because like I did
all that like I did memorabilia cards
like and then the eighth grade almost
got suspended like I'm I suck [__] at
school like I have all that and it's
just Connor real quick very important
question you're wearing a tie are you in
a private school
yeah yeah see I mean Public School
wouldn't it suck more because they
wouldn't cater as much to me you know
what I mean yeah of course these goddamn
private schools are we number one on hot
new releases what's our overall rank I
don't know Connor I'm super excited
Connor are you buying books before we
solve your life problems can we solve my
local
problems I bought 16 I love you now how
about like who's the cutest girl in your
high
school uh all gu School
Jesus you should quit school now I'm
just kidding I'm
kidding um Conor
listen Conor listen first and
foremost I'm gonna say something that I
don't want to say and I do want to say
so take it with a grain of salt no
you're are you in sophomore year now are
you in freshman year what's happening
junior junior dude it's just [__] 15
more
months like honestly if you really and
and no joke I'm going to say this
because I've been through it and you
want to resonate with me I'm going to
give you very good advice enjoy the
living crap you you got
friends hell yeah great let me make you
a really good promise I desperately Miss
Kelly Hurley I desperately Miss Garrett
van Fleet I desperately Miss Rob Purdue
and if I had somebody like me and the
internet was around and they told me to
enjoy my last 16 17 18 months with those
guys before I went 24/7 it would have
been good
advice yeah uh well my response to that
would be like I'm 16 like I have like
everything I'm doing has to do with
youth marketing and branding right okay
I've got a leverage of [__] out of my
age my profile my be careful be careful
be careful be careful I know way more
about youth marketing than you do and
I'm old as [__] so you don't have to be
16 to know how to Market to 16 year olds
I agree you could be 18 and a half and
done with school and Mark it to 16year
olds I'm telling you right now if you
follow my [__] you know there's another
thing that contradicts us having our
pants on fire which is patience matters
I'm telling you right to your [__]
face that you just have to be patient
for 15 more months it doesn't mean
anything in a scheme of things you're
going to cross that finish line and I
would instead of looking this as a
negative look at it the way I did and
look at it as your last [__]
vacation yeah yeah I I agree uh and uh
yeah so let me know if uh I'm going to
be your assistant at South by Southwest
cool yeah you by the way done I will you
know I'm in for 5 seconds but I will
100% see you email India vainer
media.com India the person not the
country India vainer media.com and I'll
see you
there hey write that parenting book for
me too I'm definitely gon to write
that okay all right thanks so much K
take care brother my man Connor hiding
in the gym
it's real [__] it's real [__] call your
man uh call my man Todd let's call Todd
that was fun what do you guys think
about that that was cool right Facebook
Live is down
again no it's not it's up tell them
Facebook lags 5 Seconds watch OS much
better lost half viewers of Facebook
yeah cool yeah know we've lost the
viewers and they'll come back what's the
main platform for this Alfie whatever
you want it to be it's me Gary Mr eight
books um very cool it's up Kyle good to
see you Kyle Hower thank you no it's
fine now thank you Michael uh it's
working thank you Michael Hopson we're
good boss thank you
Ramon pis Jr Alex Sparks say we're up
we're calling somebody 50 book 40 bucks
right is that the BS 40 books is the
game now who else bought 40 books nobody
else what is this a zero look at this
380 380
be
Deone all right listen everybody I'm
calling you putting you you're going to
have my number if you ever call me back
or text me or give it away I'll kill you
and 40 books can I use my phone no I'm
okay with it I trust I trust
it go here we
go saw you at TNC thanks Josh working
fine am what's up this is what I love
about Todd not only am I calling him but
yo yo yo yo
Todd what up I'm watching you as
I appreciate Todd first and foremost
congrats on the five entries did you
already do one entry and you like went
up to 48 I no I did I did eight a while
ago like a month ago uhhuh I just did 40
now oh and one sign I just got to get
one sign I appreciate so you're in for
six times on the
raffle sweet that'll do where do you
where do you live I'm in Ames Iowa Iowa
baby I like Iowa a lot you know in
my Iowa State Iowa State baby I was St
[__] me though years ago when they
lost in the first round of the NCAA
tournament I had them going all the way
to the
finals well I'm sorry for that but I'm
here now so everything's good but do you
know what I'm talking about Jamal timley
and and and the Frasier team way back or
you don't know what I'm talking about am
I too old no actually I just moved here
I just relocated got a job all right all
right respect thank you so much for
supporting what can I answer for you
brother hey I got a business that um I
see that be exponentially growth um in
the next couple years um and I'm
wondering where to get where to look for
investor financing or where to kind of
it's an offline business so I just need
some funding to get it the first one
started prove it and then keep on going
from there is there any way to actually
start it and build the Business Without
funding all my money tied up another
business right now and I'm trying to
take money out of it but I'm not going
to have that I don't know if I'll be
able to take that money out can you get
a since it's a non- internet business
can you get a loan here's where I'm
going the number one way to get to raise
money is to have a business that's
starting to
work yeah and and then you have and then
you have enormous
leverage so you know and Hollman law
says debt sucks and I agree debt sucks
but in a market where you know first you
ask everybody you can to borrow money
you know like to invest in your company
so your answer is you ask everybody you
should ask me right now ask me right now
ask Will you invest in my company no but
look I mean boom you asked that's one
down and you keep going you keep going
so I think one of the things you need to
do is find everybody what up Phil uh
Mike Hammer uh I think you ask everybody
you know to uh to invest if they all say
no is how many people built businesses
before if you're good debt is amazing
Deb's tremendous if you can pay it
[__] back Deb's great if you know
what the [__] you're
doing that is correct so yeah I kind of
look that way so yeah the other thing
the other thing the other thing the
other thing that I would say is there's
a lot of Middle
America uh startup business competitions
that you might be able to get
in okay and so look for those kind of
things there's also go fundme there's so
Kickstarter uh how much do you
need uh 100,000 80 to 100 the answer is
that means you need 80 do you know what
I
mean right and probably it probably
means you need
65 I could probably do it on 65 if I
really tried yeah I think you should low
inv listen dude I think what's really
fun and this is where I'm taking you
with this conversation because
everybody's going to learn from it when
you say I could probably do it for 5 I
really try the answer is of course right
like if this is your life you need to
you need to really really try you know
like it listen let me tell you something
super interesting T the other thing to
talk about is you got another business
going on like I always think that people
can live a little bit more humbly if
they want to build something
special right oh absolutely so like the
other
question yeah so I think one of the
other things to talk about is you know
could you do it for 50 could you do it
for 40 could you live in a smaller house
and do it for 20 oh my God boom boom
boom we can do it for nothing I mean
it's a really wild kind of
thing right I don't know something to
think
about yeah no I definitely will um yeah
the other businesses are so cash intense
it's just a lot of capital to keep it
going so if I take 50 out of that the
other is the other business will
definitely suffer for a you know it
could real quick one second Tod Michael
Michael Michael stazi who wrote on
Facebook I hate how everybody agrees
with Gary let me put two things out
there one very few people agree with me
it's just the people that want to jump
on my live stream during this time that
agree with me number two I'm thrilled to
talk about anything that we disagree on
if you want to call in now oh my God
the8 hour balloon thank you come in here
come in here this is very very nice
thank you guys wanted to
thank you guys this is unbelievable an
eight balloon I'm super pumped guys say
hello to everybody tell shout out your
Snapchats and Instagrams and what you do
and like come on let's get in give me
one second Todd I'm a designer amza
that's 3 Z's a mzz z a I'm a copywriter
we're Partners um at tour t o r d e k n
awesome guys thank you so much no
problem are you super excited about this
oh yeah I have it live streaming at my
desk screen wait wait wait does that
mean you're not working no double
okay see you
later thank you guys uh Todd I think I
think you need to hack brother I think
you first of all ask everybody for money
cool they all say no cool then you go to
bank cool no cool then you go more
humble or you don't care about the idea
enough and you don't want to go Rogue
enough and that's cool too you can live
your life the way you want to but that's
those are the answers my
man yeah next question is how do where
do I go to meet you in person um there's
a St Louis event coming up that's not
too far from you um no no it's not uh
there's a Chicago event brewing
potentially uh and Gary veer.com there's
a way for you to go to my.com backevents
gary.com
events right if you go there there's a
way to download this C what's it called
Cal what Cal reply there's an app called
Cal reply big shout out to those guys
that I'm using that uh you could
actually hit and it goes into your
Google calendar and you'll be up to date
everything I'm ever doing publicly going
forward and then you could hack and make
it most affordable or most most
convenient and I'd love to see you man
and you too brother stay well I like
Todd you got someone did they buy 16
bucks I don't know if that's exactly
what they bought yeah I don't think we
put up oh my man Anthony the con I call
them in my head Anthony you don't even
know this I call you the Conch I See You
in My Stream all the time we interact a
bunch I know I've got to do your show or
your blog that will happen but I want
you to know thank you g you're welcome
brother I want you to know that I call
you the
conk thank you that's funny cuz I used
to called that in high school I
appreciate is that because you drilled
people on the football field were you
like kind of like you were like The
Conch exactly Here Comes The Conch here
he is
exactly awesome conch what do you
got I'm good brother well two two things
one is you know when you say I
appreciate you I think people need to
know why you app why I appreciate you
and I appreciate you for your hustle
your content your your authenticity and
all the great things you do and I
appreciate you taking the time to
respond to me personally it means a lot
so I want to say thank you and I
appreciate that thanks brother um I yeah
I I never thought I'd hear the word
machine again as you know I I I
interviewed that guy I don't want to
start promoting but you know I inter and
he's a machine say you are definitely a
machine as well and when I get up in the
morning and and and watch you know watch
my Twitter feed I watch your videos you
know I I feel like all the things you've
done are just so amazing so done because
I don't want to I'm Fanning on you let
me get let me get to the question let's
do it brother thank you so much I think
I think a lot of peoplebook and thank
you so I think a lot of people use the
ter hustle too much because you use it
but you show it so how do I get my my
audience my followers My streamers to
really say hey Anthony he's hustling and
I see it but how do we how do we deliver
that message every day about Hustle by
the way I'm not just saying it here's
how I so I like to get your thoughts on
proving hustle rather than just saying
hustle because you talk about this time
I want to hear your thoughts on it it's
the reason I uh it's the reason I
started
DV there's nothing else to say it's the
best way first I just got to say what's
up to my boy Lorenzo I see him in spr
cast miss you brother good to see you
I'm gonna have zero P breaks Lorenzo
Anthony I think that um I think that the
answer is daily V for me right and I
think Snapchat for a lot of people that
can't afford to pay Rock salary to have
them follow you around all day is the
other answer one of the things I love
about what's happening with me with
daily V if you're not watching please
start watching it
is there's just no way to fake it
there's no way to schedule the Tweet
there's no way to [__] take out the
money in the bank well I guess we could
take out the money in the bank account
and put on the but there's no renting
the cars for [__] Instagram photos
it's like it's just so real like it's
been really fun for me to get the level
of respect that I've gotten from maybe 3
to 7,000 people that have been in my
ecosystem that heard the word I mean
let's call it what it is if you read the
comments and especially in this last one
people are starting to really understand
that like I'm playing a very different
game like a totally totally different
game that by the way is not for all of
you Periscope Facebook live mircat spree
cast it's not for everybody but if you
care about that Anthony you show it you
know some guy said something great in
the comments yesterday he said after you
did The Dr Oz Show I would have and I
work hard I would have celebrated right
I would have said boom this was big you
know Big Show on TV and I would have
been done at 11:00 a.m. and he's like
you just did another freaking 12 hours
of work like no hesitation in and out in
30 minutes boom and and it's true and by
the way Anthony you've heard me say
you've heard this conch you guys have
heard this when I did
Conan and you froze on me Anthony so I'm
going to wait a second see if you come
back Anthony froze let's throw Anthony
back on because I want to make sure he
hears this can we have two you have
Stephen on who I love but let's get
conch back on real quick cool I just Ted
him out let's get him try to get back
Stephen good to see you man you're
looking good did you wear the same shirt
I'm
wearing uh this is actually like a
maroon like a red mine's [__] maroon
too oh [__] yeah man super cool let me
just get conch back on hold on one
second mircat appreciate all of you
hanging hanging hard I'm going to get
into you guys in a minute uh but if you
get over to spre cast really easy to get
on highly recommend it English pe's yes
I love them Larchmont karate Mike Hammer
good to see you I will always say hi to
you drock keeping up with the Vayner
trucks all day he sure is drock's right
there boom Periscope share it I want to
see 537 shares right now right now share
it conch get back here I'm trying to I
know you are Dennis good to see you
Dennis have always Peter Han love you
back Sam love Sam from Belgium love him
uh it will save on Facebook you can
watch you other places because here's my
answer yeah there he is oh well all
right I'm gonna oh there you go conch
good conch I when I did okay Co you're
just going to have to watch that's it
I'm done with the conquer I love him I'm
done um when I did
Conan and it was like 4: or 5 in the
afternoon I did go out for drinks and uh
and and dinner with my family and some
friends I did take up the afternoon off
we did watch it that night and so I've
been in that chapter of my life where I
worked really hard and I was good enough
to build a $50 million business I'm just
working at a different speed now just in
a different
Zone uh Periscope you guys having
trouble octonation saying something I'm
just you keep an eye on it are you guys
good uh yo yo yo yeah you guys are good
having trouble you guys are good you
guys no problem no okay SM I'll take a
coffee SM good to see you brother how
you doing man just so everybody knows
obviously we're using spr cast quite a
bit please share it up I will start
going a little bit hardcore on the live
streams in a minute from spre cast Steve
good to see you brother how are
you good man dude thank you for having
me on and uh thank you for doing
everything you do because I got to say
and a half years ago was when I started
the salon guy I mean you know it took me
a year and a half for you to even get to
know who I was and that was my goal
doing what you know what you did reading
crush it like everything I owe basically
a following interview and thank you that
and listen thank you and listen I you
know obviously we had a recent social
media interaction where you felt like
for I don't know how long it was I
wasn't interacting or saying hello and I
I hope you saw how quickly I jumped in I
would never want to make you feel bad
you know as you know what's going on
with my Insanity it's just Serendipity
right I see you I probably
subconsciously because I see you know
you think I am doing it so I'm sorry I
let you down I'm sorry you you you felt
compelled to be frustrated like that I
apologize oh thank you man I appreciate
that um you know what's really
interesting a couple things I want to
say is is the Journey of starting from
really nothing to building it up and a
lot of people want it but they don't
like you say they don't really want to
work for it and they don't know how to
I've made so many freaking sacrifices
I've made so many sacrifices to get to
this point which a lot of people don't
want to do so can you talk a little bit
about the sacrifice of you know staying
up late and giving up you know hanging
out with friends and what it's like when
I'm an emotional standpoint go dude if
you I always say if you want the
audacity to have a crazy life where you
can live your life on your own
terms like you have to give up a lot
like like I don't understand how people
are confused by this like I give up
everything like outside of my family and
the New York Jets I've given up all of
it all the Leisure all like the learning
except Goen on yesterday right he reads
a lot of books I don't like I read my
community like you know it's different
learnings like I was I was laughing
where people like oh that's so smart
Gary you're so stupid I'm like sure if
you want to be smart about what other
people's thoughts are but I promise you
right now I understand [__] consumers
better than anybody right now in the
world period [__] period so like
you know everybody's got different
skills and so like I'm giving up a lot
of things I could be an awesome bat mitt
player like I'm super rich now like I
could be doing a ton a ton guys there's
stuff on the uh uh Steve I could be
doing a ton of fun stuff now I could be
enjoying the living [__] out of my life
right I can be chilling like like you
have to like you you give up so much
when you're a purebred entrepreneur you
give it all up you give it all up
besides your family and probably one or
two other leisurely things and sometimes
if if you go too extreme and if not
careful you give up those things too
like my biggest fear is to be smart
about my work life balance and so it's
super lonely I I've had a very emotional
like month there's been a lot of stuff
going on at Vayner media you know
restructuring Letting Go people hiring
people uh changing Concepts leveling up
people leveling down people changing out
things I got a lot going on it's super
lonely it's super lonely and and it's
even and it's even harder listen the
great philosopher P Diddy isn't wrong
More Money More Problems when I had a
lot less I liked it a lot better because
I was climbing I had less to lose like
every you know everybody envies
everybody else's situation they think
it's super easy for me now no it's not
like I'm hungrier than every one of you
I promise you and if you're as hungry if
you think you're hungrier than me then I
got good news for you we're tied we're
tied there's nobody hungrier than me I'm
nothing compared to what I think I'm
going to be I'm at zero I'm at straight
[__] zero zero and so you know and I
mean it and I mean it the most and
that's what I feel and so you might
think I have more but I feel exactly the
way you feel right now if you're the
hungriest and Sam Bean you can say
you're hungrier prove it partner show me
show me that you're [__] hungrier
than me because I'm showing you
[__] and don't give me some
[__] that I got [__] dck you got
Snapchat dick show me show me that
you're [__] hungrier than me because
you're
not and so that's it man it's [__]
lonely Out Here for a
Pimp [__] you just like unloaded dude
yeah man it's [__] pent up like it's
pent up like what do people think is
going on I'm [__] working 18 hours a
day every day like I'm trying to balance
having two kids I've got the pressure of
all my ambition I got so much ambition I
got so much ambition it's ridiculous you
know how much you know how much pressure
that is you know how much pressure that
is you know how much ambition I have you
know how bad I want this I want it the
most and this is what's important is
seeing the emotional side of you man
thank you just for being authentic and
being you you're welcome realness that's
what awesome I think it is awesome like
like you know like you know I think it
is awesome and I think what sneakers no
one second see Andy's doing weird [__]
right now sorry no I'm just [__] with
my ankle what do you need Blair I'm put
I'm just I have a good one D up they
said you want Blair to be on with
Stephen and me they get their own they
said they bought eight books they're
going to buy 16 more if you answer your
question 100% listen Andy you sell books
you don't worry about me and Steven
doing great content you don't want to
about India being super [__] fast I
love it India give me something you
don't like dck chilling all day and
doing dick you don't worry about any of
that you worry about selling books
somebody says they'll buy 16 more right
now and they prove it to you don't let
somebody game you you text gck green B
on the look I believe him you believe
him all right you're [__] you're a
gullible
kid I agree you're sneaky Stephen listen
we're gonna go oh Blair's got a look of
course they bought 16 books there's
7,000 of
them
all right I just exed him out I exed out
Blair and the crew for a second Blair
I'm sorry I need to finish with my man
Stephen Blair that crew I love that crew
you guys are coming back you're coming
back Stephen listen I appreciate you man
and I know how bad you want it and I
know you're hungry and let me tell you
something and it's a good thing to tell
you right now cuz I'm watching from afar
it's funny right you get that early you
know you're patient then you get that
pop you start getting on those red
carpets you start getting some gigs and
then you hit a LOL right and you're
wondering like like where is it going
right It's a Grind man it's 24/7 365 you
know for Life 24/7 365 for Life what you
have to do a lot of times if you're if
you're kind of like where's this going
what you got to reinvent yourself you
got to break yourself right I started
feeling a little bit of a lull hence
drock comes into the equation hence the
ascary V show comes in the equation
hence Instagram comes into the equation
hence Snapchat comes in the equation got
it got it keep hacking the same thing
that made you figure it out the first
time could be the second time go all in
on music league go all in on Snapchat go
away for a month and find a new
community that you find through all the
vecs like [__] with it [__] with
it yeah Gary can I just share with you
real quick what I've accomplished really
because of you and and what I've busted
my ass for yes but you got to go fast
because Blair bought 16 books and I
don't want to be a
dick Okay cool so I'm almost at 300,000
subscribers on YouTube uh 37 million
views on YouTube I've been on Good
Morning America live I've been on
national television and I signed a book
deal and I have my own hair care
products now just because we following
your [__] hustle and your your path
your
guidance thank you brother man listen so
Stephen listen uh you might have heard
this a lot of you have I'm 100% writing
the book called crushed
it and I want to officially right here
on the spot because I know crush is what
started it invite you to be a part of
that book and I'm telling you right now
it will be including this book my
biggest selling book of all time and I'm
going to personally interview you for
the book and we're going to write and
you're going to tell that story and I'm
going to make it not just you saying I'm
so great and you're so great we'll find
good ways to figure out how you and I
are different how
you but crushed it is going to be the
book that really [__] sets the world
on fire and so you will be a part of
it but thank you but we're not going to
[__] people like if you're you're in
a place right now where you're only
making 880k or 40K like like we're going
to keep it real as [__] I might have to
look at your IRS statements don't [__]
with me
Steve no dude oh real man because you
know what it takes time it takes time it
takes
time like I'm making a lot of money I
fine I get it you can't even wrap your
head around the amount of money I'm
leaving on the table I'm leaving tens of
millions of dollars per year on the
table to build to build
wow that's great man well thank you for
doing this thank you see wait real quick
I'm an IDI I'm Andy I'm sorry I'm not in
my S Steve how many books did you
buy buy eight dude you've got on good
[__] Morning America can I get 16 am
I a little you know look what my chop
can I get
16 all right I'll buy more I promise
I'll do it right now man I know I'm
going to go [__] look at gar green
I'm going to like literally double check
I love you Mah I appreciate that yeah
yeah got eight more Andy you see what I
did there I can sell let's go let's go
player let's go they got the book squad
t-shirts let's
go Fired
Up Periscope mircat Facebook if you're
not watching on spreecast you're missing
outeast.com
events it's linked up on my Twitter
let's put it let's let's really India
why don't you tweet it all of you
following by now Blair what's
up hi thanks for having us how are you
I'm doing super well where are you
guys we're in Utah right now but half
the sa to Scottish the big
u scin a big U and a big S and I love
it we've been watching since 8 o' this
morning um I bought eight books I comp's
going to buy another six thank you for
thank you guys so much good job Andy
K Ross my brother is probably your
biggest fan so I'll let Ross ask a
question um I've been reading I've been
following you since it uh I moved over
here about six years ago six and a half
at looking for my wife so say up an
agency small AG in a phase where we're
growing quickly we're moving to a new
6,000 fet building
and and you know with business growth is
always tough staff more staff
management scaling properly and I think
the biggest question
is at what point you it's not ejecting
yourself in the building but at what
point do you we switch to 10 minute
meetings 15 minute meetings to try and
cut down on the times but when you're
hiring and you're trying to transition
into the next level how do you manage
that you know what can is a key
personnel you sell like hand Blair the
the key Blair the key now is everybody
in that room part of the
agency yeah yeah some are some there
work
yeah how many people are there right
now 10 and then off done in well Blair I
I love you I love you with all my heart
but I can't hear any concern in
anybody's voice at only 10 people it's
10 you know what I mean concerned I'm
just not willing for you to be concerned
you've got nothing but time for 10
people I mean no not concerned just
looking at as you grow are there key for
you GRE this is the key this is the key
first and foremost it's about those 10
people this company Vayner media was
built on the first 60 70 80 100 people
it's making sure that everybody in that
little office right now and the other
five are family family for Life what
that means
is
everybody there has different wants and
needs some want the titles some want the
money some want the work life balance
some want the notoriety they all want
different things it's up to
you yeah mute so can you guys mute it so
it's a little bit better
okay cool can you guys hear me just give
me a thumbs up okay there we go so it's
up to you to know what those 10 people
care about Big Time Well Oh I thought
they were rece no sorry Jesus guys I
want receipts eight books now 16's
better 24 is the best 24 is the best
Dell Rivas buy 24 books enter three
times I will fly your [__] ass
anywhere in the world to meet me for an
hour I will change your [__] game buy
it buy it now thank you doing it now
Obsession Expressions thank you talk to
me Facebook live step up 24 books send
it in right now Super8 vainer
media.com
Blair it's up to you to know every
single thing about what matters to them
and reverse engineer it until that 10
becomes 20 that 20 becomes 40 and then
You' got a group of 40 people you go to
400 500 easy to Brandon you got a
question you got a
question get in here you're coming in
Brandon Blair it's up to you do you
understand redeeming myself oh my God
hold on hold on
Blair amazing amazing amazing delicious
delicious ERS trashing orders Blair this
is good put on mute right now I'll get
you back in a second DB DB get in here
DB you're being called in we're going
road going now watch this watch this
this is real [__] this is you know what
this is why I [__] love this this is
real [__] [__] this is get get in
here guys get in here here take my seat
you're in Brandon you can get a lot more
in sit down DB DB look great today
perfect timing for you you know all
right watch this this real [__] play
these are two wonderful gentlemen that
work in the agency watch this this going
to be real [__] what we buy yeah we're
just going to go back to let's get you
we're over here let's get in real close
so most people see us very good Brandon
you're not in here over here there we go
good okay good ready all right now don't
put that somebody will screenshoot it
and [__] use it yeah dude what are
you DJ [__] khed all right listen
here's the thing watch this DB we'll
start with you DB we've had some
organizational change this is real talk
it's just real [__] talk we had
organizational changes how long have you
been here four years
amazing give you want some followers or
no I don't know how you like to keep it
on the social you'll take some shout it
out uh dbor a on Twitter oh [__] you got
a gangster [__] name DB you've been
here four years we have had some great
changes we had a great leader going
she's going to do her own thing you've
been close to her mhm did I or did I not
on a random day a couple days later just
walk by your desk sit down and
personally check in and make sure
everything was okay completely yeah I
was just sitting there and Co came up
yeah no propaganda here Brandon real
quick keep it to shill
Brandon how many months in to your job
did I grab you and take you into a weird
room where it was just me and you two no
one that can't be true your first day it
was day two yeah no no when I said to
you like look I really want you to be
here for the rest of your when I when I
when
did how many when into your career how
long have you been here almost four
years great do do you want to get it to
some followers oh I'll take a few okay
go ahead uh B resnic 86 it's B isn't boy
Resnik re s n
i86 you got to go across platforms just
got a follower you got a follower nice B
resing yeah how many months cuz I think
it's months or it could be I don't know
you you answered the truth yeah how long
into your career at Vayner how many
agencies have you been at before two
prior to Vayner and you de um two cool
how many same one is that right we
together before this like this is a long
time coming yeah oh this is amazing all
right get in here family first so when
did you know what happened when did I
pull you I just so everybody knows I
pulled you into a room I look you dead
in the [__] face yeah and I said I
want you to work here for the rest of
your life I would say around month I I
it was it was it was it was a long time
ago it was almost four years but I think
it was around month 6 we were at the old
office 373 y i remember very distinctly
it was the conference room what you call
that one right by some weird I don't
know on the far we have conference rooms
named after dogs in this not Texas chil
but
zenen z z z we were in zenen and Gary
sits across from me dead across me from
have we ever talked before we had like
the one Daye two checkin where you're
like oh hey this is like this is my
operation like happy to have you Brian I
was like yes
Brandon no uh no but in month six I
think we really had to sit down and you
said straight up look you've been here
for six months what makes you tick I
want you to be here for the for the rest
of your life and I want you this is this
is your family I want you to comfort to
me if you ever have any issues you walk
into my office you talk him you air out
that's what we had I think it was like
six months Kelly
McCarthy yeah all right get out of here
guys I love you have fun day we be
watching thank you guys thank you Blair
that's the answer Blair that's the
answer right and I and look pulled him
off the street and he did you hear what
he said and I'm so pumped did you hear
what he said he said what makes you tick
that's what I said to
him guys it's about listening I could
talk all day I will never Trump the
level of listening that I do with my
talking you think I talk a lot I talk so
little compared to I listen and it's not
even funny and that's what you have to
do with the first 40 to 50 people and
that will build a foundation that will
scale you infinitely got
it love you guys thank you so much you
got
it they're [__] fired up over there
you
bang Cynthia 007 that's what it's
about that was that was good stuff
that's real talk randomly standing there
grab
them Jen get in here we're just proven
[__] now like we're just on a different
kick hello hello Jen hello we're talking
about agency life a little bit here on
the stream okay somebody was just asking
about how to scale the
agency you've been here D how long seven
months seven months bang did anybody pay
attention to mean drilling that that was
not bad that's good Jen um you know
we've you know in our seven months we've
had a couple of big talks already yes we
have you know you know listen this is a
tough qu this is a loaded question so I
respect that but I'm only going off a
truth so I know that as well you've
worked at a lot of agencies yes how
many five right you know I think the
last time or the time before before we
talked you you talked about how nice it
was to be able to sit with your CEO or
things of that nature like what's what's
our
difference um the difference and don't
[__] and cater to me even you know
what take the show in a weird Direction
and go with a you can go anywhere you
want yeah yeah okay um no the difference
for me is
definitely um the empowerment and Trust
in the employees um even just down like
across Juni level yeah but I don't even
like to talk about like
I get it you know younger peeps yes
these younger [__] peeps Jesus Christ
very confident they are right they are
they are very confident do you think
that my confidence run rubs off on the
rest of the crew I think so I do too
yeah and I think it's just the
permission to be confident and speak
your mind I agree yes and then like the
not the fear that if you lose the client
then it's game over right I agree Andy
you're shaking your head a lot I agree
you believe in that yeah that's thing
there's no fear here that's a very
Fearless company because I [__] eat
it yes I eat fear Jen that's my favorite
meal not a lot of calories and clearly
losing weight are you going to lunch I
am how long keep it
tight go go thanks for stopping by all
right thank you do you want some
followers you want some social media
followers or you keep it private keep it
kind of private do your thing all right
yeah guys you know what Stephen back to
you I mean what Jen said there that's
the Insight right like the other thing
the reason it's so lonely for me at the
top is I eat fear like I take on all the
pressure for the agency to the best of
my ability right it's an important thing
it's an important thing who wants to go
to Disney
World who wants to go to I want to see
my streams okay look I'm seriously
considering right now to send somebody
plus
three plus three to Disneyland or Disney
World your choice
I'm not
joking but I need to see complete
Insanity I need to see all 415 of you on
Periscope to [__] yeah holy [__] is
right holy [__] is right my count will
have a heart attack it's GNA be a bad
day it's my son's birthday honey badger
I want you to win so bad you can't even
imagine but I want massive explosion I
want everybody on face I want the two
1500 of you somebody just texted me
me I want everybody on Facebook to share
the [__] out of this I want Periscope to
explode with sharing I do not see enough
people hitting the share on Twitter
explosion I do not see it I just don't
mircat mircat I'm not seeing
enough let's see what spr cast I'm a
cheap date yes I want to go Disney World
Here We Go
Disney boy do I want to pull somebody
from Florida or La really excited I love
this stuff real quick actually you know
what we're going to build up a little
bit to Disney here's time I'm going to
do it I need to watch this watch bcast
Andy so I can watch the other
three and it's okay I want you to say no
because I know a lot of people can't
afford it shell Blum 30 minute drive
Shelly Blum better win um because I just
have to buy the tickets C 40 bucks for
gas um I want to know who is not
in yet who has not bought eight bcks
actually you know what instead of that
cuz that's tough why don't you put the
why don't you right now in Ms and I'm
talking all 1200 of you Facebook I'm
talking about all 500 of you Periscope
I'm talking about all 300 of you mircat
and I'm talking about all 1100 of you uh
um spree cast I want you to put in how
many books you've bought and have
entered so you might have bought three
but you didn't enter you might have
bought eight and you've enter like I
want to see how many books you've
already B bought and remember not
judging like super one is super I'm s
blessed the future thank you for the one
chefette at a buck and a quarter 12 six
for the chef
zero zero map made content quad map made
content put 10 zeros in my mouth just
stuck it right in my mouth no worries
Steven zero with a lot of Cs it's a lot
of zeros respect I get it 11 books I
still haven't bought it yet waiting on
the hard copy to hit stores
respect my bad Matt made content said my
bad one next week thank you
Nathan [__] I need to get mine one un
MTO ni did just cop crush it though
thank you javelle audio passage got
eight bro thank you zero Time Zero for
your re Hunter it hurts Dylan in for one
Brian Cox thank you so much 150 books
for Tor thank you so much zero we'll be
getting the audio book I bought one so
far trying to get more one book all I
can afford right now no worries Paula I
was able to afford one Pete Han thank
you one hard copy one audio that's the
common thing this everybody knows that
the audio is so different this audio
combo is going to be huge Ed turny thank
you for the eight Philip I I don't want
zero I want one get me in there Jacob
Brown went for
17 because he went what eight and eight
he went two entries and an audio book
Sorge went in Remy went for 16 four
Shannon four so far Shannon's got to
step up and buy four more and get
entered in Shannon you could be going to
Disney Shannon you can be flying to see
me for an hour Shannon let's go let's
step up and get four more if you bought
four anybody bought three four five is
making a humongous mistake take your
receipt from
before send it
in and buy four more right now send in
both receipts we know how to handle it
over there in in Zack garrettland eight
Stadium comics than you just got my
email from buying eight books thank you
so much who's buying right now actually
that will get my juices going that that
will get me going who's about to buy
eight more or eight right the second
right now who's buying one right now s
is me nice just say say me with a lot of
16 more oo I need a vacation Chef you do
this would be great me very nice me
Fabian Lane maybe Lori Peters is maybe I
need to get Lori me working on it thank
you Shannon me I Am David I love it me I
can't figure out GTA checks ex gelta
checks I got you I got you I'm I'll buy
29 the real entrepreneur on Periscope
just said I'll buy 29 first of all I
need to understand why 29 not 32 second
of all I got it paid boom bought two go
I really don't want to win Disney I want
the one-onone with Gary Gary's better
than
Mickey oh excal the chick's buying
32 fcking pumped Bayer London who's
going I'll buy 32 xcal the chick I love
you what's your real name um I am Craig
love you Craig K two P sex one screen
better than one 29 is a great number
respect real estate oneon-one baby Shen
sh shukin I want to make sure I
pronounce it right shukin thank you so
much remember Africa Australia Asia UK
anywhere in the world you're entered
everybody's now eligible I want to buy
100,000 I want you to to Marcel Ken
great to see you Ken me bought my books
in London tickets today boom I sold
650,000 and used books on Amazon in 2015
good [__] resi resales you see that
that's [__] hustle I think books are
one of the best arbitrages at garage
sales and dollar stores and um Goodwill
there's it's a i like books as a flip
because they're easy to understand what
you're buying they're easy to take
photos Amazon is the [__] with resell I
agree eBay buy eight books somebody
coming in big someone just bought eight
more all right I'm gonna wait so I know
a bunch of you just bought and I pushed
I'm going to wait 5 to seven minutes all
of you should have your receipts send
them in right now to Super8 vainer
media.com Garrett Zack Stefan the crew
make sure you're bring in the receipts
wait a minute cut it off in 5 minutes
from right now cut it off if you guys
are listening at 12:28 we are now 2
hours and 23 minutes into our session I
got to be honest with you I feel fresh
as [__] I don't even feel like I don't
even feel like fad stat what I want some
stats 342 receipts iner 2000 tell me my
Amazon rank right now they update late a
lot of times pull it up in 2,812 copy
sold 2, 812 not bad not bad not bad not
bad only 8,000 short what I want so
we're not going to get there but we got
time people come in later people Hustle
the big thing is to get this core crew
to phone a friend one person and say my
man Gary ve that I've been talking about
is on he's doing a big thing buy eight
books if I really got everybody here to
get everybody to buy eight we'd be there
you think we can do that
IND Alex it's more than 2812 we're just
not caught up lag thank you Alex foring
you feel now the other thing is there's
some people that can buy the oh you know
we need to sell you know what wait a
minute I'm doing a bad I [__] up let's
take let's rewind 2 hours and 32 minutes
the 300 book buy instead of making some
of the people well we're adding up and
we'll let people I don't want to the 300
book buy I'm taking a small group in
this office or in one of my conference
rooms Scott CF bro uh about eight bucks
guys this is literally the guy that's
going to be upset for me giving away the
trip to Disney this is our CFO Scott why
you why don't you jam a few minutes
Scott thank you Scott why only eight
isn't that what today is about the eight
yeah but you can buy 88 that's true all
right why don't you tell everybody a
little bit about yourself what you think
how you feeling all right you don't have
to roll
up yeah right here both of us well
they're all here they're all stands wow
how are we doing we CF bro we've sold a
lot of books we're having a good time
we're only 2 hours and 30 minutes in I'm
still feeling it Scott why don't you
tell everybody about your career a
little bit about your Rockstar you're
you're rock star but you're also a CFO I
find that interesting and I was in
Disney this
week about well it is important because
I'm about to send somebody to Disney
awesome yeah so my name is Scott
actually just fixed all my social media
presents now I'm SE height everywhere s
s h e ydt no more Scotty chalk for every
platform following your footsteps uh no
I'm good man been here with Gary for
almost three years and unbelievable
we're doing great we are doing great
we're doing great scottt tell everybody
how you project numbers each year and
then I blow them out of the water and
you still haven't really figured out how
true those are that's usually my
favorite part yeah I try to sandbag and
say we're going to do this we're going
to do uh 40 and Gary's like we're going
to do 55 and then we do 65 67 this year
we did 67 bam we did it's true it's true
now we're we're how transparent we this
is true we publish our numberb road to a
hundo how we doing are people getting
scope signed are we making stuff we are
we are pay our bills someone watched my
Scopes you're doing great thank you God
you know what your Scopes are legit
actually this is a good way to get a
huge influx on on uh on Snapchat
followers yes so one more time yeah one
more time s e h y DT bang all platforms
follow me you know what I'm going to do
can I can I offer something back I'm
going to give back I'm going to buy
another eight and somebody write to me
and tell me why I should send it to you
and I'll do it on my dime I'm not
charging this back
if I see this as a line item on the p&l
I promise you'll be finished fired love
you brother CF bro in the house 1 minute
until Amazon WIS are due for an update
it's 890 890 in the world 890 in the
world but it's been 890 for a while 890
us Amazon yep it updates around an hour
every hour and hasn't updated in the
last hour so we should see an upti there
Canada's at like 450 I want to be number
one in Canada Canada
I will move to Canada fulltime if I'm
number one Edmonton I will live in
Edmonton for the rest of my life I'm
kidding I'm
kidding all right Canada big up Marcel
uh all right
so um edmont I love edmont come to
Tennessee I love Tennessee we have an
office in Chattanooga uh all right one
more chance one more minute get your
receipts in get your receipts in get
your receipts in some is going to Disney
land or world and it's going to be this
better not be somebody from the
Philippines or Thailand that could that
would be very expensive we is there
Disney Paris still yes you're a Disney
you're a Disney all right that's so
awesome this is Hong Kong too yeah
there's oh Disney Hong Kong okay this is
going to get expensive oh Disney there's
a lot of people that' rather win this
Disney trip to go with their family than
see me for a sticking hour all right
let's get to the cut let's cut to the
chase how many people would rather win
this one than the actual big one later
to actually spend an hour with me who
wants this one I get it it's all right I
get it B [__] no me all right Davis for
an hour with you nice all right so far
so good Hong Kong shout out from Ohio
big up's not even close nope I'd rather
have Gary no hang out with Gary I get it
though some I'd rather be it's really
amazing well my kids would love it I
mean people have kid I mean I totally
get it over Disney I do Jack I get it
why not both why no whoever wins this
I'm pulling no I'm saying but like
people say Garrett more yeah someone's
going to Disney World this is not this
is this is not good Zach just brought a
big a big sack of them didn't he no
Z okay not
bad
Andy everything takes a all of time I
know but the key India is I need people
here on this stream you know let's reset
Periscope because every time we do we
get a double audience because they get
that big Periscope on their push so
let's close out Periscope Periscope
we'll be right back with you in a second
Facebook really building momentum up to
2600 Facebook big love for you guys
where's wine oh Wine's an interesting
idea I can't drink it right now but I'm
going to go really focus on Facebook for
a little while here my kids have been to
Disney give me Gary good one Anna
where's the wine auction book bro when
is it going to happen at the end tonight
at uh 600 p.m. is that when we wrap up y
right at 6 p.m. if you guys want to come
back the big drawing 1 hour with me
anywhere in the world um it's going to
be huge um I want to type yep
Super
Eight them in them out as fast as we can
okay it is what it is keep coming all
right Garrett it is what it
is
I you got it um
oh we shared an error sharing it on
Twitter that's all right Periscope is
we're back service what's K do you
remember Kate service's name not okay
we'll give it a shout out in a second go
ahead now we have the answers we have
the questions and the answers you type
in Instagram marketing you're going to
get a search pull of everything that
Gary's ever said about Instagram
marketing it's going to be [__] nuts
now Andy I want this to live on my site
because the traffic I'll become like we
can do it like Google like it'll become
the great I mean like I'm better than
Google am I better than
Google
what [__] you Wikipedia I got you I'm
gonna link everybody to it let's see uh
caption
cre captions
created captions created holy crap I'm
looking at I haven't seen it yet so a
design is coming it's in the rough
stages but like put in Snapchat okay
boom that's 19 and you can watch it you
could share so design is coming Zack are
you designing it y
yeah cuz when Zach does it it's [__]
the
best I'm linking everybody right now
you're going to link everybody are we
ready to show it he might not even have
it on a server that can handle the track
yeah we're going to keep it secret for a
little bit longer we're going to make
them we're going to make them I'm going
to make them we're going to bring Alexi
I need more people watch are we going to
put Alexi in the Stream he in the client
next like in two hours from now he's
today right yeah he's in you had to go
back to Facebook Chat has stopped it's
probably working should we restart it or
should we let it roll if it's working
let's Let It Roll the max is 90 minutes
I don't think we've hit this on since
the last segment it's you know what I
would I you know what I would restart
you take that Andy restart it because I
like the chat um hey everybody hey Saba
love you you know that uh all right
Alexi congratulations Mike is it's
perfect you just came to New York he's a
great kid you're Mike's you know what
the [__] you know what pisses me off it
always comes up Mike right like like
like milh housee you know like I have a
funny feel Alexi's a really talented
developer you now now now Mike's yeah
Mike's somehow gonna [__] yeah Mike's
gonna have like some awesome new thing
on his website now [__] Mike see what
Happ Mike see what happens you did the
right thing you could have bed out of
it now it comes back to you love it love
it all right put it in the VIP when it's
ready I will by the way would love to
get some comments really quick right now
for the VIP email I think Andy and team
Zack India the whole team we've really
stepped up the email I think it's
finally worth it like truthfully I think
it's finally worth it obviously we threw
a bunch of right hooks the last four
days but we're putting original video
content we're recapping the hustore bio
a lot of people see look agree uh loving
the VIP email Gary I'm heading out in
office in a few I'm heading to your
office in a few hours all right uh love
the email like the videos uh email rece
email for receipt it's super at it's
super number eight the number eight bner
media.com my email is on gary.com just
sign up for the email service it's the
email service we call the VIP email
service just email service digest now um
it's called husters digest now y on the
homeage who I didn't real you guys are
making some that's some pretty hardcore
branding decisions without me being
around but they're
still you guys are getting
very you you approved but it wasn't in
email yeah uh you know show me your toes
okay shit's getting weird I mean I'm not
C I listen I is that a hole in my sock
that would be the best is there that's
the
best that's ghetto that's super
ghetto that's how we roll baby it's
always hustle getting it down to 15
bucks no it's book pal that gets it down
to 15 bucks not Co reads book got it all
right Edie get out of here bring someone
on the screen with you oh yeah let's do
time for somebody on the screen guys are
there no more rece like are we suck at
is nobody no body buying books that's
what's happening you guys know no
receipts to print there's not books
coming in nobody's [__] printing
there's no books coming in I'm super
sad um did you talk
to is pin gonna be on Sarah South 5 o' 5
o'clock for pin yeah I Sarah am I on yes
you are
on I'm so freaking excited about this
you don't even
know okay so uh quick back story before
I ask you my question two years ago
Sarah real quick real quick real quick
before you go couple things one you got
the headphones on so it sounds
great we are 2 hours and 47 minutes into
eight hours you're you know yeah I've
really exciting news you don't even have
to rush we're gonna really we're gonna
get in this so do your thing tell me go
okay perfect okay so two years ago my
husband was working like 60 to 90 hour
week
hold on Sarah a very big moment coming
Garrett give him to me you go it's not
bad I wouldn't say it's good but it's
not the
worst what India I think you're really
funny oh you think I'm funny well thank
you I think you're great all right Sarah
go
ahead thank you thank you thank you
thank you for your book Super8 Bor
media.com I would buy 24 it's three
chances go ahead
Sarah okay so uh two years ago like I
said my husband was just working crazy
hours so you you know all about that but
we're more like interested in the work
life balance side of things not the like
hustle 20 hours a day thing right yes so
uh we have we have a six-year-old now
and a newborn a three-month-old now and
uh two years ago he was working like
crazy and um I went to a business
conference now I've always been
entrepreneurially minded but never like
action wise so I hadn't actually
implemented that even though it's like
naturally my mentality from a very young
age cousin on the other hand didn't have
that Entre entrepreneurial thought
process but he did have the like work
his ass off thought process so uh it's
like it works perfectly together so
years ago I went to do business
conferences for entrepreneurship and I
was like I'm gonna go I'm gonna meet
people I'm gonna start networking I'm
gonna put myself out there even though I
don't have anything to show for myself
yet it's like I have to do something to
get myself over over the edge so we can
like start going right so I went to
these conferences met some people felt
that energy and I've never really
networked with entrepreneurs and I was
like oh hell yeah like we have to get
this going now I know that there's
something that we're meant to do that we
can do so I got home I was all pumped my
husband like freaked out he's like whoa
whoa whoa like calm down what are you
what are you what are you bringing at me
right now so uh but over like a week
long period he he really started to see
that I had a passion and I had a vision
even though I didn't know where and
which direction as far as what business
to build but I was like we need to do
something and I know we can so uh he's
like okay well let's let's do it and
he's like I'm gonna quit my job and
let's let's move across the country so
we're like all right we're gonna sell
our house you quit your job we did
everything basically just went all in
ended up moving across the country from
Texas to Oregon just to get like get out
of the whole space like we needed out of
Texas a fresh just a fresh palette you
know why why or why
Oregon because we're we love nature and
we love the outdoors hiking all that
kind of stuff and that's where in the
United States it's gorgeous out there so
um anyways we got out there three months
the apartment we're scrambling around
trying to play with different ideas
podcasting we were like thinking about
starting YouTube this that and after
three months we were you know we we had
enough money for about a year to kind of
get things going but uh you know things
were starting to dwindle and we're like
oh we need to cut we need to cut off any
extra expenses to really like be able to
stretch this out if we need you what
kind of what kind of what kind
of what kind of business were you trying
to build
okay well right now the business we have
built is we're YouTubers so we are our
kids Adventure Channel which idea is to
build a business as a family including
our child because like me from a young
age like I was saying I was like I was
an entrepreneur as a kid I would like
have my birthday party and the next day
I would be selling my my presents to my
friends I love you already
anyway so with our son like I I see that
kind of in him as well so we're like why
can't we build a business together as a
family like with our kid and he was four
at the time so we ended up starting a
YouTube channel which now like after 21
months I think we've been in it we've
had over 400 million minutes watched and
over 100 million views we hit like two
weeks ago and uh and it's just like this
this whole long process but now we're
actually in the on the successful side
but we want to scale it up and get it
going and are you are you monetizing
cont are you monetizing through ads on
YouTube ad this is 100% AdSense right
now so we haven't Diversified like we
haven't really gotten into sponsorships
or anything like that and we have to be
like we're really careful about what we
will get into as far as that's concerned
because of like the type of people we
are and I we won't promote things that
we don't agree with or we don't you know
like we're not passionate about so Sarah
one of the biggest things one of the
biggest things that influencers and
YouTube stars are making a huge mistake
about is what you just said in a good
way um right you don't want to promote
anything the reason AdSense is good is
you're not you're kind of loosely
affiliated with those ads so that's easy
and the reason you're not taking
sponsorship from Brand and have you done
some sponsorship stuff because you
believed in the
product uh you know we have done a few
things without charging so we haven't
done any paid sponsorships we've done a
couple things like to help out some
families who were like oh we have this
product similar to how we got it helped
out but got it um uh wow hold on one
second Sarah lingo I'm super sorry that
you feel like I'm been hard selling the
new book so much and not doing content I
feel like I'm trying to get the right
balance I'm I'm I'm in it I'll try
better links so I'm sort of let you down
um seriously I thought I thought we had
you know I'm having fun with the hard
push but I think I'm pushing a good
balance you guys you guys always call me
out like I think I'm doing mostly
content all right cool Linka I'll try
harder I apologize thank you Sarah but
but listen everybody's got you know I
respect the [__] out of everybody's
point of view so lingo I will step up
and I will try to go harder with it um
Sarah um I think uh I think one of the
most interesting things that a lot of
you can do if you're lucky enough to
have a following on social and you want
to monetize you're letting the deals
come to you right you're getting offers
how many subscribers do you have on your
on your YouTube we are we we're starting
to get offers um we're I think we're
like 55,000 somewhere around there so
the reason our views are so uh large or
the amount of views we're getting is so
big in comparison to our subscriber base
is because our primary demographic is
like two to sixy olds right so they're
not subscribing right they just go on to
the kidnap or whatever I mean those
two-year-olds get freaky as [__] on
YouTube Sarah so you know they watch 87
times in a row xan man my little guy
he's three and a half he'll watch the
same [__] 447 times in a row and on 448
he's like I never seen this [__] before
so they're a good demo for our for our
unique cookies we're getting like 90
minutes per like each each cookie we're
getting 90 minutes so it's it's Sarah
what's your username on YouTube let's
make sure some people follow you the
axles show and it's axles show.com ax L
show.com the Axel show that'll take them
right to that's my son's name Axel love
so uh basically it's just my husband
started it with my son they're the
primary ones in front of the camera
we've started a few more channels since
then like our family Vlog and all this
stuff that's starting to take off but um
my question for you like you were saying
about sponsorships they're coming to us
that so that's happening um but
obviously so far we've been filtering
out most of them because we just don't
it's not it doesn't fit with us so still
waiting for them to come to us but I
need to know real quick Sarah 40 books
rece trying to get a confirmation on
Periscope Sarah I think the number one
thing that you should be doing is
sitting down with your husband
strategizing late at night uh early in
the morning however you like to go and
pick the 50 to 700 Brands and products
that you think can integrate well you've
already thought about how to integrate
it it feels native you believe in them
right and you need to go on the offense
versus the defense too many influencers
let people spam them instead of taking
full control of what's going on with
them and attacking there's literally
every goddamn toy in America is trying
to figure out how to get to two to six
year olds they've only got Nickelodeon
to spend their ad money on and you're
sitting on
it right full control yeah and right so
90% kids just like bashing on the keys
you know so um we need to get more
engagement we're trying to shift people
and filter Maria we got it them on
Facebook and talk to us so and we get
tons of great feedback from the parents
but we're not getting a lot of sharing
which I recently uh on your page I said
hey Gary like make sure Sarah Sarah real
quick did you see Lorenzo saying Sarah
hit me up my wife is a buyer at Babies R
Us no I didn't see that I'm well you
better [__] see it because it looks
good to
me okay sweet cool a
um S I think I think you've got it right
right it's like look you got to make
micro content you've got to focus on the
moms you've got to make some of the
creative focus on moms like it's moms
which is what we're about to do yeah
right it's not dad's we're right and
we're going to open up we haven't even
really tapped into like educational
content which our our our show is
basically just us living our lives but
having fun so it's like I said primarily
my husband and son and they just have
adventures and they play and do like
Goofy and my husband acts like like a
kid with my son and people eat it up
because Sarah let's call let's call it
let's call it what it is cuz your
husband is a goofy
kid yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah this is true but but that's why it
works right of course because it's real
anyway awesome well listen good luck to
you thank so much Gary how Sarah did you
guys read was crush it how you kind of
like how did you get into the ecosystem
you know Rob I'm joking about the Dad
I'm not sure which book read first but
I've read I've read all of your books
now um but but yeah it's just your
energy and it it you know you draw
people in so thank you I last week I was
watching you and you did the 40 book
deal thing and I was like texting my
husband like can I is it is it cool if I
buy 40 books Gary vayer like calling
people and I didn't get his text back
but he ended up saying like go for it
but I it didn't come through for a while
and it was like past the time and you're
like oh no like I so wait a minute did I
lose out on some books Sarah I feel like
I lost out on some books yeah tell me to
my face I lost out on some books you
lost out on some books but that's all
right I just bought 16 I bought 16 I
don't give a [__] I lost 24 bucks you
bought 16 I would have had
40 God damn
it and look this was even better than a
phone call and I still lost 24 bucks
awesome God damn it awesome I could
probably find some other people to get
those books now we're talking Sarah
thank you so much good luck to you focus
on the 500 Brands email them find the
executives names on
LinkedIn Google on ready for this you
want to do this baby juice you Google
who the exe who's the CEO who's the CMO
you find their name their name is Sarah
South right you go to Google you've
heard of it right Google you go to
Google you type in Sarah South Twitter
right the first result you know Sarah
South you know Gary V's an easy name
Sarah South there might be a couple more
you click on one it's not that person
you click on the next one sure enough in
the demo it says CMO of babyj juice. org
you tweet at them hey really believe in
your product I've used it my girlfriend
said it's great what however you decided
you believe in it that's it nothing else
you're I assume you've got a Twitter for
the
show you know it's got a good account
she stumbles on it you do that 48 times
only one of them actually pays attention
and you [__] grind
okay awesome it perfect awes so much
take care SAR have a good one you too
darling's number for uh Loren you got
Lorenzo's number for her good we'll set
that up I want to talk to my homies here
on Facebook live Periscope mirat Big Ups
Periscope you guys are just not sharing
enough Periscope you are not sharing
enough down below hi Gloria but
like I'm trying damn it no you're not
honey bager you're not because if I
looked over I'd be seeing the Sharon and
I don't see it all I see is nothing good
to see
Alaska you're ignoring us I'm not
ignoring you want to hit that live on
check us out on spr cast what's that
iwes talk to
Andy they are happy now very much so
happy love you too Larch mon Kate big
UPS lost 24 I lost 24 funky fairy how oh
I lost 24 from before got it can my 40
go towards my 300 yes anybody that's
thinking about the 300 which we've got
up here 300 books if you go to Gary
v.com love you g love you back Gina um
the uh 300 book deal is with 15 people
here in the office thousand books
one-on-one with me or by eight and be
entered receip goes into the bucket is
it time to give away something oh I
didn't give away Disney yet give away
Disney I've been waiting all right here
we go I'm giving a trip to Disney and
plus three three four people are going
to Disney unless you don't need it if
you only have one kid and it's a plus
three take that and if you're like 25
and you just want to take your honey
then two up to four if you have the
children to justify it I don't want some
nieces and nephews I just you got to
prove it here we go Periscope you want
Disney
mircat
Facebook sprc ass yeah let's go here we
go I want my Louis Vuitton purse I might
give away a Louis V I might give away a
Coach bag coach great client I do that
here we go Disney here we go this is it
this is it oh wait a minute whoa
whoa com you might have just made
somebody's life just got changed
somebody had it Garrett came in Garrett
literally as a human changed another
humans life that's what happens stuff
like that happens all the time in life
we don't
know this person's about to freak their
[__] this person on me on me to Disney
World or land or Hong Kong or
Paris plus their spouse if they're
married I don't want any like divorce
couples team like you and your kids kid
up to two kids you have to leave the you
if you're like my family AJ you stay at
home sorry here we
go ready there's a lot of people want
this I hate GG right now chefette is
convinced that was hers and Garrett
Shannon Rice you ready twin 5-year-old
girls oh man I want this for Don near
Don are you in do you have eight books
before I go don you have eight books in
here so you only have one ticket you
have 16 what's going on laxman you ready
Warren you ready here we
go here we go just bought eight
books we go I got five kids damn it Phil
gotta pick gotta pick here we go I trade
the trip for a phone call wow media
buyer I hope you win I hope media buyer
wins this is bad I'd much rather do the
phone call
India here it comes
Andy oh no I don't think this is us it
is us oh I'm so happy right now it's in
Anaheim Hills California isn't that
where Disneyland is is that fairly
that's Stephen
govig
winner the real winner is me I'm so ped
right now step goswick are you here
Stephen are you here here Stephen are
you here Stephen are you here Stephen
are you here is Stephen here somebody
get me play what can you believe Anaheim
look at this I have to pay for gas
that's it this is amazing I'm so
pumped is Stephen here all right Stephen
Stephen can't go to Disney Paris Stephen
goes exactly where was close that was
amazing can you believe that that's nuts
that's nuts he emailed a couple times to
make sure that he got in I just sent him
a confirmation Steven's unbelievable
Stephen where are you I'm going to kill
GG nuts only Gary could pull that off I
you got you know what that was a big
moment that was it was amazing that was
huge that was like a $10,000 moment you
were literally about to draw and he
comes in with a Garrett Garrett saved me
my man all right let's answer some
questions oneone face to face on
Facebook live uh Periscope mircat love
you uh spring cast we've been very good
to you today and let's get more people
on speak cast cuz we do want to throw
more of you on Wow you called my name
laxman I did stepen choose Disney
Florida can't he's going to
Disneyland all right what do you got
guys congrats Maria Maria LC floring go
Jets gojets is Right karma for your
generosity interesting Rob perro
congrats Steve all right guys stop
adding receipts we're adding receipts
Chef lazette forever Amazon update oh
Amazon update's a good idea Amazon
update Amazon update as by the way if
you guys can Amazon update because I'd
love to know where we're getting how
we're rolling how we're doing love from
Portugal Caleb Maddox that's that kid
that 14-year-old I'll be seeing him in
Australia spent 11,500 for me my two
business partners to come VIP event with
Andy Vella March 8th bringing the fire
Tyler I will Max hug you out um in St
Louis I can't wait worries about
combining my social media and losing
followers Beth I get it um you know it
it Beth I actually think losing
followers by combining into one place
and then letting people have a 360 view
on you is an important thing like I have
a lot of different kind of personalities
I think the complete version of you is
the best way to go and sure you'll take
a step back but you'll take three steps
forward over time chewy got to buy eight
books to enter that's okay how can I
ship how can I get an unpaid internship
aqm get we're getting a thousand emails
like that at B right now it's tough I'm
sorry but you should enter on Vayner
media's site is Amazon one of your
clients it is not Obsession love from
Germany Big Ups uh no because it's hard
for everybody else to see what I'm doing
with three guys though I could kind of
move it a little bit maybe we'll do
something like that got to think about
that hi from India love your energy I'm
going to give you a little heart for
that love you back uh Amazon is at 554
per the share is that where we're right
that 554
Andy I love my view what up Gary what up
Q it's good to see you in here great to
see you in here um we are now three
hours six minutes into our stream
feeling great love from Vermont go
Dolphins no way Jamie but great to see
you Jamie did you buy books I need to
know
that want want to buy some books for
some people thank you Trinidad nothing
in the come to Miami I'm on possibly
Miami hungry good to see you just bought
the audio book thank you James eight is
[__] great you were right Obsession
uh what up what up to you 1,000 Vio club
boom is very aggressive on he says that
he was on daily V and he's like met with
you his name is Patrick finegan okay
he's very aggressive and wants to be on
the stream with you how many books you I
don't like got eight books yeah and he
says it's not enough Andy tell him tell
Patrick he's a really great guy and we
love him but great guy we need at least
32 32 yeah 32 oh 32 wow yeah yeah we're
tough I mean look if he's been if he was
on The Daily v he's already won there's
a lot of people here I've never
interacted with once we're hustling in
Houston big hugs Nicole great to see you
Nicole Pace love from Memphis you guys
sent the email right we did good
awesome let's see what else okay to
Creek G vco cards yes go ahead Jeremy
done official give away a Nick's trip
that's a good idea 890 in books are we
at
890 I have a thousand more books for you
Gary nice Wesley Chapman stepping up as
always got a big book by got a hit up
Alex D Simone he'll be very happy
um when does persistence cross over into
annoyance how do you walk a fine line
Dallas I think it's you know for Dallas
I know I owe you a email on your update
thanks for being on the show back in the
day it's good to see you in the Stream
Dallas it's it's a board you know listen
it's it's a balance it's a Cadence like
every time I'm on this book stuff people
start yelling at me and getting upset
that I'm throwing too many right hooks
where I didn't throw any for 18 months
and people and I'm always like God damn
it how does like a year and a half of
saying nothing or asking for nothing in
return and putting out all the for free
answering all that for free meeting and
free like just like how does that not
translate and it doesn't for some people
so I think it's the eyes of the beholder
that's trying to judge you on if you're
giving enough in return and the market
is the market and so one you've got to
find Big Ups Poland you got to find your
balance right what works for you and uh
and then you take it from there Ava
Grace Fashions thanks for the share
right now when I'm not asking for it big
UPS um yeah one Library TV One 2001 was
amazing we didn't talk we didn't we
didn't we didn't talk enough about that
I want more right hooks Craig here's a
right hook Craig I'm not letting you
hide now Craig MCU how many books did
you buy there's the right hook here we
go Craig go Craig everybody watching at
home Craig let's see what happens with
Craig Craig M let's see what happens
with Craig you're 56 in the top hot new
releases on Amazon UK let's go UK Craig
bought eight Craig here's my right hook
I want eight more from you now let's
wait and see what happens let's see if I
landed my let's see as Craig
contemplates what he does with the other
eight did I done look at my man Craig my
man Craig let's go
Craig Craig where you from Gary tell us
about success University in Dallas Big
Talk in Dallas coming up Craig's in for
16 he's gonna get back in here Scotland
now I'm gonna be in Dublin right Craig
do you know about my Dublin
trip Craig just stepped up now UK is
number 56 overall
it's possible because everybody is
getting fired up from my London and and
I know that Alex is working on
Manchester sale that looks like it's
falling apart it's not coming in yet
there's Scott there's Dublin Denver
what's up when are you in Chicago
nothing yet top new releases yes I'm
coming to London Craig my man I'm going
to hug it out with you bought two
Norwich UK Gina Bell love
you AQ thank you for the invited to
followers Pittsburgh who is that kid
Patrick so Patrick hustle is B on
respect sending you a screenshot he's
Give Them All to and models rappers and
models I do want rapper and model I
don't care you don't care who I mean
it's cool if he wants to give to rappers
and models as long as he tends to rece
you know Patrick is right the young kid
that was oh there yeah he's awesome he's
awesome uh funny combo rappers and
models so weird that's my favorite
combo Dino it's good to see you thanks
for being on man Loren with a z 193 oh
1913 in books UK got it conch good to
see you I want to give away eight books
do it Drew Drew someone said if we put
Burns Baby Burns eight books that was an
amazing dinner for in steakhous Gary how
do I decide I just want you to know I
bought 32 books in November I know Wes I
know brother trying to buy Sri Lanka but
it's still on pre-order it's on
pre-order everywhere Big Ups to Toronto
Dublin is cool yes it is honk honk
Obsession good to see you let's restart
Periscope it's only at 370 soon as we
restart it gets right back up 6700 you
went to Burns and Tampa of course I've
been Burns dude biggest Spike ever on
the business side is Kade talking about
the biggest Spike he ever got on the
business side is he asking me that
question or is Kate talking about uh the
spike we just gave his business I feel
we just mentioned it wouldn't be that
easy to find but Kate I'm super pumped
actually you know what like I'm super
pumped that we were able to talk about
your your business naturally what's that
it just happened yeah super fun what's
for lunch I'm fasting right you're
you're going to have a shake and then
you're going to have dinner today got it
Gary how do you not let everyday life
get in the way of your your hustle my
everyday life is my hustle the mention
you spiked my sight yes Kade got a spike
on his sight Kade you deserve the
business man people if you if you have
content that needs to be transcribed you
were blown away I was skeptical I'm
kidding Kate I'm always Kidd but you
guys were pumped yeah D Rock more pumped
than you actually cuz I want I want to
see what happens with yeah Andy Andy's
tough
trouty I knew it you did I knew
trout
John somebody give me trout Scott give
me
trout trouty man I own Wine Library on
Snapchat he was I own wine on Snapchat
by the way wine that's why I don't
that's why I I need 20 people to send 20
people to hey trout hey how are you pull
up a chair okay I'm going to be on the
Super Eight see what I came prepared
with today oh my God trout this is rare
this was the least this is the one that
I made the least of show ajv hey you're
coming later I thought thank you me I'm
just saying what's up cool how's it
going it's going quite well we're
selling some
books uh fun D dck yeah dr's doing very
little everybody else is working dck
you're not doing we doing a lot we're
doing a lot do you think deck's [__]
doing a lot
compar it's going well we had some peep
stop in Jen and stock Smith and somebody
got me peeps got me balloon internally I
love it cool eight yeah like trout trout
bought brought the rarest wristband this
is the rarest one yeah show it trout
again trout watch this this is
crazy official bids oh God for trouty r
thank you economy wristband very rare
very rare official bids you put a dollar
amount in the Stream right now and it's
taken as official thing he'll take in
PayPal this is real I'm dying chefette
for 200 chefette he's gonna take your
200 bucks so I want official only five
bucks for Jeff it seems real that seems
real Facebook come in here 25 for Manny
Hernandez 15 from Chris Green Chris
Green would go Chris Green how many
books did you buy Chris Green is a
[__] buyer AJ get back here we have
can we have them reinvest the money into
book buys and then we'll just send them
The
Wristband I'll be back around three all
right
AJ 215 bucks from Conor who's only 16
and sitting in a dark gym in his high
school right now it's real cash that's
real cash guys pay attention these this
is real money 80 bucks now people are
just putting lower bids because they
they know they're in good shape CU 250
is real chefette is really at 225
Conor's really at 250 this is [__]
real we might be able to dig up some
I'll buy eight more books for it I do
want books do you have some than economy
pels here at home at home okay Chef
that's up to 265 265 Kira kirma Luna's
at 260 super fun in her uh group Georgio
at 50 bucks but that's not going to make
it no love just bought 95 Tony Caruso
you just bought 95 I'll give you [__]
love for days is that true let's confirm
that Tony Caruso talk to me real quick
love you Tiffany is in for 2501 300
bucks Chef Lizette at 300 270 all right
hold on I need to make more of these
wristbands this is real [__] I make some
real [__] books I'm never writing
another book I'm just going to I'm just
going to make wristbands just going to
start a huge wristband like company all
right I you can figure out if you want
to sell this wristband trouty what's
your social so you can really get into
it trouty on Twitter t r o u t y no you
take it this is yours don't mind you
hold on to it okay I want you to take it
we got enough to do besides selling your
wristband trouty on Twitter t r o u t y
okay and that's where they should hit
you up that's where you should hit me up
or SnapChat trout monster you're the
trout monster yeah got to build up that
follow on Snapchat it's my weakest
Channel and that and that username is
trout monster trout
monster and on Instagram follow me there
too trout monster the the wink was
amazing I saw the win the wink was you
fell for it no I just thought it was
good do you think is charming yeah to
thanks guys means a lot love you guys
than later bye trout monster bye trout
Monster by guys my homies are in a trout
on a chat Carlos Gil good to see you
brother Periscope 2 yes Periscope yes
mircat yes Facebook live call me Tony
Caruso that's done Tony Caruso bought 95
he's asking me to call him I want one of
you Manning or womaning Facebook live or
tweet me please go do Facebook live
comments there's a lot going on there
and I don't think we're doing the right
thing like there's we're too much in
spre
cast Tony did buy 95 did buy 95 he's
sending them to us but he used the wrong
address so what do you mean the wrong
address he used like 251 Park EV I don't
know if that was a prior I don't
understand what does that mean he's
shipping books here okay but he used the
wrong address our old address or
something I guess so what Tony cruo
bought 95 hello we got you Tony I see
you brother really appreciate it you got
him and he's jumping in right now Tony
you bought 95 and you why didn't you buy
96 that would give him eight official
entries
no that's not my math which 12 excuse me
864 uh this Chris band is [__] beast
this is Beast we're gonna do something
with this you know what I got it I'm
giving this away because I love you guys
don't make people buy like they're gonna
buy not I'm giving this away and then
I'm going to answer some questions
because I want to get we did a little
hoo-ha and now we're so the crush at
wristband who wants
it who wants the crush at wristband I
want to see I Want I Want I Want I Want
I Want I Want I Want I Want I Want I
Want there we go look at Periscope at
504 I love it 504 in the morning book
Squad look at all those me I want a lot
of wants and spr out there's Facebook
live blowing up your cat doing its thing
me me me me here we
go wristband
time here we go this person has just won
this wristband Tony Tony cuso got him
there's a lot of
comments here we go you guys aren't as
interested in know you're
working I'm
interested New York brookin where you at
Brooklyn if you live oh no this is
from Ontario Canada steps up Canada is
awarded The crushit Wristband and the
winner is Andrew Fado Fato Fato F I
can't read that's like it would really
help in moments like this help me here
Andrew are you here Andrew you here
Andrew are you here Andrew are you here
fog a fog a
Andrew Ontario boom Andrew congrats
congrats congrats where's Andrew shiv
Patel big
up Lauren want to move to London and
work for you okay apply this is Spence
Lind this
suspense Mohamed good to see you Canada
boom funky fairy good to see you bro I
me Summit should buy books for everyone
agreed Carlos I'm buying 29 books Gary
and plan on giving them away on Scopes
can you show me some love 100% at real
estate preneur big loves giving books to
Tim K DOA do
media for the non-americans please
explain SE Super Eight all right one
last time at Super Eight then I'm going
to throw somebody on the spre cast here
uh we do and then we'll we'll answer
some questions and then are you good
with uh Andrew because I want to call
him Andrew or I'm sorry Tony cuso Tony
yeah I have what's that he just wants
you to watch video how long is
it okay I'll watch it it's 3 minutes 47
seconds that's long but I'll watch it he
bought 95 okay not eight but two thank
you glass go with thank you Paul Chris
Green or Patrick first Patrick for sure
why is Chris Green getting on he
deserves it he sold a lot of books for
you I know I love Chris Green but I want
to make him buy
more Patrick what's up what up
Patrick that's a crazy ass shirt you
wearing I'm good man Parker snare Glick
hey Tony says he does you know okay how
you doing man Conor is gonna be he's
been ask I'm doing well I'm doing well
Conor messaged me that he's gonna be
your assistant so that's exciting yes
I'm GNA hang out with Conor talk forth
so exciting Chris Green B 88 Chris
Green's the best yo go ahead Patrick
when are you going to do a huge La what
go ahead do your
thing I said when are you going to do a
huge launch party for your book in New
York City you know I'm doing a small
event at the 92nd Street y um which is
on uh on my site right now gary.com uh
but uh I'm trying to think about what I
want to do I might come back like I
haven't decided that believe it or not
that may be it or I might do a blowout
thing I haven't really decided but it
sounds like you got a ton of rappers and
models so you know that might make me
want to uh well we're having drinks with
J we're having drinks with James and
that that will get to then you get Diddy
you
know right there I love it funish we
might have to do that um I wanted to ask
I I wanted to ask you if you had any
thoughts about you know what talked
about I mean I have probably not no no
it's right I like the hustle I you know
there well like I told you in the
meeting we had there's a one major thing
that I have to like get through on like
conflict shops like it's a corporate
structure thing for Vayner um but I will
have that figured out by St Patty's Day
and I and listen you know what I think
about you I think you're a straight
winner you're going to win I like and by
the way I'm saying you're going to win
right now not to make you feel good I'm
saying because this is being recorded
and when you go and win I could be like
cool told you about [__] Twitter told
you about Snapchat told you about
[__] Patrick Flynn so I think you're
gonna win and so I'd like to figure out
some [__] I just uh I want to make sure
I can answer your your guys question
first if there's something to do within
an Invader environment and if not then I
want to have a question with I want to
have a conversation with you of like
what do we do
next yeah and James also wants to talk
to you cuz like you know I mean that
that's a possible Vayner client you know
because Diddy has Revolt he has
aquahydrate with Mark wallberg but he
was saying you know he's a manager like
he was saying like I saw 50 I saw Diddy
like you said the same thing you said
this is a talent bu like I don't have
that many that much skills I don't have
that much experience so what is it
really it's Talent it's talent and so
it's like may maybe maybe it's like
working with v maybe you an advisor you
I don't know what it is I know I know
what it is I know what it is you're a
16-year-old kid that's 16
right 19 19 sorry about that because I
know when at 19 when you're 19 you don't
want to be 16 I [__] RI my [__]
arms off to be 16 um I look like I look
like I'm 16 don't worry when I was
[__] 19 I looked like I was six and
um I think you're going to win and so
we'll figure it out so I'll get you some
information soon I promise you will hear
you will 100% here for me before the end
of
March definitely and I'll see you at
hunted fish you're going to love James
you and James are like can't wait love
it brother thank you so much for
supporting the book Thank You India
sorry for annoying you wor you didn't
annoy she she appreciated your hustle I
got it Facebook live talk to me are we
are we calling we're calling oh yeah if
you want to call first yeah let's call
It's Milan he's in Italy we're calling
Milan yeah we're playing Milan who's
Milan That's Tony Caruso oh that's
that's okay let's do it okay plus
sign do your thing oh crap Facebook
mentions where'd you go Facebook crashed
okay cool Facebook
crashed Meer cat remember when I didn't
know what a mircat was yes I that was
crazy I literally didn't I was like
what's a mircat like I thought he made
it up like and everyone was like no Mir
cat's like a real animal I'm like no
it's not Facebook sucks Periscope is
where it's at we're still yes you are
email me I have 18 left oh somebody's
giving away books I love that show us
the black poster what's up with that
that is some of the offers there's 300
books if you want to do the group thing
there's 1,000 books if you want to do
the one-on-one session uh Maryland I
can't wait to see you either here we go
hi Tony Tony let's get Tony on the
speaker Tony what up my
man what's going on G things are well
thank you so much for
supporting oh well thank you I sent you
I don't know if you're remember who I
was but you uh I sent you a video
hopefully you'll see it it's like three
minutes but uh I you called up the
lurkers I I sent you a comment you asked
one time how how much would I pay per
show I said $10 per book there was 183
shows I Ed that by 10 I divide it by the
price of the book and that's why I
bought 95 books you're unbelievable
brother thank you so so much I can't I I
will 100% watch the video and dck and
Indie and Andy can tell you I don't
think I've consumed the video ever like
I don't watch any
I have no time thank you for the hearts
Periscope I love you for that that's an
explosion um and I really really really
really appreciate um uh Todd the the the
300 book deal does not include the
flight to New York I apologize um uh
Tony so what uh what's going on where
where in
Italy I'm in Milan Italy I'm from
Brooklyn New York I've been here for 20
years I have h a chiropractic practice a
holistic Clinic here which is one the
biggest in the country I also thought
out a fund in 1998 like yourself and
when you see the video you'll figure
that out and nothing you just put out
the best information on the planet for
business it's incredible a lot of people
don't get it because of the [__] the
curse and all that [__] but like first
five seconds I heard you I got it you
were speaking to the choir so I really
appreciate all the stuff you're putting
out and I uh just thanks for letting me
be a testimony to while you're kicking
ass I appreciate you brother I'm uh I I
definitely going to be in Italy I think
in the next 12 to 18 months it's it's on
my mind and uh and your city's on my
mind so there might be a really good
chance that we can hug it out drink a
little voo if if [__] Michel muscle
mic let the the video the video I sent
you is three minutes 30 seconds please
watch it I I will 100% watch it and I'll
email you and prove it to
you thank you so much thank you brother
thank you so much for the support it
means a lot to me today today's a big
day thank you thank you
bye all right huh yeah it's going 3
hours and 27 minutes in we've sold some
books books we've put out some good
content I know some people have been
saying it's a little too right hooky but
I think they're liking this new
perspective they like this new what is
this I'm saying oh for you yeah let's do
that are you gonna blow up Sydney when
you're here uh no I'm gonna be in and
out unfortunately
uh Kima I'm really excited about your
community I want Kim's Community to
really blow up the books I think I think
kimra can do something big he just out
another 88 book who did Chris bought
another 88 on top of the 88 that's what
D Simone just walked in here to tell us
no no he said he bought the 88 he didn't
buy us one you're TI by the same thing
one time 88 but he sell a lot before
that he just bought no he's the best I
mean come on the Lego thing he's the
best yeah he's the best I still want to
make him hold out for the CU I think
that just made him laugh put him on put
him on and you know what I'm gonna I'm
going to do something with you guys real
quick while Periscope and do something
with you while I put Chris Green on I'm
going to go like this green he's got the
Mount Ida College hat
what uhoh more more let me see looks
like a small
snack it's a solid stack how now there's
some 16s and 24s in there yeah there's a
few in here and another I'm about to hit
a 30 I feel like we don't have a lot of
56s Gabe I don't think I've seen a 56
today what Gabe your volume down up
brother what up brother hey what's going
on is the book yes is this for the book
love it now Gabe what
Nate Garrett I'll be with you in a
second I like the m a shot Nate is it
true that you bought the first copy of
the askar review book period in the
world story because I sent you the link
and notified yeah called out
congratulations Nate thank you now did
you buy seven more to enter into the
Super Eight I did not because you know
an hour with me is hard I know I'm try
to get it every week and how many weeks
have you been able to successfully get
it zero years no no when you were my
assistant how many of you have
interacted with Nate when he was my
assistant that's a good
question choice you want to get in here
I'm
curious now choice choice you're in our
Fantasy Baseball League I am you you
went for it last year even though we all
advised you not to right and you almost
stole it at the end right but you didn't
but I didn't and now you have no chance
of winning this year no okay very good
thanks for stopping by do you want to
give do you want to give a shout out to
your social media sure do you want
followers or no they're gonna come I
always like followers okay go ahead find
me at the right choice the right choice
with the Y so it's c h o y c e the right
choice one more time spell it out the
right choice the right choice c h o y c
e Twitter or Snapchat and now do you
regret going all in for it last year and
now having no shot to win this year
after many people that were smart aka me
told you not to do that
no but you didn't win right okay till
you try I have a meeting actually do I
all right good to see people working
seems like seems like WN seems like
winners have things to do it seems like
choice just wants to hang
out love you Choice have a great day
brother all right Garrett good job you
want this post after Garrett leaves
honor you can do it I love you boom all
right man here we go we're going to your
cat all right Facebook live doing its
thing we're mixing up it's getting
getting good right all right Garett can
we hear you
Chris hey
brother what's up man I appreciate the
uh the big screen right here to give a
bunch of shout out how you
doing I'm doing well always excited to
talk to you always want to give you a
big thanks or for all that you do U
basically just taking your advice works
yeah let's talk about that give me an
update on on how that
works well every time I think about
asking a question on Ask Gary ve I'm
like I know what Gary ve is GNA answer I
just the search engine is gonna help for
that too yeah the search engine is gonna
be amazing started linking to people so
Chris what had to represent oh my God
Chris put that back on show me the
wristbands one more time the jab
wristband the Wine Library TV wristband
you wanted the crushing wristband
huh I can't believe it went for 300 I
mean like good for whoever got it but
man you should just sell those straight
up yeah no I'm I'm shutting everything
down Vayner media done Wine Library done
the G brand done I'm 100% going to sell
wristband for a
living interesting wait they weren't
supposed to tell you how many books I
bought because I was going to tell you I
only bought
11 but I meant 11 entries I know man I'm
super pumped so what's going on with you
man what what can I answer you or like
what can we talk
about well I I would like to get you
away from the eBay hustle cuz I know the
eBay hustle I know you know the eBay
Hustle the hustle that is 10 20 times
eBay is the Amazon hustle yeah that's
what everybody's saying tell me your
best Amazon flip tell me your best
Amazon
flip oh I don't we spent like 97 Grand
at a Home Depot one day and uh broke
apart power to combo kids sold it on
Amazon
that's
you it's a term we call Retail Arbitrage
you buy off at detail and flip it on you
don't have to go to garage sales flea
markets all that but I love the hunt
yeah know I get it it's crazy what's
going on with your Echo right
now I don't know I thought it was you I
don't think so if I want to respond to
someone yeah I I do it there Pedro yeah
Pedro wants to know where I can buy
eight books I just want Pedro I mean you
can just talk to him because um Chris so
you're basically
saying that forget garage sing forget
all this stuff like just go to the store
buy [__] and then post it on Amazon and
make
money yeah use your phone to do your
homework and the
barcode see what it's selling for on
Amazon I mean you can make 100 Grand on
eBay you can make two three 400 Grand on
Amazon though and I mean I love it I
love it I mean it's it's I really
believe in that like I believe anybody
that loves buying and selling should
really just run Arbitrage on Amazon and
eBay I really believe that you know and
you're right I do say eBay even though I
know Amazon's like winning that game I
say eBay like the slang term for
flipping I better start clarifying more
you know like I get it I see it every
day I get emails every
day super into it I see it what you for
me I got another I sold 50 more today to
another guy so up to 350 on my special
offer I appreciate it brother thank you
so
much it's all good I'm GNA keep pushing
it I'm trying to get many people here to
to spre cast man you're the first person
to use free cast in a long time yeah I
know they've got some new stuff coming
up the CEO hit me up so I'm excited to
see what's gonna
happen no just a man I I believe in spr
cast has to well listen it's now
competing with Facebook live Periscope
you know mircat it got competitive
he perfect segue Gary because this was
an actual question I have my answer but
I'd love to hear your answer goad all of
these live platforms mirat Periscope
Facebook live hold on one second hold on
one second Chris Alex no excuse me Todd
just bought the 300 book deal I need to
understand that on spr cast because I
want to give him a kiss in his face
super pumped I was pinging with him you
were pinging with him huh boom he says
does the 300 book deal include a flight
to New York I just bought 300 book deal
we have to find out what's going on
there so go ahead
Chris I think you need to give people
advice as to when to be live and why to
be live because I would say if you don't
have to be live Don't Be Live am I right
or listen it's a it's a it's a same old
game right it's hard to be good live
yeah it's hard to be entertaining it
it's hard to be interesting I one of the
things that I want to see way more from
Periscope and Facebook live and mircat
is breaking news events like there
should be way more stuff going on on
Twitter where a water main breaks or you
know like a a non-fatal car accident
like you know I'm a little weirded out
because a lot of this stuff ends up
being rubbernecking and bad or good
things right like I want to see somebody
go on Facebook live where they walk a
lady an older lady across the street
like break why can't we start a movement
that breaking news on pariscope and
mirat and Facebook live are predicated
on good deeds in society that'd be cool
like an up worthy for live like why
can't one of you establish your
brand why can't one of you establish
your brand as the person that literally
runs around life and Records there's the
level of the level
of kindness and good stuff like if I had
nothing as a platform right now nothing
right like if I had time on my hand if
time was my asset I would tomorrow start
a periscope Facebook live or mircat
predicated on walking around my
town sometimes taking a train ticket and
capturing nice events it happens all the
time like kindness TV like it would be
huge it would be huge it would be so
cool it'd be so
cool why are you guys so silent because
you're thinking about how cool this is I
totally agree of course
Chris people got to do it listen it's
[__]
work gooded and and it's hard right
because you're walking around somebody
said don't be non creepy way that's a
good call KR to you dude R squar what's
up buddy like I got I just got 30
emailed you Jared thank you so much like
our we'll get them in here five minutes
um uh I think it would be super cool I
think somebody would have a really big
show dck what do you think you know
what about someone doing it themselves
like their whole stick is going and
helping people that's fine too and I
mean like real [__] like like just
carrying somebody's back like stand
outside a
supermarket see somebody that needs help
whether it's an elderly person whether
it's somebody with three kids now listen
society's gotten to a place where they
may be scared and they think that you're
pranking them or stealing their
groceries I get it but over
like it be really cool it'd be really
cool
I don't know I'm like people are hungry
for positive there's so much negative
because I agree man I agree Chris like
why not and then somebody says monetize
that how I'll tell you how every Fortune
500 brand in America wants to be
associated with good our client Dove
would love to be associated with that
like like I don't I can't think of a
single brand like literally this episode
of kindness TV is brought to you by X
and they probably pay Jesus I don't know
a th000 to 10,000 dispending on your
audience side for the day to be
associated with such a good
thing um Breeze stop swearing I it's
just not going to happen I've tried so
hard sure I'm a uh where am I looking at
Dr I mean you would look there's a lot
of places to look I'm a uh I'm a
recovering corporate lawyer uh turned
Ultra endurance athlete uh written a
couple books Finding Ultra the plant
power way and decided I was going to
change my life and adopted a plant-based
diet had all this energy started working
out again I'd been a swimmer in college
but where' you grow up in DC in DC I
live in LA now but I grew up in DC I
used I lived in New York for many years
as well um and uh started working out
again and one thing led to another and I
found myself just wrapped by the idea of
ultra Endurance Sports and entered some
crazy double Iron Man competitions and
did really well there's a double Iron
Man yeah yeah so I do a race called
Ultram man which is a 320 m double Iron
Man distance Triathlon that
circumnavigates the big island of Hawaii
I don't even like following Andy around
twice down the
court yeah and then I did a thing in
2010 called epic 5 where I did five Iron
Man's on five Hawaiian Islands in a week
so that kind of put me on the map and
got me a lot of media attention also
because I was doing it all on a vegan
diet like no animal products and people
were really interested in that story are
you vegan yeah vegan but when you said
plant-based diet does that I'm not
educated enough does that mean you're
vegan or that means you're even more
intense than vegan or meaning not more
intense a different version of that well
you can you can eat vegan and eat potato
chips and Oreos all day long right so
plant-based really means like uh yeah
plant-based means eating plant like high
nutrient dense plant vegan based on on
animals well yes so no animal products
is honey like a big vegan debate yeah I
don't really get too caught up in the
minutia of it you know most people are
are you know addicted to terrible diets
you know fast food lifestyle stuff like
that on sugar was my sugar was my life
yeah and you made the change right I
made the change and you look 10 years
younger than you did I mean I'm 49 now
I'm turning soon so I'm thriving on it I
feel great I continue to be able to go
out and kill it I ran for 2 and a half
hours this morning and you know I feel
awesome so so yeah I'm I'm sort of a
Wellness evangelist and lifestyle
entrepreneur I guess it's really cool
yeah Andy what do you think you think
you're going to start getting do you
want to do a double Iron Man with me
I'll start with one let's do it man I
you know what so so Mike really kicked
me into gear and I think you know he's
Mike's done in July so two-year thing my
next trainer is going to be three years
and I I've been thinking a lot about
like I might go a little bit longer in
this cuz I'm just doing it for the first
time ever I never worked out I was not a
swimmer but I definitely think there's a
chap the whether it's the next chapter
or the chapter after that I'm going to
go way more cardio way more biking and
swimming and running like right now I'm
just eating healthy getting a little
stronger but I can see that becoming a
real thing yeah I love it and you know
swimming's great you know it's It's
Tricky for a lot of people learning how
to swim later in life but by way suck at
swimming I I suck at you would do you
want to know my swimming story pounding
yeah I want to hear it let so I was
scared crapless of I was scared of
everything as a kid hi PL water dogs
bees everything um and cuz the bees
weren't vegan except for talking no I
loved talking and I wasn't scared of
people and I wasn't scared to S you know
I was scared to swim at 5 but I would
ring your doorbell and sell you [__] so
that's who I was right so we're at the
swim club all I'm doing is playing knock
hockey you know knock hockey no it's
it's like a hockey board where it's got
the cube in the middle and you can like
do the thumbsy and you remember that
[__] yeah yeah yeah so I'm playing knock
hockey and then out of nowhere my sister
who's three and a half years younger
than me starts swimming uhhuh like like
I hear like Yay she's swimming I
literally run India pay attention here
I'm listening this is real insight I get
up I run from knock hockey and I jump
into the pool and basically within four
minutes learn how to swim and literally
that's how I learned how to swim you did
I was eight just get thrown into the
fire I just I tried to disguise that my
sister swam before me I was like no no I
got it I got it was it was this it was
and that's it that is that the only time
you've ever swam no we're uh Dr Rock get
in here uh Andy I got um it was uh no no
I've swam a bunch since I can swim I can
swim I'm not good at it but I can swim
but it's a great workout oh it's a real
workout Mike Mike um Mike
uh and I swam early in our workout
session I was dead yeah dead yeah yeah
yeah like when we travel on like
vacation I'm always scared I'm like when
he sees the pool we're like in Vancouver
on business there was a big pool we're
walking into the he looked at it I was
like oh [__] I'm so scared I was like
please God Don't Make Me swim get you in
the pool and sort you out okay we'll
talk about that stroke work with you I
like stroke work yeah I I don't know how
to do it I'm not a good are you a good
swimmer India no I like swimming but I'm
not good Andy you feel like you got a
good swimmy build I do have a swimmers
build but uh one time I was at a oh
shit's getting the only time I've
actually ever really swam I was at um a
swimming event for my step sisters and
they just needed an extra swimmer
they're like hey can you swim freestyle
you're like I guess and they just threw
me in what happened it was all right I
came in last yeah I get it when I was a
kid it was just it was the one thing
that I was good at I wasn't good at
anything else so I just that that was
your selfesteem that was I think for
sure where where can everybody find the
podcast uh Rich Roll podcast on iTunes
Rich roll.com I'm rich roll on Twitter
and all those places Andy I am rich roll
on Snapchat yeah I see you got Louis's
book over here right my man so leis uh
Le is my man too there's a whole like
he's got a whole chapter in in here the
whole like physical body chapter here is
all is my story so you got check out
Lou's book it's awesome yeah man so much
see yeah looking for to take thank you
thank you so much take care of yourself
that was fun thanks for letting me yeah
of course super fun all right let's get
back to some super fun stuff what's that
just bought 500 bucks excuse me c yes
who I love yes another 500 she put
another 500 she's she's getting ready
I'm going to put her on she's
unbelievable she just says blue hair
first of all is unbelievable talk her on
the phone one time she's super cool
she's so talk to me Gary Can you spot me
for eight bucks yes Sheldon done boom
Sheldon ask Sheldon got Sheldon got
eight books done on me stunwin get his
ass on uh get my receipt Craig will
double check Chicago uh by the way
that's the only person I'm spotting he
got it Sheldon won just the way it is uh
turps I'm coming to Maryland um super
eight is about the following bad doing
this but someone bought this for you oh
my God this is
amazing St look at this look at this
hold on before stunwin steals the show
look at this cake is this
unbelievable who's it from
mdl love it I can't eat it thank you so
much mdl up stage by Bak Goods yes
you're getting upstage by Bak Goods
Steve stunwin how's the stream this is a
very how are you Steve very uh I'm good
I'm on 12 I can actually just to the
fish bowl right now no no you stay on 12
and work we'll do our thing please don't
come here do not come up here this
setting this setting is not nearly as
cool as the All Day Live stream you did
for that was me you Dio you already on
camera get out of here we already
exposed you as a fraud on Tinder get out
of there Dio um Steve who was that me
you Nate and
Phil PL me you Playa meu Playa and
Nate and Phil yeah out out in the middle
of uh Connecticut and Phil yeah now
Steve did you buy your eight
books I have purchased a book thank
you now have we discussed the idea of
just doing pre tax deductions from
media's paycheck no we haven't done that
but you know what that's a great idea as
a matter of fact Steve will call it the
Unwin rule they can all come to you I'm
just going to deduct eight eight books
worth of stuff from everybody uh what
did you just do just put that on the
screen you just covered Steve's face I
didn't you just covered me with a coupon
yes that was amazing do that again stun
one I love you what's going on on
12 uh working really hard doing lots of
fun stuff fun fun client stuff that I
probably can't talk about on the stream
yep how's how's the team all
good yeah they're good here come hold on
say hi what's up gang a lot of people
are
gone what's up gang you're on the
internet
the internet is huge it's gonna win hey
guys amazing all right someone I gotta
get back to work I love you see you all
right some one is gone thank God all
right no more spotting Mike Hunter I'm
sorry so what's the breakdown buy eight
books or 16 or 24 what does that mean
can I still get the audio book Sean you
can get the audiobook what we're doing
oh Garrett they're still coming in
that's a nice thick stack I like thick
Stacks smells good send in your receipts
8 16
24 32 still haven't seen the the
nobody's bought 56 yet I want seven
entries in one shot for two books no gr
kill kill them kill them um so uh ritell
was in the house he's gone now it's a
this is a good-looking stack this is a
great stack thank you guys all so much
for buying the book today and supporting
me means a lot to me eight books gets
you in the game uh gets you a receipt
that puts you directly in the bucket
what is this
I and and got to keep them coming bunch
of receipts in here drock should we give
should we give something
away what should we give away how about
a personalized book what 2 o' uh let me
let me give away some of
your what about your time
a all right we're going to yeah let's
give something away what do I want to
give away is there go find something
swaggy in my office yeah go find
something I put this right
there all right what's going on hey GV
I'm back had to do a Skype with a client
great job Melissa mayare you're getting
a thumbs up for that can give some
thumbs up right now one-on-one goger
let's go Gina's got krock sign my book
subscription box marketing what about it
I believe in it Bark Box Birchbox Faith
box I'm in any more info on Dublin yet
Alex what's the info on Dublin Chef list
that is back good to see that swaggy Big
Ups IA Garrison good to see you mark
Constantino Jr I love that dude connect
with us on Twitter
um uh sorry just checking up on my
business uh just ordered my eight Anna
Ross you did it I've been watching that
carefully sign Jets Jersey that's not a
bad idea de I've debated that will you
go to Brazil Gary's like a social media
conductor conducting conducting uh 300
books I'm back online Todd's back online
with 300 books in the spr cast let's
talk to
him Todd is back eight books from Scott
I
appreciate give this away or this let's
give this away this is amazing this is
probably how much is this prob I'm up
right now oh my God these are the music
Headlights this is from Twitter this is
insane yeah this is insane I'm telling
you guys this is insane these things are
legit somebody's gonna sh it when I get
this I'm jealous yeah you want this
right all right why not just buy the
book uh gal you could do that as well
but we're just having some fun today
little uh Super Eight just enjoying
ourselves have lunch with Gary ve and
Phoenix best way to Market subscription
boxes Facebook ads uh blogs a lot of
ways to do it I'm G to get you know what
I'm going to give this away right now
and I'm going to get really hardcore I'm
going to go speed round answering like
I'm going to pump out a lot of business
information D Rock get ready what's that
we'll put Todd so I'm going to give this
away we're going to give we're going to
get Todd on who going to come here it's
gonna be at bner media Todd's gonna make
daily V that's the other that's another
kicker by the way dck I got a kicker for
you everybody who buys 300 books which
is the big sign over there none of you
can see it but uh 300 books and uh you
get to be part of the group jam session
this is all on Gary banner.com actually
put up the barter stuff on the live
stream at the top gary.com
that's that's what we should put up
there so the'll understand of 300 and
the today's Super Eight just as I'm I'm
catching everybody up I'm about to give
this
away Shameless plug get in here get in
here yeah you can take it go ahead
Shameless plug time plug this this is a
podcast that I work on with my now
fiance and his friend so Shameless
plugging go ahead talk about it more and
it's a podcast where they do brackets
based on pop culture stuff so like we
just did Superior sidekick and we did
like powerful princess and we're about
to do Nick's tune for those who are into
cartoons so yeah what's the name mad
bracket status you can follow us on
Twitter Mad bracket stat and then we're
on Facebook and you can Google us real
quick and that I love you ladies why
don't you tell everybody you are Zach
yeah Zach's on it sometimes Michelle's
been on it yeah it's fun my embodied
disembodied voice has been on it I think
a huge mistake has been not asking me to
be on it I know because I don't know if
you've heard I've got a little bit of an
audience I know we've when well we've
asked stunwin and your schedule's been
booked stunwin
he never had power I know but I asked I
will do I will do it oh yes because I
love you I love you I do and I why don't
you to tell everybody a little bit about
what you guys do at Vayner oh uh so I'm
Caroline I'm a developer here um I guess
most recently I helped build Gary's
website so yes she did
architect uh I'm Michelle I'm a ux
designer and we're actually helping work
on wine library right now bang my ladies
thank you guys for stopping by great
Shameless plug punch you at Vayner could
learn something from these two fine
Hustler ladies all right so how can I
buy 100 at a time uh there's book
pal.com which is the way to buy the 100
at a time uh Jared thank you so much so
I'm going to give away this these are
[__] cool these are oh these I think
they were either invested in by Twitter
or there's some sort of so I'm going to
give away these headphones I'm gonna put
on Todd are you guys good you guys
feeling good good and then I'm gonna go
hardcore speed round I'm gonna answer a
b I'm just gonna go crazy and answer a
bunch of real questions bring you guys a
ton of value all right sound good uh
Facebook I want you to start sharing Up
Down Below let's share up share up share
up share up uh bring back this thunder
show Jake I did episode 101 the other
day
um all right here we go I already pulled
it or should I put this one back and
pull another one let's find out this
will be an interesting experiment this
for the headphones who thinks that I
should put this one back
in and pull another one or who thinks
that I should pick this
one put me onast pull another look
amazing they have some cool features
yeah these headphones are amazing guys
Google this up future of headphones no
these are
incredible got these Chris Green and
sell them on Amazon that's fine too keep
keep do it look at this keep keep that
one pick pick another one pick that pull
another one very interesting keep it I'm
going to keep it Andia okay all right
I'm keeping it so the music headphones
Andy take it away go
to by the way if you win this and you
said pick another one please explode on
the stream and say that's what we did or
if you said keep that one I'd love to
know if this is one of the people on
right now
yeah why don't you guys all do
it yeah I like it yeah yeah yeah here we
go yes I like it
boom it's going to the UK it's going to
the UK it's going to the
UK it's going to the
UK and it is going to Michael Charlton
Michael Charlton Michael Charlton
congrats Michael Charlton congrats
Michael are you here let's let's all say
congrats Michael let's all say congrats
Michael congrats let's all say congrats
Michael Michael are you here Michael are
you here I want to know if Michael's
here Michael be really great UK shout
out that's right Matt haris that's not
the guy that you talked to on the phone
that one night when we all I don't I
don't know I'm bad with names that's
great congrats Michael and uh good
really good work on speaking
[__] that Tracy Martin's upset congrats
Mike love all right cool ready for Todd
yeah ready for Todd Todd let's get you
on the cast if you're not on spree cast
Facebook Periscope mircat get over to it
guys this virtual book tour is a really
cool idea we're going to we're going to
have leaders a
leader what we what we're doing is
there's 23 bookstores that I'm
passionate about that I can't get to is
it 23 we can't be specific multiple
exactly it's
multiple thank God we're super alive uh
multiple bookstores that I'm super
passionate about we're GNA have some
leaders uh do a virtual book tour where
I'm gonna Skype in or bcast in or
Periscope what are we doing Skype Skype
uh and so if you live in these towns are
you going to pull up the addresses right
now the source I'll pull up the cities
can you pull up the name of the stores
in the cities we're not be specific
we're not we can't be specific got it so
we're going to tell people
but eventually we'll tell them where to
go right that I'm about to put all right
Andy's about to put a link on spree cast
want to read them it's Gary
v.com ask garv book- virtual D
jam-session if anybody caught that in
the other streams because it's on top
right now on it will be in a second on
on um on spree cast so the thousand of
you guys are all set um but everybody
else who's watching right now uh I'm
throwing it up
and uh and Andy's going to pull it up so
we're going to do a virtual bookstore
virtual book tour where I'm going to go
on for 30 minutes and talk to all of you
uh my big thing is that I'm asking for
15 books to be bought right at least 15
books at that bookstore right do we have
a date we don't have a date it's going
to be the week of the first of the book
release likely yeah got to figure out
the schedule 9th or 10th probably yeah
9th or 10th leaders here to cities and
so how there there's a URL let me give
the URL one more time for the people
that are really good at capturing up
there yes spr cast is fine but for the
rest of you Gary v.com asgar V book-
virtual
djam Das
session askar ebook Dash virtual Dash
Jam Dash session um so here are the
locations Tempi Arizona Corte Madera
California Cadena California San
Francisco
California Santa Cruz California Boulder
Colorado Denver Colorado Madison
Connecticut Washington DC Coral Gables
Florida naville Illinois Lexington
Kentucky Brookline Mass Cambridge Mass
OK
Michigan MI is what Michigan I think in
St Louis Missouri yeah St Louis Missouri
Oxford Missouri Missippi Ms is
Mississippi I thought Ms is a Missouri
this is
fford Mississippi Oxford Mississippi
Rybeck New York Portland Oregon
Nashville Tennessee Austin Texas Salt
Lake City Utah Manchester Center Vermont
Lake Forest Park Washington and
Milwaukee Wisconsin go to the URL it's
all listed there tons of details uh is
that you super I'm not yeah I'm nudging
you out a little bit super excited to
figure out who's going to be the leader
in those markets uh hopefully that will
be you I'm uh Boston is not confirmed is
Boston falling apart no definitely not
Boston's alive oh definitely a lot but
is it am I going to be able to fly
private from that night so she is the
ninth back in play yes
bang
bang guys see Alex go let's print some
receipts buy a book 1624 enter go in
here right go in here and uh one of you
will be flown to somewhere around the
world to spend a full hour with me where
I I am so going to rip that
hour like I'm so like I have to change
this person's business or life or
whatever it might not even be an hour it
might be a lifetime we can become
friends I'm going to care more after
that
hour yeah I mean look I'm busy as shits
I barely see my kids I'm not GNA hang
out with you for the rest of my life but
but I'm going to answer on email like
it's almost like a mentor that you know
what I'm going to save that mentorship
for life but that's going to be like 500
books on the next book and I need like
5,000 people to buy it I feel like I
just am holding on to this receipt I
think I'm just going to do something
random with this receipt I think I'm
going to call this person should I call
this person yes I'm going to Ben Alon o
l e y n i k get in touch with me Ben I'm
GNA call you and say hello
Ben all right here we go emotional toll
writing your book I'm gonna I'm going to
go dead all right here we go oh actually
I'm going to wait I'm going to wait for
Facebook live because there's a lot of
people there so get some coffee on the
table yeah I might need a little coffee
is right can I change my name to Ben
Gina you cannot what about Philly for a
virtual jam session not yet so
disappointed no Chicago me too I wish
somebody bought the 3500 to 5,000 books
that got me there how to convert
Instagram followers into sales throw
right hooks tell them that the link is
in your
url uh or halfway uh Chef lazette has a
surprise she's Onre we'll take a look at
that interesting ways to maximize snap
and insta as a musician put out content
put on content teepe will be fire Lionel
I hope you're there are you sure I'm
sure George I can't call you I am 12
what would you do if you were me be so
pumped that's what I I'd be so mean if I
was 12 I would be so pumped I would be
learning and I'd be reading like content
or watching content or whatever uh helps
you thanks for doing this Carri you're
welcome you are super welcome good
morning Gary good morning I know I know
Australia is starting to uh wake up
which is exciting um Periscope let's
share it up think Seth really reads a
thousand books a year I'm not sure Blake
I think it's he made it seem like uh
that he reads you know the first five
pages get a first five pages uh L thank
you for the invite I like the invites of
the followers Tyler Ty Guy what's your
opinion to Ty Lopez just getting know Ty
did one interaction with him so too
early to fully make that call but had a
a good time I almost made a big basket
his house which of your books would you
recommend people read first maybe don't
have as much cont ask scary B like it's
just really the combination of the four
books you know what I mean me they're
all my kids but I think you should read
ask scary B it's my current work and for
you Scott you know Scott that was for
you man that's really what I believe
Gary need to go back to work Gina you've
been here you've been so
great damn it and I love thank you
economy Matt you know that's my favorite
um but I really think I'm telling you
man I think Ask Gary ve is the right
book to start with if you haven't read
anything audio book is included right
audiobook is included so if you buy an
audiobook and you buy seven more books
on Amazon you send in both receipts they
know what to do to get you in uh the
audiobook is going to be a
beast uh for I'm back Andy my camera is
live That's Mike
convery is the audiobook included yes
Mike hey it's Zimmerman there's
Zimmerman let me stop the chat check
where is it l she Zim Jesus oh wow going
fast Zim get back in here I see want me
to put them on yeah put Zimmer I'm
listening to thank you economy thank you
so much how can I contact you um email
Gary atvan media.com I think I win just
Chad Gary vainer
media.com follow me on Snapchat I'm
going to try oh Snapchat would be good
where's this
guy we're gonna put um Mike on screen I
want to make sure what's up Snapchat
it's getting crazy here been in the room
three and a half hours in askary Super8
ton it's very
real I'm G to put this guy on I he said
he bought 22 they didn't find the email
so let's find
out Andy don't put them on yet I love
them but I need to do I need to answer a
bunch of business questions I think
we've been in like kind of like
whackadoo mode a little bit long enough
like I really want to go hardcore are
you on Facebook live yeah okay cool I
want to get this here I'm just going to
go crazy in and Facebook ad spend this
year uh I think it's an enormously
important platform I think it's
underpriced I think it's a great a great
great great great Market um I think
people are still underestimating it um I
think you can do great targeting I think
you can do look like audiences on your
crms or your email lists I think just so
much more to to do I'm a big big big big
big fan D Rock be careful uh best cheap
startup I don't know what that means but
Richie if you can ask that again let's
talk targeting there's unlimited
targeting capabilities Andy what do you
like
targeting give me give me and you you
love retargeting because it's so good
right like targeting Gary vaynerchuk
fans of Gary vaynerchuk on Facebook
because you guys don't see by the way
that's another thing let's bang that out
really quick on Facebook especially for
the Facebook
your Facebook yeah we need to the C
first thing is a big
deal like a really big deal like I want
a lot more of you to make sure you don't
miss content of mine on
um on uh Facebook and so this
[Music]
video love this
video it's in my Instagram by the way
did you guys see the Jamie Fox video
hey
miss this is really [__]
funny serious promise me I [__]
promise you [__] promise me [__]
promise you [__] promise I'm Legend
to
be so funny promise J was a good guy we
had a really good
session [__]
promise Dam it's time to get serious
about social you promise me I [__]
promise you you [__] promise me
[__] promise you [__] promise I'm
Legend to be baby it's time to get
serious about social promise me [__]
promise [__] promise [__] [__]
promise I'm a legend to be this is the
Facebook
[Music]
video
what do you need Maddie saari come on
Gary I'm here for you brother what do
you need for me please oh what just the
music just popping
sorry how would you invest if you how
would you invest if you only had $10,000
I would buy $110,000 wor a Facebook
stock that's what I would
do that's what I would do I'm a legend
JP
Salazar are you in North Carolina oh
that's somebody asking somebody uh
what's your opinion of website live chat
and its usefulness I think Mobile Live
Chat is tremendous but I think desktop
website um live chat is intriguing but
creating good content live is extremely
difficult and um I think too many people
underestimate it need help taking my
social media marketing agency from 20,00
a month to 30,000 4050 how do you come
back grown pains to blowing up where you
are Steve I you know I guess you're
asking me how to get clients to pay you
30 40 and 50k a month instead of 20
please come back make sure I see that I
I'll keep my eyes on this right now love
to hearing me show Wine Library that was
awesome I agree Wine Library TV episode
101 was so much fun big shout out to
Arkansas boom let me give that some
love email marketing tips for low open
rates Lauren really look hard at your
titles and what you're providing in the
the copy like like what's the email
about I'm a real and half of my audience
doesn't have Twitter or Facebook account
should I build my own mobile platform
using buddy
press I mean it's okay you could I mean
you know I don't think that if they
don't have Facebook or Twitter they're
going to be so pumped to download your
app either so something to think about I
think a lot of people get caught that
their people aren't unsocial and then
they try to build an app or a website
and they're not into digital at all so
something to keep in mind hi hi tensent
hey tensan Gary would love to get a
chance back video on spr cast real world
real wooden Warden all
right I don't uh we'll see what we can
do what's your opinion on burber's
social media stratch catwalks and Apple
TV and Snapchat steart I think burber's
trying to stay contemporary and relevant
and so I think it's super important what
they're doing um best advice given to me
was word is bond don't go back on it how
to promote content with having a spammy
look or maybe it doesn't matter no it
matters Ally like it's finding that
right balance of going in for the right
hook but jabbing uh having that Cadence
really really really
matters
um see what else what else I do
basketball skill development training
for kids what's a good idea to grow my
business I want to do online courses any
tips help you with your jumper I
actually need some help with my jumper
um look I think YouTube and Facebook are
an absolute place you've got to go
you've got to Target the psychology of a
parent you know all these parents want
their kids to go pro or at least pay for
college so you got to Target properly
against parents that are into sports um
that are that are fans of local gyms or
things of that nature that are fans of
athletes there's a lot of things you
could be going against and it's all just
content guys it just comes down to
Content really is is the content good
enough and that's the key that is the
key
advice on building a digital marketing
agency Maria know what you're talking
about hire good people sell clients do
good work keep the clients happy get
Word of Mouth invest your dollars back
into the business you know it's a whole
thing you know there's I mean that's it
I mean run a business right like you
know I don't know like you got to for
the strategy has to be on par you have
to have the people that are skilled
enough to create the content ENT if
that's where you want to go it's just
it's all grinding it's step one step two
step three Maria you know and I
appreciate the thank you but that's you
know that's what it is number one tip
for a 16-year-old
patience the 16-year-old that has 16
more years double your life is still
eight years younger than me GH that
hurt double that kid's life is eight
years younger than
me that
hurts um anchor update Auto correct
added no you wanted it Eric does that
mean it's on in M thing now like am I
good like am I fundamentally good like
did it update for me like am I in a good
place let's see App Store updates did
anchor update anchor updated beautiful
there we go let's hit the update
boom auto correct the audio I'm super
pumped about that going to do an anchor
right now going to do an anchor right
now anchor really intriguing new
platform what I love anchor you love it
uh-huh are you using it
yeah oops I just updated want Andrew to
be the their new hit song on it all
right here we go anchor anchor anchor
here we
go what up anchor which really means
what up Twitter too um uh good to see
all of you or I guess I don't see you uh
nice to have all of you listening to me
right now I really appreciate that I
actively live right now doing my super
eight for my new book askar V the best
book ever written by a human um well
there's been some really good books
written by elephants yeah no I'm super
excited about it I hope you come and
check me out
facebook.com Gary I'm on Facebook live
right now I'm on Periscope uh I'm on
spree cast I am on mircat come and check
it come and hang would love to see you
uh ankor I hope this works and that
would make me
happy
doing Super Eight done
boom publish boom there it is let's hear
it so it's anchor is an audio social
network it's really well done what up
anchor which really means what up
Twitter too um uh good to see all of you
or I guess I don't see you uh nice to
have all of you listening to me right
now I really appreciate that I'm AC live
right now doing my super eight for my
new book Ask I don't know why you can't
mute those yeah anchor notifications are
killing me
yeah Phil Phil Phil Campbell who I've
Loved engaging with Through The Years yo
Gary I've been watching for the last 4
hours 29 minutes you're doing well man
Phil I love you
brother guys I do not want these
notifications no likes no new followers
replies yes there we go boom FR okay
done okay better
what and it this Facebook post and like
it you want a grow hack a little bit is
this the Facebook in influencers on
Facebook you want them to like it yes
that's what you want right yes all right
let's do it uh go ahead put it
up what up
anchor which really means what up
Twitter
too has 11 replies so on anchor you put
out content anchor the app iphone only
from what I understand at this point
right and then and then people reply
Phil replied I'm going to turn off all
notifications even replies all right now
they're off so there's
mine if you're like in the app I think
it'll still tell
you I see you yes I hope I am the first
comment on this you're not Chris or
reply rather on this anchor as I'm
watching super Aid so great job on
superade really looking forward to
reading the book Gary uh hope everything
is going good take care thanks
brother mik that's the best UI when it
goes to the next reply I have all four
streams
going what up Gary Facebook live and
prast bought a books hoping to wear
hoping to win the one hour Big
Time Eric thank you for the update hey
this is William
young hey Gary I'm watching Super Eight
I'm watching you listen to this anchor
right now just pretty great I love what
you're doing and I'm glad that you're
making all these sales I hope you reach
your goals thank you brother Blake a
Mets
fan Christian Butler Christian
Butler very meta Blake tune in Gary
right now for the second time today I
had to go do some stuff but uh back in
sound like a booty
call Matt crane Matt
crane Gary V Matt crane here at I am
Matt Crane and hey man I'm locked in
with you for eight hours as a matter of
fact I'm so locked in I am sending you
an application right now to be your
party coordinator for the jam session in
Nashville Tennessee yes don't make
excuses baby make it happen a I have a
funny feeling it's going to be you dark
posts are basically Facebook ads Dan and
they're very very lening on Facebook
live Dr chitra Duram North Bergen New
Jersey Bergen
baby hey Gary welcome back to Anchor I'm
watching super a it's been really great
the past few hours looking forward to
seeing more content and I'm already in
with my books thank you darling see you
later on Periscope and Facebook see you
in a little bit back in the game Let's
do this brand a
[Music]
raw hey Gary um this is exciting I
actually signed out for the picked love
you Gaddy love you or Here Comes
Catherine the honey badger oh the honey
badger there she is you killing it love
that you're giving out advice thanks for
paying it forward loving your books
thank you honey badger Periscope
questions come on where where's all the
action I see too much of a future for
this unless they start integrating some
new stuff some ways to uh really build a
community of course bro but you got to
give it a few more seconds than it's
four [__] days old I don't see a huge
future for a four-year-old either hey
Gary Carlos Wilson here Carlos um loving
the uh the excitement today there is
real
excitement subscription box thesis is a
good anchor to get people into the
business model then you can resell them
stuff on top of love
it over here Fusion soft and we have
Phoenix find a mentor is a good question
you ask you consume content from as many
mentors as possible decide who's the
right one for you and then you ask and
you go backwards on who you
want anchor that was fun that was a nice
little fun little thing I like anchor um
Facebook questions have stopped we're
pounding the Facebook thing like it's
like it's like tough to like like we
keep dropping like I'm trying to figure
out what the right Cadence is with
Facebook I know it's working but without
the questions it's not as fun you know
you know and I don't want to keep
stopping it every 20 minutes how much
hour do we have good we're probably good
but you can always do that all right
Periscope I'm actually going to stop
Periscope
too and come back
on he
is super
cool
bang all right scope spre cast you know
what I feel like we I feel like I need
to stop it I just need the I need the
comments not in person cool got
[Music]
it all
right it's fine let it be Facebook we're
back good to see you he Facebook was
cutting out the whole time yay it's back
good to see you oh Garrett great timing
boom look at this huh let's going well
are you guys behind um no we're not too
bad I mean
there they're rolling in U de is putting
them into a dock and I'm just going down
down and they don't stop so so we're
still going well I think it's going
really well he would know best cuz he's
the front line but are you the back line
I'm turning I'm making them come to life
sounds off on the scope oh sounds off
got it okay cut out
yep thanks
yep all right that should be better
let's see what happens there Facebook
how we doing share it up Facebook want
to get that going you crash Facebook
live pick a prize pick a prize go back
to Anor anchor rocks nice people getting
some anchor love uh can you guys leave
some comments in Facebook here 315 I
just want to make sure this is working
see more this new batch smells real
good there we go donga thank you for the
share have you ever tried float tank
nope sure I
have't you will not I know um Mr V you
have though
an this was good this was a good good
batch I'm really happy about this batch
What's Up Periscope what's up Facebook
live I'm loving ankor I like anchor a
lot too I I really like it I like audio
old school lurker here Jeff Morris good
to see you 4822 why name super AP
because we're doing an eight book
giveaway um this is why we're calling it
super eight we're doing eight books um
and uh we are doing a big giveaway where
if you buy books you get entered in to
this contest with this big bucket huge
bucket a lot of receipts in here 16 gets
you two entries and the winner gets
flown into somewhere around the world to
spend an hour with me London Australia
New York La those seem to be the kind of
main spots H Hawaii's actually in play
Believe It or Not um had to in marketing
department that social is the future
Scott the way you get people to
understand that social is the future is
you don't call it social media you call
call it the current state of the
internet this is the most important
product in the world this is absolutely
where our attention is and on here
social networks represent half of our
activity the end so social media is a
slang term it represents the current
state of the internet what's going on
with Peak Fitness they're spamming hard
are they excited they're good they're
good they just they went for a big push
big right hook all right Peak I got you
uh
uh no worries star thank you for the one
audio book uh pre-order it means the
world to me I'm I don't need eight books
like I mean I need it I want it I want
you to be entered I think that you know
what let's give away a book yay let's
give away a book giving away a
personalized book right now on the spot
and I'm actually going to do it this way
watch this boom Jeremy Cavalry you won
that's how it is Jeremy left a comment
just now on Facebook
Jeremy
I love you boom Jeremy cavarly he's in
Facebook comments Jeremy won boom Jeremy
next watch this
boom Garrett Jeffrey done winner
Garrett
congrats boom bam Garrett big winner
boom here we go mircat talk to
me it's say your full name in mircat on
there let's go your cat it's Danny
Phantom it's Danny you won he wanted it
Danny I love
you there you go Danny Danny you got it
Danny I love you bang Danny won that's
that so it's Danny so Danny and crew the
three of you that have won so far want
you email India interm mediate.com India
Baner media.com I got that's fine but
like you guys can figure that out and
finally mark Cuz Meco You've Won Mar k
Mark k I love you bang amazing bang four
books Mark congratulations brother good
[__] good
[__] that was
fun four Quick Books now how about 100
bucks in
cash snap snap cash it's not a bad idea
actually I like this you know what who's
got
Snapchat who's got
Snapchat uhhuh I like this you know what
as a matter of fact why don't all of you
real quick hit me up on videos what
you'll do with a Mone yeah Indi I'm
[__] hit me up with 100 hit me up on
Snapchat messages right now Gary ve on
what you would do with the hundred bucks
that I'm going to send you right now on
Snap
cash that's what we're going to do a
little bit of right
now good idea they're coming in I want
video I see a lot of I see a lot of
written word snap I see a lot of written
word but I want video you have your
Wi-Fi on right yeah you have your own
Jesus Christ my Snapchat's exploding
right now
in holy crap it's coming fast I can't
even stop it I can't even stop oh Gary I
would buy five more books 100 bucks well
that's a really good that guy's got a
real shot he said he buy five more books
that was a real shot but like now I've I
mean there's no way I can keep up with
this holy [__] a lot of you on
Snapchat could not ref look at this look
at
this they're just coming in like rolling
look at this rolling in oh my gosh yeah
just rolling in just rolling
in just rolling I just have to like tap
one I'm trying but like I can't stop it
I can't stop it and you got remember the
name oh my God this is
crazy Jesus I
mean I
mean all right I'm I'm Jesus I'm like I
remember the
username I can't even get
it wow I can't I can't get
it I would buy copies of your book
you're too successful
XOXO I'm just literally trying to swipe
hopefully get
something holy [__] guys you guys really
took to the SnapChat thing
huh Super 88 yeah let's do it big time
woohoo Alfie
noric noric what's up baby oh watch this
I'm do look we're gonna live stream with
noric if you hold it you know how they
say yeah cool nor there he is what up
bro how you
doing it's amazing you enjoying the
Super Eight yes I'm watching it I'm at
my store I love it man look I see it my
mattress store The Mattress Store is
rocking baby I love it thank you for
watching that's awesome dude I really
appreciate it no worries man I wish you
well
awesome that was
fun this is crazy New Jersey
K trying
car you made your bed now sleeping
it I would buy take to New York City to
come see you
Gary awesome 20 minutes south of Hill oh
it's awesome I love all you guys God I
oh man I want to do super eight every
day should we do Super Eight every
day once a
week once a week oh my God my guys I'm
sorry like if you saw what's going on
with my Snapchat right now
like yeah all right so what's going on
Facebook live good to see you guys yes
share it up Facebook live shout out to
Nick ke I Snapchat un
ucnc football are you hiring always we
have 54 openings that was dope it was
liony um if you buy eight email Super
Eight Vayner media fairy thank you so
much for sharing that super
at8 I feel like it's time like I feel
like all right let's do this I'm gonna
give away something
big but I want to give one hard push now
like to make it worth the potential
thousands of dollars I'm giving away
right now I want to make it o I have a
really good idea oh I have a really good
idea I have a really good idea I am
gonna fly somebody in to meet me for
five
minutes not really five minutes of
selfie a little what up what up at a
keynote that I'm going to be giving
within the next 30 to 45 days maybe
Maryland May maybe yeah maybe we'll go
through the list like all right look
guys a lot of you have not come in yet
for the eight books or 16 which gets you
two entries 24 is my recommendation
because I love Dell revas and 24 is a
lucky number in a lot of cultures did
you know that I did not know that
because it's not true but it would get
me 24 Bucks sold and so here we go um a
lot of you on Facebook
mircat the
scope here we go I'm going to give you a
little bit of time right now me London
another 20 books bam why 20 bu 24 it
helps you so much more uh I have no idea
what's going on actually it's a good
time to recap does anybody how many
people have no idea what's going on
might be a good time to uh to do a recap
let's see what's going on 92nd Street y
Sunday March 6 if anyone's in New York
City yeah New York City 90 92 straight Y
no
idea War saw me a lot of people don't
know what's going on so we might as well
go into it I just want a book Tracy
Martin you're in boom email India done
Tracy Martin when she emails you India
at Vander media.com she just wants a
book you've got one as a matter of fact
you know what no joke and and listen I
don't like I don't like to do I've never
done this before because it's a very
weird thing to do but I'm gonna say I'm
gonna do it right
now
um I think there's a you know I'm so
thankful and there's a lot of good
things going on I do think there's
probably listen I have a lot of empathy
and I and I've been paying very close
attention I do feel like there's a lot
of you that can't afford the book even
one book you know like trying to make
ends meet watching me because it's
giving you the motivation or it's
escapism through the entertainment of
you know I have a feeling there's a lot
of you that can't afford a book and
instead of saying me or that's me um
what I want you to do is I want you
email India and I want I don't know you
know and I I don't know how many where
I'll stop at but I want you to email
India right now please please please
please only write if you can't afford a
book please write us right now if you
can't afford a book and I just want you
to put and this is where people can like
take advantage and like I really please
don't just but if you're in a place in
your life right now where you can't
afford a book um I would love for you to
send India at Vayner
media.com um something that and I just
want you to put in one book that's what
I want in title so it's easy for us to
organize India like the country and like
the most amazing
gal in the game I love you you Britney
not you know all
GS where where is where is
Britney there Britney I really feel like
you need to I feel like Britney and
Andrew Britney and Andrew I see you
smiling Andrew Britney and Andrew it's
time for you guys to make appearance uh
India vainer media.com I want you to
Title One book and in the body please
put in um please get in here Britney
please put
in
uh your address your name and address
you getting some emails y okay you
cannot afford
it uh now some people are asking thank
you so much where they can buy one book
which means a lot to me that's Amazon is
probably the best way to go Barnes &
Noble's too it's
great Andrew Andrew breny great peeps on
the team come in here say hello get here
let's do a little Huggy Huggy yeah why
don't you tell the crew what you guys do
how you roll what's going on Facebook
live right there what's up peeps yeah go
ahead Andrew
uh you're good designer for Gary uh do
all those BS you guys love they don't
know what a BSU is that's my own
terminology that's become termin
Instagram posts I should say uh BSU
stand for Branded status updates
something I coined back in like 2010 the
pictures all the amazing quotes and yeah
uh and all that good stuff yeah cool I
do um what's your name Britney yeah um I
do Instagram influencers influencer
marketing paid advertising uh content
syndication Gary um affiliate manager
for Wine Library just a whole bunch of
stuff are you dead you're dead right
this is really bad I made a label and
just label archive I'm going go and
respond to everyone can you do an
automatic filter that if it says one
book yeah guys thank you so much how's
the day going good we've been watching
you from like 5et away the whole time
now Brit you're doing something I'm very
excited about about which is you reached
out to a bunch of influencers where
we've used ground signal ground signal
what was ground signal called before Co
everywhere just remembered a company I
invested in you've used the tool
successfully and we're getting long form
Instagram reviews of the book um which
I'm excited about you know picture of
the book we got a whole landing page for
that um and you've got a good amount and
what what were they like 10,000
followers or more like what were they
10,000 or more yeah and how many do you
think you have right now yeah 500 that's
[__] huge that's actually what I'm
working on right now I got to make sure
I get everybody's addresses right and in
the CSV so how many how many you know
the books that we have that I did the
marketing deal with the publisher how
many books do we have left addresses to
give
out 200 250 200 okay I'm going to use a
good amount for what India is dealing
with right
now thank you guys so much have a great
day you too come back later
um BMW no FS trying Gary when could you
check my email I will bring value to
both of us keyword tool Finland I'll
take a look brother just super behind
I'm not eating uh Chef I don't get to
eat I still have
17 17 books in there so listen I know a
lot of you are trying to give out books
we now have a huge database of people
that are looking for one so if you want
to email India as well uh with help on
that and going to be busy yeah I'm
getting emails like that too cool uh
let's do that so um Gary Rock and trying
what's the email India well my email is
Gary at Vayner media India is India uh
Vayner media so uh okay yeah so what I
want to do was I want to do a big push
right now I want to get a lot of
receipts in I want to do one big push
right now eight six now a lot of You'
have bought eight but maybe you could
buy 16 a lot of you bought 16 maybe you
can buy 24 and how would you ever buy 10
yeah don't buy 10 buy eight save your
money I mean listen I I'll take 10 I
appreciate it I mean I like 16 but send
your receipts right now to to uh Super8
vayer media.com Super8 Vayner media.com
if people can put Super8 Vayner
media.com uh kimra is gonna be here soon
she will be shout out to uh the ask V
Twitter he's been he's been yeah ask G's
been killing it right there's ajv he's
gonna stop by a little bit should I do a
Ask Gary V Episode just like ad hoc yeah
that's cool I let find some questions
though all right well we'll do that in a
minute why don't we do this why don't we
do a oh AJ a AJ what do you
got it's for AJ
um uh what do you guys think about doing
an an askcar V episode right now let see
what let's see what the comments are on
that yes do an askar right now okay spr
has very hot on it uh Adam Rogers no
respect uh go for it yes Adam Rogers
says no both on Periscope and Facebook
live Adam Rogers you know what everybody
says yeah yes but Adam Rogers says no so
we're going with no how about that that
was a wild upset that's a huge upset
Adam Rogers 808 or whatever it was
that's a big upset Adam Rogers
single-handedly seen one person yeah
every single person said yes and Adam
Rogers singlehandedly no this is a very
intriguing situation Adam
single-handedly stopped it stopped the
show that was
amazing he a lot of pure to Super Eight
Adam Ro look everybody's M at him but
he's right he just said let's be pure to
Super Eight wants a pure Super Eight I
respect it no listen I think it's an
interesting point of view and we've
accepted it now um can I make 600
limited edition headphones for Vayner
media excuse me yeah yes they can make
six 600 limited edition headphones for
Vayner media dude figure that out like
get that to me we'll have a very serious
conversation TV
episode should I do a Wine Library TV
episode right now that was so
unexpected no I don't think I can I need
to really do those at Wine Library
that's a commitment I wanted to do plus
I need mat to do them not the rock Jesus
this punt is huge it's called a punt
that's what don't get d a pervy um pervy
did uh who who defines what super eight
is though that's a good point Michael De
that's a very good point Adam Rogers
loves Nickelback appers does Rogers
loves
Nickelback it's funny super eight is for
the askar book okay yeah so let me let
me let me get everybody caught up super
eight that's what we're doing today a
lot of you don't know especially on
Periscope um I'm doing a kind of a
teleon there is an
enormous and I mean enormous amount of
receipts in the bucket and there's way
more than this it's pretty amazing thank
you so much Community these are all
eight book orders uh if you buy 16
you're entered twice I've been pulling
out gifts somebody want a trip to
Disneyland somebody's we've given away
some books we gave headphones we gave
away 17 t-shirts to somebody
in where was it it was somewhere far it
was Singapore Singapore that's right
what was India just super excited about
we did a whole thing we that's done
that's gone they ordered 16 of your
books question mark they have to order
eight M backs uh for one entry some
people ordered 16 some ordered 24 uh can
I have the balloon that's an interesting
one maybe you should direct some of this
money and attention to charity Laura I'm
more than happy Laura
3232 for you to no no no no no I want to
have this conversation Laura you're more
than welcome to email me at Gary bayner
media and I'm more than happy to explain
how I live my life in a charitable way
versus how I live my life in a business
way um more more than happy more than
happy for you to come to New York sit
down with me and Ted berer my accountant
and talk about my tax return I think I
think there's time and place for a lot
of things plus family and charity and
other things of that nature um no I know
you're not questioning Laura I think
that it's hard for me like for me person
and by the way I know you're not
questioning it's hard for me to mix you
know I think I think a lot of people use
charity this is my one man's point of
view and I have to live with that and
that's who I am I think one too many
people use charity as a crutch buy one
of these we'll donate one of those just
tactics not that Tom Tom started that
way but the amount of my friends let me
rephrase it's hard for them to be my
friend the amount of my acquaintances
that use charity as a coverup for their
own personal Ambitions is um difficult
for me and so I I I decide to give my
time sit on boards pencil promise
charity what the things that I work on I
I don't like mixing them the same way I
don't like India Vayner media.com in the
same way I don't like mixing my family
with my content and I respect why people
do it and I do a ton of stuff to get
attention for the nonprofits and things
that I do in the world um in and how I
use my time and energy to make them be
able to do it not just using my platform
to get it and so it's a constant
challenge um but I uh but I super
respect you bringing it up and I I know
you're worn question I know it's coming
from a good place
um uh Cynthia I love you back uh Gary
how do I order 300 I need an hour of
your time Dean let me just clarify that
for you that's in Facebook Andy Facebook
right now Dean Miller I'm going to I'm
going to heart that Amazon only has 26
books left
holy [__] for real that could be
possible look Scott compa just said
Amazon only has 26 books left awesome no
that's not awesome that's bad yeah oh
does mean we just doesn't mean we sold
lot no it means we going to leave a lot
of books on the table hold on this is
not interesting I'm confused that can't
be true
um stop should
shoulding on people shoulding Laura I
hope I hope I'm not is there a problem
with Amazon is there only 26 for that is
that true I don't know into it please
look into it uh I want to make sure I
answer Laura's question because I hope
she's I'm not losing
context what's happening ratchet hack
audio book yes on fire mom mom my mom
just texted me only 26 books left no Mom
there's a lot more trust me Gary if I
buy a thousand books can I shave your
head
yes right now no should I do it for
thousand I mean I kind
of I kind of would do it I think I would
do it to be honest but I also feel like
I look really old if I shave my head I
want to shave it any like it's getting
close 5,000 right for the head shave I
mean best part is it's interesting
what's the biggest failure and how did
you overcome it Trey I failed a lot in
school I failed a lot in um
in trying to do too much um when I uh
when I got out of day-to-day Wine
Library tried to open up like 30
businesses and so I went for um I I
started Forest then I started uh cork
then I started obsessed TV I tried to
bite off more than I could for me I tend
to lose when I try to do too much when
my eyes are too big when my appetite's
too big when I stretch myself thin that
is that is where my concern is and so I
I've I've learned that about myself and
now I've kind of try though I still need
things to keep me active and crazy um I
try to do too much at times and so I've
done best when I'm fully kind of focused
right I've got I've got vinner media
I've got my personal brand I've got my
Venture Capital activity I've got my I
on Wine Library I've got my person you
know all this my personal life if I buy
a thousand books will you be my friend
I'm only 12 yes I'm absolutely selling
my friendship no I'll be your friend
other for without buying a th000 bcks
I'd also like to really see a
12-year-old buy a th000 books I think
we're on random questions at this point
how was Vader media in the beginning
what was the biggest problems and it was
good I mean I wasn't really involved in
the first two years um can I H the chat
on Facebook is dead again Facebook live
[__] I love them they're my favorite I'm
just sad that the chat dies
Andy can I be upset about that if the
stream works maybe it's but for me when
I'm looking at my desktop they're still
coming
in so just on the app right
nor H okay I'll keep it on you tell me
what's go then you're gonna have to keep
an eye on it and tell me what's going on
love you Gary love you
back um Periscope is definitely the best
MC says because she's on Periscope or he
um so wait a minute we were about to do
we were about to do several things the
askcar TV show Wine Library TV and I was
about to give away a big oh I want to do
a hard push
micro Conta perfect minute number five
minute draw is the best Periscope is the
best I need a book Gary can't afford one
Trey India ater media.com one book I
found you through grape story and Jerome
jar Jim that's awesome this is so
freaking awesome Barbara you're so
freaking awesome Facebook it's working
fine Facebook's working fine cool so
then so now I'm gonna have to look at
this yeah or get me another laptop yeah
you know like you know what give me
another laptop with Facebook live or
something like that and we'll put it
here we wecast
[Music]
here give me a small I do think that
privacy is massively important I also
don't have context like as a matter of
fact only because I was in a cab and I
heard something for a second I guess
they're asking for the phone of the
person that did the terrorist attack in
California like so I don't know I think
it's very very very complicated I think
there's very compelling arguments to
both sides of the equation and one of
the best things I did at 38 besides
fixing my health was I started to
promise myself I wouldn't talk about or
punch pontificate or opinionate about
things I wasn't educated on I'm a normal
person like all of you and I know what's
going on a little bit but I'm way too
much headline reading right now and it's
very complicated boy is it complicated
uh president Choice want to know
everything president thing is really
tough as well literally La two nights
ago in South Carolina Nevada was the
first night I started paying attention
so I've been staying out of it uh I tend
to stay out of it fairly early on um I
have voted for both Republicans and
Democrats in my life I don't I don't
feel uh like I need to be on the party
lines uh and I haven't really started
paying attention really just yet uh I
would say that uh I was born in a
Socialist Communist country and I'm I'm
most fun most fun I'm most curious to
really dig into Bernie Sanders point of
view like you know obviously as an
entrepreneur socialism is a really bad
word in America but there's versions of
it and I'm so curi that to me that's the
most interesting thing the other thing
is I'm curious to see if Donald Trump
after getting the nomination for a
Republican party is going to be like aha
I tricked you here are my actual views
cuz anybody that lives in New York uh
and anybody that just uses Common Sense
sees that he had very different points
of view only 47 seconds ago uh I'm also
a hair concerned I'd be lying if I
didn't say that and this is just from
not paying attention a lot but the hate
mongering is scary you know um but but
I'm also not judging all the way I have
a lot of friends and contemporaries who
believe in a lot of so I haven't truth
is I haven't gone there yet so thoughts
on Nicks it's a mess it's all about
Zinger uh porzingis is the only thing we
can build around right now um and that's
what we have to focus on and I'm I'm
scared about that what's going on am I
going to get a laptop here with Facebook
good uh thoughts on how Market unsexy
industry like Insurance there's no
interest in the content Hans there is
interest in living your life meaning
like it's super interesting to be a
human in society and insurance is part
of that and a lot of did you not know or
I would tell tell you like running your
household TV is a big idea where you
talk about paying bills life insurance
uh how to
rent how to rent a car for a vacation
instead of buying a plane ticket like
kind of a money management how would you
live bless the fut Tri I'll follow you
how do you like manage your life and I
think insurance is part of that life
insurance health insurance paying bills
and so one of the things that I think a
lot of people make a mistake on is um
not leveling up their content and so if
you want to sell insurance you probably
wi win the minds and hearts of people of
how to like run their household and you
teach them about a lot of things we're
bringing other experts and then
insurance is one of those things tell
India and Daka said hi no problem Max
chapen
done you've answered all of these other
questions a 100 times can we get some
subscription box thesis yes no problem
subscription box thesis which I've
answered quite a bit as well but here we
go we might have not missed we might
have missed them uh I think box
subscriptions are a a good good not a
good gift I think that they're a good
people don't like the shop people value
time so a lot of people can buy into
boxes I think if boxes curate properly
uh they can be quite successful and
build a big base I think they run very
basic math Arbitrage you know how much
it cost you on Google or affiliate
marketing or Facebook or influencers to
acquire box subscriptions you know what
they're worth after a year to see the
average of the lifetime value do people
stay on for four months do the people
stay on for 9ine months if you can level
them up to buy full products using your
subscription box as the gateway drug to
Ecom I think there's an enormous
opportunity I think there's a lot of
niches that people would buy for 20 and
$30 actually let's do this India yes
what uh would you have you ever been a
subscriber of box of the month um yes
for a hot second birch box birch box uh
so makeup I well I thought it would be
more like skincare stuff got it so I
don't wear makeup so I I didn't
subscribe anymore but it was really cool
cool got it very cool Andy drrock okay
so I think I think box um subscription
models are really intriguing and I've
invested in Birchbox I wrote the first
check into it I invested in Bark Box I
was in the angel round two of the more
successful ones I co-founded a company
called
faithbox uh with Willie which we
incubated here and he's killing it he's
a Hos where's Willie Willie are you here
Faith box I know you guys are watching
I'm looking right at you where 's
Willie is Willie
here hi Gary hello got you another
computer for Facebook thank you very
much also Melissa vernine brought you
some cheesecake I wish I could eat it
Mike would break my face in here for
some it looks
delicious you should just put it over
here boy damn it God looks I have my
slice downstairs looks amazing
wow is there may give away the cheese oh
my God smell get this out of my face
smells phenomenal Frank and Mike set all
the stuff up today Frank and Mike thank
you guys so much give me some deps yeah
yeah man you got it um I'll frame it
more Snapchat secrets that's a good
point I will do that sadest I love big
Goods you know me super well JP how do
you feel about virtual reality and the
outcome in the video game industry
Calvin I think it's going to be huge I'm
obsessed with VR it is my absolute
prediction of the game-changing
technology of our society over the next
15 years um I'm a big big big big fan
I do think it's going to take more time
than most people think but I think it's
going to be massively massively
massively impactful on um on video games
and on movies and TV and entertainment
so um that's a now a wiser woman needs a
signed copy and I think she bought 40
she what's her name oh I can't I saw it
she said it before but I I'm doing it
right now because she bought 40 and
she's giving away books and she's
amazing Maria done Maria
I
adore you
boom
sorry
Maria
bang give away the cheesecake love it um
all right Maria you're all set I love
you back okay I'm GNA give you guys
seven minutes I'm going to do a real
push right now um you can get your
friends and relatives business partners
friends acquaintances
Associates uh I want a push on uh eight
book orders right now give me a sign
Super Eight poster
ooh o I like that this one's the big one
this one's a big one have one of these
ask version of these what is that oh my
God I forgot about this this is legit
the crazy plate lady I'm going to go
spre cast the crazy plate lady on
Instagram she's getting some good love
for this and I'm paying her for it like
she really hustled good [__] crazy plate
lady is going to make an askary V plate
we're going to give that away right now
going give it away right
now you are going to get an askary V
plate these are gorgeous that's why I
was willing to do it from the crazy
plate lady boom here it is crazy plate
lady I like eating and I need a plate
Connor
D spr cast you ready Daniel day here we
go crazy plate lady Michael J says plate
me here we go here here we
go uh oh thank you so much Perry Girls
TV for inviting their followers by
sharing they are paying attention on
Periscope respect we are
now 5 hours and 8
minutes five hours and eight minutes
into this live stream I think we should
do this every
week I have to qu the
te India has resigned all right here we
go the plate lady Chef lazette wants it
the plate
lady you almost set up with the Facebook
thing yeah cool here we
go Jim caset Michael J plate lady
Melissa Porter wants to be plated here
we
go thank you so much Chris Feed the
Beast Connor here we
go the limited edition oneoff one of
kind hand designed plate goes
to Dr Michelle Summers
Cologne Germany nope Oh elonte
California Dr Michelle Summers cologne
oh cologne I'm not using beam because I
haven't gotten Michelle zomie Nice
Conor's pumped uh yeah it is a doctor
because beam is like I just haven't
gotten used to this functionality yet
plus I wanted for glasses stuff like I
love I I really want to get into beam
and I will um Chef is very upset Chef
you can you can offer do Dr Michelle to
buy it case n said is the
man uh okay that's it so here take a
picture do whatever you want congrat
let's congrats it up we didn't congrats
enough we didn't congrats this time I'm
seeing
it big shout out to Mike
Hunt Gratch doc there we go what is your
book sale goal I'd like to sell 100,000
copies the first week which would be
shattering
numbers um thank you for there we go
that's some nice love on spre cast I do
not use blab yet how do you find
American Dream American Dream to me is
just the dream forget about the American
dream it's a global dream which is can
you live your life on your terms I mean
that is super nice can you do what you
want to do always books on books on
books on books thoughts on ankor FM we
just missed it we were talking about
about Anor I like anchor a lot
struggling over there I have to
update Jesus uh how would you invest
$1,000 besides buy your books I would
buy $1,000 worth the Facebook Stock and
there look who has come into the
equation mom is going to be pumped I
think Mom's watching where are you he's
here round three to get up got ajv anle
ajv my brother AJ is in the house we got
a lot going on so what do you have
you've got spree cast spre cast Facebook
live we've had a reset a bunch of time
mircat and Periscope you had to reset
Facebook live a bunch of times yeah just
it was working with the comments
comments on the phone weren't working
but now that's why we're going to put on
a laptop all right guys AJ's here
co-founder Vayner media co-founder
please dress
me tell India I said she is awesome you
got a Trey uh let's fire away with a
couple AJ questions probably some good
stuff yeah why not you can give a
different AJ who's the better basketball
player that's not even close it's AJ
unfortunately not this morning though
Gary I'll play me this for sure only
late no I didn't play well the whole day
I thought your mid-range jumper was
pretty solid the end you a couple oh you
know what in game four or five you had
two nice drives to the basket to start
off you scored the first two points yeah
last game was okay Circle shot Andy
today was a intense basketball day it
was anybody who played anybody who
played basketball today that happens to
be watching on the stream right now at
Vayner come up here and talk about it
and then if anybody's watching at Vayner
stumbling I know you're not working you
know like find out if anybody's playing
basketball around you Barbara wants to
know how's it working with Gary how's it
working with Gary awesome AJ is cute see
getting some love AJ go ahead AJ uh I
mean we we we' been working together
even before vayer oh here's a good one
AJ I'm sorry I apologize what strengths
do you have that outshine Gary from your
perspective you know and you know I's an
unfair word uh I think some strength
that compliment and a big thing a big
thing Gary's 11 years older and I am so
when we we were we knew we were going to
work together once College was done so I
spent a couple years in college really
thinking through like what can I develop
to compliment Gary so not knowing where
we would go what we would do I picked up
uh I I was a computer science minor so I
was learning how to develop code and
become an engineer took database courses
computer science courses I taught myself
CSS HTML PHP uh from the front end and
the back end side things so that was one
thing I ran through my mind I think
naturally that was super that was super
hardcore that was yeah you were not
pumped about that towards the end you
know after it was done it's good you
know I mean but it was tough I mean
computer science was I love how you were
using like CTO of like big internet
companies at the time to help you like
Joe stump and everything real you were
talking a real oh AJ tell them the story
of tech Crunch and please dress me in
college this a great story I mean this
story is also how I met my wife that is
true a direct correlation me Joe stump
the former CTO of dig.com and AJ start a
business call please address me yep
he'll go into the the love story in a
second but tell him the business story
or like the class the comms class
because I think that's incredible yeah
uh so I went to Boston University and
they had just introduced a new course I
don't it was something extent of like
New Media 302 I don't remember some sort
of New Media course generic and even the
professor who was awesome shout out to
Professor Quigley he uh he was like
listen this is a new class I I
personally don't have a lot of
experience working in the field but I
think it's interesting I think it's
going to be something that matters to
this University in the future so major
credit to him uh so very first class
very first day there's maybe like 15 to
20 students and um the first thing he
did was like let me just show you some
websites that kind of reflect New Media
Web 2.0 so he's going through websites
and uh one of the websites he utilized
was a company called or website called
life haacker which is still out there
now great website site that I used to
visit all the time and uh the front page
story so this is on the big screen in
class yeah this is on the projector in
class and the front page story is uh
Vayner Chuck's launch t-shirt search
engine and know six minutes earlier the
professor does a 15 person class roll
call and one of the names is vaynerchuck
so you know he had the wherewithal to
realize that that unique name popped up
twice in six minutes when it popped up
zero times in his life prior uh and then
it's not only is that the headline but
the picture is to does it just update
keep going a yeah our our faces and Joe
stump's face so there's three faces and
a title so I'm sitting there's 15 kids
in his class and he looks at me I'm like
yeah uh it was the day we launched the
website Gary got us to kind of press uh
so he goes listen like you you might
know more about this stuff than I do
clearly front of the room and like tell
us what it's all about so I talk about
please dress me I talk about my
experience in San Francisco this summer
prior and talk about wi R TV and what
Gary and I've been up to uh from a wide
variety of things AJ a very important
question for that did you get some ass
because of that was a very profound
question I mean sorry Ally but an
indirect way uh I'll get to that part so
I present this at the end of class A
girl comes up to me says hey uh I'm the
head of a group within our PR group I've
got a group of like 10 girls we had a
client that uh a client that dropped out
last minute we have nobody like would
you like a group of 10 girls to help you
with PR with please dress me I'm single
I'm 21 I'm like yeah of course no
problem yeah what time when do I meet
the team uh when do I meet the team I
think the next day show me the team yo
where the squad at and so uh I go to
meet the head of that PR group who
happens to be Allie's best friend I go
to meet her after lunch and Allie's
having lunch with her best friend prior
um I met Ally for like five minutes at
that point I thought Ally was cute next
day I saw Ally walk around the halls
asked her for her number we went on a
date and rest is history so indirectly
please dress me is how Alie and I met a
you know what a story we haven't told in
a long time probably a lot this one's a
lot we used to tell it all the time and
I don't think we've even told it in 5
years years okay which is the story of
when I went on a trip to Napa to buy
wine okay and on the way home saw
business 2.0 magazine that said fish.com
sells for $58 million and I read about
domain names on the flight home yeah and
I
land and Friday night it's a you take
you take over you take over so what do
you think Friday night 10:30 11: p.m.
yep Gary calls me I'm a freshman in
college this is September or October
second I say second week of college Andy
pay attention that's a good one uh
second week of college it's like 10:30
1100 p.m. at night Gary calls me I look
at the phone hold on AJ Zack yes just
want to say I'm getting a lot of
receipts for just one book you need to
buy eight books so seven more so you
need seven more so if you bought one you
can for seven and we'll we'll put it in
right so it takes eight books to be into
the entry for all these prizes that's
why it's called Super Eight go ahead
AJ um Gary calls me it's like 10:30 11
p.m. it's a Friday night it's I think
literally my second or third weekend in
college I'm at a frat party real cliche
uh I hear all the noise I'm like get out
of there I need to tell you I need to
tell you something I pick up and Gary's
like what are you doing like at a frat
party like I don't know with like my
floor I'm with my Florida flat frat
party and he's like all right we need to
talk I I'm I I want we're going to I'm
going to change life I'm like I
literally said this conversation is
going to change your life I'm like okay
so we go I go outside the Frat party
we're probably on the phone for like an
hour from like and I'm like AJ I'm
literally like AJ I'm telling you this
internet thing it's different than what
I've been deal this was the pre- dawn of
Web 2.0 yeah and I'm like I can feel it
diff it's different and even though it
was about domains there was other stuff
going on it was all tied end and I said
the time is now we're going into this
thing
yeah it's really cool like that
literally happened I literally because
at this point we're thinking us should
call me and say he's going to change my
life like every week ever ever right I'm
just really the impact I know it sounds
like something I would do you're right
good point good point for reference I
never did it any other time right AJ no
and you have to understand we were
thinking like we're going to start a
sports agency together or like I went
into college thinking I was going to be
a lawyer a sports agent I thought
gete law degree
um yeah it was crazy and then I I spent
a ton of time get to work going down the
rabbit hole of like domains is where it
started but what was it site point or
digital point yeah there was some
marketing Forum this is 10 years ago
this is 10 11 years ago so just going
down the rabbit hole and that's what
drove here's a fun fact AJ was the first
video blogger in our family that's true
cuz so like this is going to be big and
AJ started jet first good video
blogger know it is a good D that's a fun
fact that's a trivia question all right
there's some good questions about about
the Jets first yeah I want to sign copy
from AJ done hey done hey I'm supposed
to say done oh I'm sorry AJ done
all Who ah rich I was uh was it uh Duke
seal I was in sleeper West Campus so
near Rich what was it what was it uh
Rich sleeper and Claflin I was in
sleeper there was a good question
about AJ what's your biggest challenge
at Vayner biggest challenge at
Vayner you know what has been recently
the biggest challenge um I used to watch
yourself Adriana I used to really pride
myself and this is just full
transparency I used to really pride
myself on knowing every single person uh
in full transparency it's gotten it's
slipp in my grips recently we're up to
625 people are we at 625 625 oh I need
to start saying we're at 700 I I'm like
down I'm playing what do we do you know
that we do you know that we have 59
openings yes 59
yeah I sat with recruit I sat I sat with
recruiting yesterday and they're like we
have 59 openings and I'm like we
literally have a large digital agency of
open of openings like we would be a
large we'd be a large
agency yeah all right there's some more
good stuff
uh let's see did you did you like school
more than Gary no I was better at school
though I actually think the reason why I
was better at school was cuz our mom mom
I know you're watching went through what
Gary did in school and really didn't
want to repeat so there was stuff like
I'll tell you a great story the most one
of the is this Mr riddle no no that's a
great story tell after you tell it after
you tell that story uh I got sick in
like eighth grade once and mom didn't
believe me cuz she thought I was just
pulling a page out of Gary like I wanted
to leave school early and Gary's like
[__] mom was like [__] I've seen
this play but like no my I'm
legitimately sick like [__] Gary I know
he lied all the time about being sick I
promise when you pick me up when I walk
out I won't smile oh this was this was
yeah AJ's referencing I used to call out
sick I used to mentally convince myself
to be sick and run a fever in this is
something I truly believe I like would
run like I would get higher I mean I
don't know your bra the brain is
underrated anyway I I would you know
they'd have to send you home if you just
fought I kind of figured that out pretty
early on and I would have there was this
walk from the nurse to my mom's car yeah
it's like a courtyard right yeah exactly
and I would and my mom would be sitting
there picking me up but I couldn't look
her in the face cuz I knew I'd laugh cuz
she knew the deal so I would like look
down the whole time until like I got to
the
car yeah so yeah I think that's I didn't
like school either but I was pretty good
at it what about Mr riddle Mr riddle
grade y sth grade history
teacher go ahead that's fine and uh s
eth grade teacher and No Nonsense type
Guy best dude great guy uh Had Gary when
Gary first moved I only went to eighth
grade in this school AJ went through the
whole school and on my first day of
seventh grade Mr riddle kind of like
establishing his position like and he
was a tough dude nonsense yeah he's like
I got
three
fly elbow yeah see yeah he quickly
realized I wasn't a problem and I think
quick here's a fun fact of Mr riddle he
always thought I was a handful but when
the one kid in school that had the Mike
Tyson Buster Douglas videotape on VHS in
school riddle gave me a I'll get you out
of class I need that video I'm like all
right riddle you know what we got to
do just give me that
d give me that D give me that D riddle
oh
man uh what else is good
AJ or what people got questions let's go
Periscope Facebook give it to
me yes AJ does look more like my dad
that is
true uh what else is this scrolling
scrolling has it been no there it is
there we
go um oh our sister's in here n great
story let's give her a little like
bertrude get in here Liz Nell drive over
L Nell get in here Liz nello you can get
in here we can put you on spree cast you
want me to email we can get you on the
screen saw that AJ looks like more I saw
that AJ better at school than you yeah
talk about that way
better is uh starting this agency I mean
I think you know I I got a good I got a
good story so between vayer RSC
uh Banner Capital um Tech Stars other
programs I've had the opportunity to sit
down with entrepreneurs along the way
and there's one question that I've been
asked five to 10 times that I laugh at
every single time it is uh how do I find
a co-founder I sit there and I go I mean
really like I'm my blood is my
co-founder so the I can probably help
you in a lot of ways but I'd be lying to
you if I told you how to find a
co-founder and I think I'm really
fortunate in the sense that
when we started vayer media it wasn't
two kids with no network coming out of
school with an idea it was a business
that G and I pre-planned Gary having
been 11 years older being successful
working with my father and doing his own
stuff and establishing a network you
know I I'd be lying if I didn't say that
we started Vayner media on second or
third base it's not like I started at a
home plate and hit it somewhere so I
think best opportunity 5050 that's how
we started the company yep somebody
asked what's the percentage yep question
is this is an interesting one age
question person asked would you guys be
as successful without each
other yes and no I think differently I
think a dep depends on your uh
definition of success I think a big
factor that both of us could probably
say to is trust and loyalty and in one
another huge benefit of uh being in
business with family as opposed to
meeting a co-founder at some tech Meetup
not that that hasn't worked before but
um I think different I don't think I
would have had the gall or the want or
the desire to build 600 person agency so
I think if there's one thing that's
probably more in Gary's DNA to scale at
this size of a head count than mine I
don't know what do you think G I think
we would both I mean I did win without
you and I think you would have you would
win without me and I do think we're
different I do you know I you know
what's been most fun for me bro is
that is that in a weird way this may
surprise a lot of people in a weird way
way this is not a joke or maybe this is
how I think about it and maybe you think
about it exact same way I was I've
enjoyed and this is probably my own
selfish ego talking but I've enjoyed I
think we came into this business I I
think you'd be stunned how much
confidence there was on his end and my
end on what AJ brought to the table we
already played a lot yeah like you like
like I would say that I I uh AJ I say I
say respectfully how do you manage Gary
to get the most out of him as a person
in his energy that's a really good
question actually Golden Rule uh net net
number one thing Gary by nature and
desire and the magic of it is he'll try
a lot of [__] he'll be scattered but
Focus I'm not trying to say he's Maniac
running around but I think a lesson I
learned early on is when maybe you know
if something happened that went wrong or
didn't go exactly how I thought it could
have went or how I thought I could have
impacted it for even better you you have
to take a step back and have perspective
that that net net no matter if you make
a 100 mistakes if you're doing 15,000
things right who cares about the 100
mistakes so I think that's probably the
biggest thing and I think there's no I
don't think manage I know you said
respectfully it's not managing him I
think it's just understanding the style
and figure out how to complement it the
uh thing the uh I think people would be
really surprised how much confidence we
had in you me and you and and so for me
back to the net net thing and I think AJ
did learn that along the way for me
probably the thing that was most fun was
I was excited even though I'd already
helped massively grow Wine Library um it
was cool like there was certain things
that happened in the business along the
way where I was pump I watched AJ adjust
to me in a net net I watched him create
more not friction but like we would
debate more things early on in the
business well I think a big part of the
early days of the business is that you
weren't dedicated to the business that's
right I'm talking about that first year
where I was dedicated you know
that'sjust adment too right in a world
where you were pretty Loosely not
Loosely that's not fair but not day
today I wasn't it's just different yeah
the first year two years almost the full
two first two years of Vayner media I
was really not involved I mean I got the
customers yeah which matters matters
course but Top Line Sales fix every
problem remember that that used to say I
used to say that a lot it's still true
top top line sales fix a lot of problem
make M if you can make money it helps
solve a lot of headaches the way when it
comes to business yeah cash is oxygen
cash is oxygen 100% cash is how many
people over the age of 35 not life how
many people over the age of 35 work at
Vayner media
625 a lot uh 75 yeah when I started 75
not when you started
but 75 easy 100 easy a lot not but
frankly when we were like 200 people a
handful comments all right oxygen too
lot people even hit like
30 those are what do you and AJ argue
most about board
games board games I think and basketball
basketball anything competitive and
Chippy in basketball me and AJ right we
can get chippy yeah does it get we what
do you think what how do you how do you
feel tell tell tell them the truth go
ahead Andy tell say you compared to AJ
is not even the same Spectrum what do
you mean of chippiness you mean I'm more
wrong I mean you do like low blows and
cheap [__] I only get chippy when it
gets cheap Stefan yeah so like
you no no listen I'm a big boy I can
take anything what do you think St fight
the hand that feeds you no no I no I
like you know I like the truth what do
you think no I mean you're like you're
more you're quicker to throw elbow
than a cheap elbow cheap but like but
for me it's just like it's all in good
chest like I know you're just having fun
yeah it's not like dirty but I mean
that's how I take it cuz I'm like I'm
just like [__] you yeah I mean I say
[__] you too that's what that's when
things get chippy it gets chippy out
there today today was a good
day I think the best thing for us we
don't like it I don't like it at all I
think the best thing for us is in the
last two or three years one of us
quicker is quicker to realize like this
is so unnecessary let's just diffuse it
even the last one like a week ago you
good job yeah both you did you with
you're like so like it get gets and
apologize 2 hours later right 2 hours
later Gary apologize I'm getting better
yeah so we got better no I do think it's
weird for you guys I think the funniest
part is when we're arguing yeah like
cussing at each other like yo [__] you
dude don't do that [__] basketball
awkward you were
scared like are we still going to play
You're like is the you're like are we
still allowed are we still going to play
basketball is the company still going to
be around do I have a job was there some
like vayer veterans like no no they do
this all the time don't worry about it
was there somebody it was every it was
like filming filming like that one and
you like fought and was is that fil yeah
it was like the earlier ones what's the
one piece of advice Gary damn it that's
a good uh what's the one piece advice
Gary and AJ would give each other that's
a good question that is a really good
question right
now I I don't feel like I'm like I think
I'm done with my advice you're
done you're you don't like giving advice
I'm not in I don't I don't like I don't
like giving advice
anymore of the that's the end of the ass
Gary me
show weird yeah weird are we gonna still
do show you know I'm excited I'm I'm
excited are we still are we still doing
the show do I have a
job I I'm secretly super excited for AJ
you know I went through a big
transformation at
30 and I think that uh you know 29 ages
29 we're T the business and just like I
think there's just like so many chapters
in one's career I I would say the advice
is
like you know to really really think
about
like all the different things that you
want to accomplish like you got a lot of
success and a lot of time and that's a
really big
gift I don't think there's advice I
would give um I don't think I'm in a
position to give advice per se but I
think something Gary and I talk about
that I'm always keeping in mind is that
whatever we're doing and however we're
doing I think one thing that I push a
lot is let's keep thinking big let's
like not not not and it's not AR talking
about perspective like uh but I think
just not falling into habits of years
past and how to continue to push I
really re what AJ's referring to is like
holistically I think big the biggest but
but what AJ's referring to is I really
really know how to build and operate
businesses from three to 100 million
right like I'm [__] good at it I've
done it twice now you know not that Wine
Library hit that level but like it would
have if I just continued
um and so what happens is as you get
bigger you don't need to buy something
for 50,000 you could buy it for 500,000
you don't need to buy it's it's just you
know getting out of the we've got we've
got the luxury now of more dollars
bigger things and I'm immigrant I'm I'm
always hedging I'm definitely that and
so no question no question pressing when
you got it it's funny it's funny though
how that
works when I when I think like about
like the LA move like I it's funny I I
in the same way I am I do so many like
different kind yeah but that was a safe
bet but it was a big bet yeah yeah it
was that was a funny story yeah we're in
a meeting and I walk in we were having a
meeting on a separate issue and I like
agent and I talk about agent and I talk
about every decision and I uh and I'm
like but this one I just had to move
fast on and I'm just like uh I bought an
agency we have an LA
office AJ looked at me like excuse me H
excuse me yeah to my credit though net
net at that point that's why I like if
it was 18 months ago I wouldn't have
done that because I knew that I I don't
think I would have done it in that
environment cuz I I mean how long ago
was it two years ago what six months
changed a
lot no I'm sorry 18 months earlier than
that yeah 18 months earlier than that
day all right h cool a v check bro sign
copy oh yeah to to that person or over
overall Prize winner we'll pick a prize
for the two of you to sign and then
Luise is getting a copy sign just me do
you want an update just AJ no this one's
both this one's both of
us want
update one second AJ you get to pick who
gets this
too all right AJ that book India there
you go am I pick for this yeah there's a
lot of receips receips yeah it's a lot
of paper boys going have done pois and G
more efficient I pushed for it I don't
love Mother Nature remember fair enough
I don't remember that episode 12 daily V
start watching i' I've watched a
combin 10 minutes 10 to 15 minutes of
Ask Gary ve and daily V combine but
that's more that's more than I thought
I'm I'm happy I'm like yeah but it's
because I get un fortunate lifetime uh
oh G Green's coming in AJ watch this uh
Luther geler from Vegas Luther geler
bang more more and and did anybody buy
56 I don't think I've seen who's going
to buy 56 can grab another B 156 hey
look is there one I was 156 I haven't
seen one
yet there's a lot a lot are they rolling
in still chugging oh I don't know if it
slowed down or if we caught up so it's
slowing
down what time is it
now 3 38 so we're 5 hours and 38 minutes
in y pretty good yeah AJ we're doing
this once a week now it's a
good love you thanks for coming by bye
y'all all right see you guys and who's
this one this one's that's going to Luis
all right L all right we got a we got a
guest here and we have another guest
James is Gonna Come Jam
James oh great on on on here on the cast
on the cast all right spre cast guys
James out ofure four camera's going to
come the outman as I call him big time
podcaster great author uh I know a lot
of you follow him so told you here is
legit get on spree cast hello hello are
you hi to see great how are you get in
here I'm getting in here you really
hustled today I'm super impressed I'm
very very impressed well I've been in
Hustle mode the past two weeks so it has
been my right hook the past two weeks
launching my uh be true brandu program
um we H closed up it was my first seven
figure launch that I've been able to um
accomplish in a pretty short amount of
time I've had only had my business for
about two years congratulations so um so
thank you thank you so um but yeah it's
just been kind of crazy the past few
days and I was just like well I'll just
buy tons of books I got tons of people
to give books too so thanks C I got
plenty of people to give away books to
so so why don't you tell everybody here
for a bunch of people I know a bunch of
people don't know who you are like tell
tell them like your story I had like a
pink mohawk that was like this tall and
like like the Mohawk was taller than you
yes yes yes exactly people actually say
that they like your Mohawk is taller
than you but yeah so um I you know I
can't run my business if I don't have my
nannies Lizzy might be
watching uh but yeah I'm like I can't I
can't run my business you know if I'm
not able to have assistance and now I
have 10 members on my team um my nanny's
count as my team you know because during
my launch they're working more hours um
you know they count as my team and you
know so I've been able to to grow
something you know pretty pretty quickly
in that so why uh good for you so why
while you're here any questions I cat
oh good to see you go ahead I agree with
you Gary I think though Esports is GNA
be totally enhanced by augmented reality
reality every neurochemical is going to
be firing in the brain I think I think
gaming and and entertainment right and
porn I think those three Industries are
going to be massively affected by VR
early on and shopping and real estate
later later all these different areas
but I for me they're later I mean for me
the most interesting like I'm dying to
know how much travel can actually get
affected um by VR like I mean you you
just hang out with sharks or extremely
extremely attractive
dudes yes exactly that's what I I always
say to the booker either sharks or or
people more attractive than meas as the
rest of the
world James is self-deprecation is all
time and she was thank God three months
older they were like really trying to
give us trouble so I was very persuasive
there too um kind of calm down the scene
people wanted to fight the cops I kind
of I was neutral so yeah a couple times
in my life I've had a I've had to use my
charm in police situ
okay that's good to know
then and then I actually have a question
for for my company itself um how how do
you how do you feel about over hiring uh
versus overing the team you know do you
take the risk to overhire initially or
do you stretch the D to the point where
you know it's a little bit stressful for
everybody both I love over hiring if you
can afford it I love over hiring because
I'm playing for long game and I'm
playing to win you know I've over hired
at Vayner media the whole way I over
hired at Wine Library I want have more
bodies I love
it okay over higher it is I mean that's
what works for me because I back AJ was
on a little while ago and you know we
were talking about how Topline Revenue
solves all problems I can overhire
because I can sell my ass off and I can
keep bringing dollars in that won't make
me vulnerable to it so you've got to be
a great Revenue generator to overhire
because or be okay with not making any
money which is fine Brandon I've had
really I've had like one cof by the way
Alexa excuse me for a second Brandon
just answer your question this is this
is a question I get a lot I probably
drink two coffees a day I don't drink
them you never finish them I never
finish them I leave a lot they're
comfort food I two into here so that's
that's a story
Alexi okay sounds good quick question
about the the the pr though is that a
session with goach and you there no not
me
brother but maybe we'll see and I really
do appreciate what you did and the vayer
nation and the biacs are going to [__]
their pants when they see your
infrastructure designed by Zach added
with kad's startup our search engine now
questions and answers of every answer
and question on the askar show is going
to be a big
deal it's gonna be cool I'm excited to
share that hopefully you know really
soon that's going to be live and uh
excited to share that with everybody
else I'm I'm excited you're in New York
now brother and uh we'll put you
together with Mike and thanks for being
on great thanks take care take care all
right guys guys we are we are 6 hours
and 10 minutes into
this pretty good right good energy all
the way through all right Periscope all
right Facebook live what up drock Jeremy
X Lewis had that to say to you drock so
pumped for the book thank you Daniel
Luther says the balloon cracks me up
Luther goler did he win something was
that Luther thought there was a Luther
that one was a different Luther no
there's a Luther that won I don't it's
the same but this is so much fun
oceanana it is super fun you're G to get
a little thumbs up for me on that bang
your staff is like your family hell yeah
it is Adam we are we are cozy we haven't
even spent that many years together guys
I would say we're much closer than we
should be given the amount of time we've
been
together everyone yeah I mean this
collect what how long you on average you
think it would take to get close I think
for most people they'll never get this
close because I don't think they have
the Open Hearts that we all have d wow
Open Hearts that was nice that was nice
right not really I think we have a
really really sweet VG right my mom just
had amazing energy wow just now guys if
you want to know guys if you want to
know why I think I'm the best it's quite
simple it's this text right here from
Mom like this is like there is nothing
there is nothing like disproportional
self-esteem building it is my number one
piece of advice to I cannot wait to
write perfectly parented it is going to
be I actually think it could end up
being my bestselling book of all time
because it's a parenting book it could
be completely priceless priceless you
know like Evergreen it could be it could
be completely Evergreen forever it's
literally perfectly parented how to
raise an entrepreneur I should have
wrote it three or four years ago cuz
that was the hot wave it'll probably
spike in like 21 years again when people
come but like it's going to be big well
you can he keynot from everywhere you're
in reality by then it's going to be big
man right my keynote in VR Asia is Asia
your new name instead of India so
weird I don't think it should be since
that's not your name oh it's pretty this
is from my college class tonight here in
stugart Germany yes that's that dude is
the best are they live three hours of
Gary ve and students bought 12 books I
donated seven more to them they're
amazing this is how you learn business
com yep Gregory cheek right yep he's
amazing Gregory super appreciate you man
so fun Ian Gregory like for you come to
Italy okay Andrea uh fire it has been
Julia what is there I got a picture look
at this P this was unbel this guy's the
best this class is the best too I love
this class this class picture they were
watching all day how cool is that
awesome this was an a you know what's oh
by the way by the way I did an interview
with the Observer which is a great
magazine uh newspaper here in New York
and this is super
important this is now
this this has not been talked about
enough this has not been talked about at
all I think I wrote a really good
book I think so
too you do right no no no no no like do
you know what I mean like the guy flat
out said to me like a lot of people are
going to be so do you know Hollis my
publisher said to me when she read it
she read it right away she called me the
next day and said Gary this
is this is a big deal this is your best
book this is this is going to change the
way people look at you because the book
because the listen and I know it to be
true because the show has done that for
me as a matter of fact for the comments
right now Facebook live and uh Periscope
um and spre cast some of you have been
longtime Maniac so it might not be the
case but I think this is the case and I
think you're going to be all surprised
by why you see what I'm about to ask
right now how many of you really upped
your level of respect or or thoughts
around me because of the Ask Gary V show
like took me from a seven to a 10 or a
three to nine or like it leveled me up
because Keynotes was the only thing that
people had out there which is really
where I'm my most you know you know
respectable we up for sure 10 times
Monumental like a lot of you knew who I
all the wild building this hundred
million doll year business like like you
know like yeah 10 to 20 like the LV did
that for me oh daily you know daily V
also did do that
right how many Gary thanks for
everything free tennis lessons for Life
stand and chatam for 6 there were 600
books that came through on Periscope
something interesting just happened on
Periscope um let's see what's going on
on Facebook here um I think I think the
ask 7 to 11 for me Gary that's actually
a good way to see it like numbers like
people really jab jab jab right hook got
me thank you Harry interesting daily V
did that for me actually saw your hustle
makes sense Chris daily V
really watching you do the audio what's
my favorite episode daily V yours and
theirs
oh what's the oh actually that's a great
question just the numbers there's only
15 of them one through 15 what's your
favorite episode of daily V
go should be interesting wltv episode 9
got me Lorenzo I love you brother that's
old school 15 14 14 6 and
10 see what else I'm asking for a
thousand Gary I'm asking for a thousand
books there's 16 there's 16 episodes I'm
sorry D 6 2 16 14 or 15
I'm asking for a th books I want to talk
about the Thousand books to they confirm
getting your email for Super Eight Greg
all your books have changed my life
there's 16 yeah episode 16 went up last
night last night all I knew was Wine
Library before the show nice big time
absolutely more on Del B very nice 12 14
5 11 16 16 a lot of people like 16 17
because I haven't seen it yet this is 17
today's been 17 what's up
17 um 14 11 11's getting a lot which one
was 11 D Rock 11
yeah which one's
11 11 got a lot of
love went from business duude to overall
life coach interesting yeah so I'm much
more 360 with ask scary you know
definitely 11 11 is day in and day out
day in and day out we went up to
uh Mar Mon oh yeah that was a good one I
like that episode
too I like that that episode two I have
a question go ahead MD the snapman 14
did get the most votes here and no one
was looking thank you pariscope honey
badger six wi Library seeing the
connections hey Gary question how do you
suggest one should hire virtual
employees now I'll get into that a
minute let me get to the uh every
episode thank you Sean
bang gaming what do you think about
Trump's uses purchase of mail confirms
Adam I don't know what that means what
if you're good
what if you have good content already MD
snapman I need to understand that better
like go way way more give me a lot
more
um seems to be seeing and ignoring which
one Laura I'm not just so everybody
knows I'm not trying to ignore anything
come and sit in front of five streams
I'm trying I'm really trying oh giving
away a seat at dinner I did see that Dam
Daniel what's that Dam
Daniel damn Daniel and Daniel
started the
book I know yeah I've heard about the
meme Gary how do you explain social
media to your grandmother um carefully
what was the you know just like you know
listen it's the newspaper any a
grandmother it's you could you can
complete complete you can uh articulate
social media so easy easily to to
grandmothers you just tell them what
happened with the radio and the
television and and the letter and you
know email a lot of grandmothers are
doing there's a lot of do why do people
give companies a lot of DC money so many
props when they have no sales because
venture capitalist uh and
Entrepreneurship got way too heralded
and overrated and overg glamorized over
the last three to five years because of
the explosion of the internet and really
Facebook and other things of that nature
um that's why I read a great article
about that tell them why you should
never take DC money Leon is emotional in
the rant Wine Library TV and the Taco
Bell pairing yes read that was a good
one Wine Library TV how many of you guys
saw Wine Library TV episode 101 how many
people saw that so weird what do you
guys think what's
that my God the faces this is very
creepy look at this Weir the crazy faces
guys that's super spooky but I weirdly
love it as that you should wear those
all the time now LIC for love come stand
in chadam getting 600 books I want to
find out who this 600 books from chadam
is somebody bought 56 yeah James Fran uh
I think it was I saw it in there nice
pumping them out printing them how we
doing we're doing well doing well are
you guys caught up yeah we're caught up
so this is it no more books no there's a
few more on there but we're caught up
and then it's we're getting close so all
right big push get us
behind good job Garrett that that might
have done it yeah that did it I think
that yes 600 books what's going on with
that 600 books yeah chat them in in
pariscope hit up in India what's your
heart bread right yep what is heart
bread two words that sound good together
heart and bread yeah really India K on
everything but it's really hard do you
want me to get you India K yeah do you
want me to get you India K on Snapchat
[__] yeah I think all right we'll talk
about it later um yes Nick
uh
what do I want to do here what do you
think oh see oh that stopped already
you're amazing balls thank you he Gary
question how do you suggest one should
hire virtual employees n i don't love
virtual employees I never have so this
is not my favorite area I think that
there's a lot of developers and tech
people that love it um and so I think
that that's somebody you should ask
about it I'm not I've not I'm not tired
Jason I uh I don't think uh I don't
think that I'm the right person to ask
about virtual I I I struggle with that I
don't like that I only had one liquor
store at the multiple office things has
been a challenge at times though I
finally got it Sherman Oaks is my office
I'm a Scorpio um damn Daniel uh and so
I'm just I'm just answering [__] now
that's crazy uh so that was my answer on
Virtual employees I'm not super oh um
Laura keeps asking this so yes I'm doing
a podcast and a video podcast with a
Sandra zadii is your aunt that crazy MD
say what's up to Sandra she was an
amazing Wine Library employee she's
super awesome I haven't talked to her a
little bit please please please tell her
I said what's up love love love love her
hope she's doing super duper well um so
I bought eight need my email
confirmation Adam Rogers 808 you got it
I'm I'm sure I'm sure you're in I mean I
don't know are they confirming the wine
dinner I'll get to that in a minute uh
Alex
you guys are you're not confirming to
you guys are replying to all these
people and saying got it for the most
part yeah all right Adam Rogers 808 is
not uh didn't get his confirmation on
his eight he wants to make sure he got
it what's what's the name Adam Rogers 8
the guy that Adam you're confirmed you
remember yeah cool remember the guy that
he single-handedly every single other
person thousands four or five thousand
people wanted me to do an askar me show
and Adam was the one person that said no
and we didn't do it mind name more books
Adam right eight book gu [__] bought
eight books and ruined everyone's
life that's funny um someone named Laura
Don just emailed me you tell Gary I
bought 56 books two hours ago he thought
no one had oh my God Laura thank you so
much done Lord done all right 300 book
buys 1,000 book buys who wants to buy a
th000 books and spend an hour with me
you don't have to take the chances of
all all these receipts just being the
one lucky oh wine dinner you're right
Laura Laura you know what I do love
Laura's hustle all right let's do this
Laura Laura how many books did you buy
you've been on me Laura wants me to give
away a seat at this dinner without sure
38 well that's a legit number I I I
tried to punk Laura and she punked me
right backing me nice coffee Laura two
more and you get another answer um so I
think Laura I think we're gonna give one
away I think I think 36 to give away
Laura 32 32 I don't want to impose on my
friends with somebody who's going to
struggle like somebody could win that
would struggle first
episode give it to Nicole I don't want
to I'm not giving it to anybody uh but I
I should I give it away for like the
third one once I understand it okay
Laura we're gonna do something good I'm
gonna give away the you're worried about
it right you got to get lucky with the
right person some people get crazy some
valuable as a priz it it's maybe more
valuable cuz it's going to be me like
the third one might be me and Ashton and
scooter braon like it might be in La it
might be ridiculous like this it could
be way better the only difference is
we're going to be doing our thing and
they're going to be watching one hour of
me focused can literally be worth
millions of dollars was happened before
it could it might not be worth anything
but like if I understand uh how often
how often what are we doing them how
often are we doing what the new podcast
I don't D Rock D Rock always loves doing
new shows how many [__] shows you
want me to do drock want me to be a
[__] circus clown huh I mean let's
just do a circus clown show Gary the
clown why don't we do that on Netflix
over the top once a month I mean what do
you want from me [__] man Jesus with
this guy soending seriously he's like
when's the I mean he's like when's the
when's the
show this guy get his da Vlog sorry dck
that I've just been hanging out for 6
hours and 25 minutes straight of pure
[__] energy don't cry Jesus Christ
this
guy right remember when Andy bought 25
books on book pal when he threw the
first right hook can I get a question
answer yeah get Michael con conver on
how's how's Tor voice going to cope
how's T oh it's gonna be fine we need a
receipt Andy will'll tell you oh he's
coming Gary London office well he's
coming but I'm sure he bought the first
25 I believe
him
Michael Michael you look great am I here
you're here there's a blank screen see
me but
thanks do you want to try do you want to
figure out
uh Alex I to see myself I can see you so
you want to maybe there's a click for
okay good man what's up what can I help
you
with well I really just wanted to ask
you one question because everybody's
always asking you business questions and
I know you kind of came up with your
father which is very similar to how I'm
coming up right now kind of went into
the family business and we've kind of
doubled it in the last couple years so
so Maz good I'm kind of curious cuz I
know you said your relationship got a
lot better with your father when you
finally stopped working day to-day at
wine libraries yes or Wine Library was
there a point where you guys just almost
killed each other where you really just
didn't know if you can make it through
it probably around the time I turned 30
which probably speaks to a little bit of
like Wine Library TV and things of that
nature it definitely got a little bit
tougher but not really never kill like
my dad and I to his credit and then I
that behavior we loved each other more
than we loved the business I give my dad
enormous amounts of credit for the
opportunity he gave me as a 22 year-old
he gave me ungodly amounts of uh
opportunity um stunning amounts of
authority and uh and I wouldn't be here
today without him and uh it's it's
unbelievable to me um how amazing he was
to me as I get older I'm 40 now my dad
was 44 years old when I came to the
business and really basically wanted to
make every decision you know
so uh it got better it got better
Michael because because you can't have
two Cooks in the kitchen right you can't
have two CEOs you just can't and so um I
think that uh I think it got better
because I got to like focus on a thing
that I was running he got to refocus on
Wine Library and I wasn't there to to
not let him or have it my way or what
have you and so that's why I got better
well that's awesome to hear man I do
appreciate that main reason some people
have worked with their fathers and
they're like I don't know how you deal
with it some I mean I met Darren Hardy a
long time ago and he said him and his
dad almost killed each other so I would
tell you this Michael I would tell you
this and there's not even a distant
second including working with my brother
nothing and I mean nothing will be a
better decision in my life than working
side by side my dad for all that time
because one day he won't be here and
it's going to be something that I very
much very much I now I cherish it and
you know I cherish it a lot it's not
something you can replace you can't make
it up you don't get to you know you
don't get to uh you don't get to uh you
don't get to say that you you just got
to do it it's kind of like daily ve like
I say hustle I mean hustle and you can't
manufacture spending that kind of um
time and so many of those moments were
tough but many of those moments were
glorious and like laying with my dad on
my bed when I was like 24 and going
through the numbers on you know on
December on on Christmas day you know
being Jewish has some funny like
different variables one being Christmas
day my dad and I were exhausted of
literally 34 days of straight intensity
18-hour days and to lay down and look at
the printed out numbers and see us
crushing our sales from the year before
and just like strategizing oh [__] I got
to sell more German wine or next year or
this that the other thing there's just
there's nothing nothing like it there's
just nothing like it and listen I take a
lot out of those times with my dad and I
want to make sure I'm smart about
thinking about how I spend time with my
my uh my kids and you can't take any day
for granted so you know days are going
to be tough and people are going to ask
you how um and this that the other thing
but I uh I cherish the moments with my
dad I really appreciate it man I feel
the same way sometimes it's really hard
but family comes first and revenue
solves all problems are going good yes I
mean listen when listen the benefits yes
when things are going good it makes it
so much easier I mean it is very
stressful when things are going poorly
and you're in a family business that's
super
tough yeah yeah I appreciate luck much
your time I know people got a lot of
thank you so much thank you so much for
buying 25 books man I means a lot to
me I feel like I got to give it anytime
there's a good person putting out good
good content I try to give it to
everybody in my family and all my
friends most of them never read it but I
still give it
so I'm G be giving your book to
everybody I can get it get in get in
their hands hopefully they'll read it if
not that's their fault that's their own
fault appreciate it brother thank you so
much you man I appreciate it take care
kid thank you I like that dude I'm in a
really good
mood
I remember last jab jab jab spast we had
the pasture on oh the pasture yeah take
a look at him can you if you look at you
can look at him first Bruce Bruce yeah
this I think this is
him I'm almost positive put him on I
think it's him I can see myself but I
get through to him I'm here
Bruce I want
it h i want Pastor Bruce I'm maing out
already all right what um all right
let's see what's going
on all right dude I offered my time
because I couldn't afford eight books
you respectfully decline this is Julian
decided to garage sale a few things
today no joke and made
$162 38 cents buying eight books now you
better [__] pick me Julian T the man
sending that receipt great hustle Julian
thank you so much man the eBay hustle
any primary thoughts about Snapchat GE
Carlo I'm a big believer big believer
and just like big believer overall the
whole thing this is super fun Julian
that's so good you're doing a great job
thank you SAS Wilson love you wish I can
make the book J watch in St Louis I
thought Julian that's so cool right in
yeah that's why you came in to talk
about the hustle us yesterday that's
awesome what a great Hustler you know
who that is right episode 100 the tennis
player yes dude I love that kid I love
that kid he ebayed that's such who's
still in the room I am Nicole let's
start I'm going to restart Periscope
guys because I get a big boost of double
every time so give me one second I'll be
right
back
yep see I'm saving this to camera roll
why
not what are you reading the book now
Alex the hell are you
doing it's G crash it's gonna Crush
right you know what's what's uh
interesting is it's just a really good
book it's good book and it's so
like it it works for so many people
right like you know what I tried to do
with the book I tried to uh have like
you know what I tried to do an India I
tried to have like seven to 15 moments
that would make people
stop and then forward the book like
chapter like what is it chapter nine and
crush it you know best marketing
strategy ever just one word care that
made a lot of people take a step back
forward it like all you need sometimes
like like all you need sometimes is one
sentence one I feel like the book has
seven to 10 answers that are game when I
read it for the audio book I was like
okay there's like seven to 10 answers
here that can really the audio book is
gonna be I think the audio book is g to
be majorly majorly majorly say it's a
whole new book whole new book new book
whole new book all right let's uh Gary I
bought eight books where do I send the
receipt uh Neo you send it to Super8
vainer media.com I'm going to put put it
in my comment right here it's already
the top it says no it's linked at the
top on spre cast but if you're on
Facebook
Andy Jesus can we do a recap yeah I
think it's time for a big recap Big
recap for
everybody um how many books have we sold
for this yeah North 4500 North to 4500
not bad I wanted 10,000 so going to fall
short
unless in one of the great rallies in 8
Hour live stream
history
we need it's just one event we need we
need receipts right now do you remember
you were spotting me eight books yes
Sheldon Sheldon Pierce is in I'm I'm
giving him eight books oh he just wants
a receipt do you want the eight books
Sheldon let's get let's buy email yes
Sheldon I saw your email well episode
200 of Ask Gary VB in London that's a
good question he wants Cyber Dust for
India I know someone got me on Cyber
Dust I love that I want Twitter I'm kid
ID Dan thank you for the one book uh
give me something what do you want Felix
45454 no receipt uh Perry pis don't
forget to follow call me live for the
giveaway details Chef lazette is
hustling for the calling live selfie in
London yes jel daps um Chef was that
hold on hold your horses cheffy I will
trade you one month of working for your
company for free in exchange for 30
minutes of your time Justin
Diana I the problem is is we can't like
take it like so easily just sent the
eight book receipt thank you Billy Funk
but Justin Dian I like your energy we
need to talk about that uh Chef that is
a legend yes she is Andrew you're a
[__] beast 8 hours yes sir Mario what
can I give you besides books nothing
Mike
nothing I want nothing but eight book
receipts and I want receipts that have
eight in them meaning 88 and eight who
wants to buy oh you know what would be
great if somebody bought 888 bucks right
now you know super great no big deal all
right I'm doing a real hard push right
now I'm going to get a little bit crazy
and give away some really good stuff so
let's get some extra receips in right
now I'm going to do a five minute thing
to get you guys are you caught up yeah
you guys are feeling good so if we like
get a really good bash here okay let's
do real hard go bash I want you guys
who's in bum no San Francisco book tour
still bought eight books thank you Brian
there is a virtual tour unemployed
respect Nile I'm not asking for that
Gary I'll give away a set of my photos
javelle I like his photos by the way we
got to talk about that we'll talk about
all the random stuff later but right now
what we need to focus on love from
Iceland uh Felix 45455 you got a book
send email to India right now with one
put one book in the title and then your
address holy crap I can actually comment
to Gary for once hell yeah Dev here we
go how many any advantage to getting the
book on the Nook no get it I love it can
I take the appointment that opened up
today no you cannot um um but great
right great ask I love you can I have a
book yes X GL India vainer media.com put
one book in the title and your address
what's in your pockets let's see my
wallet my
headphones some drock [__] all right
that's it okay now we need uh we need to
get uh we need to get serious very very
serious right now who is still debating
who's sitting here we're going to do the
big drawings the big prizes are coming
up in the next hour and 18 minutes who's
still debating another eight and put
another eight in the comments cuz I want
to see that or first eight or another 16
or another I want to get a sense of
debating I I got to get a sense of
debating another eight first eight
respect is she shy M my mom can I have a
signed book Adam Rogers Adam Rogers is
[__] asking for a lot of [__] he
canceled my show I'll buy 888 books for
2 hours for you in London this is
interesting now an hour is a th000 2
hours is 2,000 he's offering
888 he's going to have to buy them at
discount we can't buy him on Amazon at
quantity he's no he's gonna have to buy
him a discount for sure which is fine
you mean a bookpal or whatever he's
gonna have to ship it to London you know
what whoever just offered 888 for two
hours email Alex D Simone what are you
Alex Alex DS ad Simone ad Simone how the
[__] do you spell d Simone d e s i d
India stop d s i m i IM o n e o n e a d
Simone how do we spell d Simone d e e s
s i i m m o o n n e at Vayner media.com
somebody throw that up for the guy or
gal that's offering 888 Scott burman's
in for one another 12 from Ryan first
eight thank you Alo can I have a book
please I AI yes email India another
eight Billy Funk thank you it's like a
Talon it's very much like a Talon first
a first date Ryan and Jack thank you
first state Sean russer thank you first
eight Doug thank you f man I'm debating
my first man there's a lot of first
eights here boy there's feels there
feels like there's 4,500 just in this
Paris okay actually I'm going to come
back to you in a second Facebook did
that just end no it's gone okay um we're
good we're fine bro give let me get oh
another 56 from har
Harry Wow first date wow uh first well
thank you already heard about per
preneurs Gary I haven't heard about per
preneurs I assume that's Periscope but
there's a lot of people in here Nathan
you can have a book email India vainer
media.com put one book the number one
book or can yeah barter are still alive
barter's still
alive all right we're about I'm about to
go crazy so I highly recommend if you're
ever cons like here's the huge mistake
of your life your life your Gary ve life
is not buying eight books right now or
more and then ever buying anywhere close
to a books after the next hour like if
you're even in my consideration set if
you're even in the consideration set of
buying two or three or four and like or
one and you want to level up to eight um
I highly
recommend uh you uh you do this I highly
recommend you do this because I'm about
to give away an hour with me I have a
funny feeling I might give away a second
one which I'm worried
about that would really make the Roi
terrible yeah I'm a real [__]
idiot you're there you find me to be a a
really nice chap yeah yeah nice
CH that's the V London coming I'm super
London in it damn have to pay for class
can't do eight respect Nicole excited to
see you in London excited to see you all
I bought 17 but I may buy one more yes
JW 17 but I may buy another one another
one eight package or I made it happen JP
I love another 56 for Ryan okay people
are really stepping up I'm really really
getting excited 72 in exchange for 7
minute meeting if I fly out from Denver
100% do it I respect seven minute
meetings there's something consumable
about that just do it I'm not going to
do more of those but whoever that was
got me at the right
second but they have to do it now I'm
not tired actually I'm actually like
like somebody say you look tired like
I'm stunningly not tired I'm just like
trying to like understand why 58 is the
same book yes Christopher Campbell 58 is
56 is the same book you give 55 away you
sell them all back on eBay um I'm going
to adopt your book in my social media
class all my students that's 25 copies
thank you AI you'll agree with the
enthus anything love your enthusiasm I
will agree bathroom break all right I
didn't even go to the bathroom the whole
time I just sat here the whole time
Jesus uh I've got two coming on 323
would love one on release day can I buy
you lunch May here I appreciate it but
no unless you send it here and I can't
even eat like mics and charge the whole
thing's a mess um I'll get 10 minutes in
New York I'm in New York 80 bucks Gary
can I get 10 minutes for 80 bucks okay
so now a thousand is did 72 for seven no
I know but I'm not I don't want to do
that anymore I told you that guy ripped
me off I'm by the way just so you know
that guy [__] is getting seven oh
that gal respect lady she's getting
seven minutes Julie's getting seven
minutes she's coming in it's going to be
like seven minutes you know it's going
to be 11 minutes cuz I get like crazy
and I'm like oh I didn't fully get my
answer to
her
um can I have my first book send me a
tea I will carry drock's bag a battery
bag for a day say no the ROI won't die
respect Gary when are you coming to
Iceland them I'd love to come to Iceland
somebody buy 5,000 books I'll be
there um all right all right eight books
for one single minute of your time pre
or post 92 Y show I'll be there anyway I
could probably get the feel like I'm
getting H feel like people are starting
to really RI me off people are getting
me like people are tricking me IND I
feel like I'm being
tricked my girl
bam just bu I'm gonna buy 56 books for a
single Gary ve hair okay that was easy
no book not give
you you want to call Pastor no I I love
you Pastor but I I have to I I have to
focus on this right now you're I can't
do the phone call thing but I'll get
back to you Pastor I love you uh how
many books do dck didn't buy some books
I think right or not yet I'm gonna buy
it wow did you just see what happened
Andy you didn't buy any books either
your face was so funny no I don't Andy
did you buy books no so wait a minute
let's let's let's let's take a step back
drock India and Andy
combined have zero
bucks all
right my mom bought one
I told her too same do for the Indie
book
stores Stefan I mean there's no shot
here Stefan you buy any books
yet that I mean that I knew before I
asked shame
on your dad's gonna buy the alarm
clock I love your dad so much all right
please first state will you sign one for
me please those sold out fast today
barnes's a noble
was
like that was
fast about them selling out of
course explain to me why I should buy
eight oh decline this phone number uh
you should you know I think the biggest
reason to buy eight in my opinion is the
ROI Exchange in my opinion the way I
roll it's the ROI exchange of if I've
brought you enough value for eight bucks
because you've been watching the show
for a couple years and I've answered
questions this that and the other thing
um uh Laura has bought 112 what's that I
need to understand what that is uh Max
and Hannah bought a book that's my niece
and nephew thank you Max and Hannah uh
and so I think that's the number one
reason uh the other reason is I actually
think it's a game-changing book I really
do think it's the most impactful book
thanku economy was too heav for the
masses jab jab Right Hook was quite
valuable and it was a textbook but it
doesn't get you get pumped right like
like nobody gets pumped or motivated to
get something done Crush had changed
lives Ask Gary ve will change lives and
be detailed and be hey and like it's my
360 I mean look the Ask Gary ve book is
tricky because I've talked about you
know I wish everybody was born an
immigrant I've talked about perfectly
parented I've talked about crushed it
the truth is if this gets as crazy as it
could and it might based on some of the
early reviews I'm getting from
people I might have to come out with the
the second edition of the ask V book
like it's it you would have to you guys
agree with me that askary is is
structured to be a a multiple edition
book right yeah a lot of I'm just going
to link everybody to this there's a lot
of barters coming in yeah but it's all
like [__] like people like I'll buy
a book for like nine weeks of your life
one one guy said 100 books for 25
minutes and I said 15 minutes in Mond
but is that a is that right a thousand
books is an hour Andy yeah and that's
divided by six like stick to the math
that guy who got me for 72 RI me off
don't let that be the
that girl I'm sorry Julie Julie RI me
off cuz she's a beast she found the
right timing and she got me but but but
Andy 10 minutes is like aund like we ran
the math like I have a business to run
here no seriously I mean like it's not
she said I have a family that I don't
get to see I have a business to run like
it's not so easy for
me you know like like like it's just not
that
easy
D all right let uh I'm about to start
giving away a ton of [__] though and so
I highly recommend if you're gonna buy
your books you do it right now eight 16
24 32 40 48 as a matter of fact if
you're like trying to negotiate with
Andy and rip him off because he's
getting ripped off left and right um not
I know but just stick with me Andy play
with me a little Andy uh then then this
is the time to do it buy it get your
entries in here win twice
you should definitely do
seven of the audio book sorry yes seven
of the book and one give be the audio
book right one yeah however you get to
eight is fine eight right hooks in a row
all right Chef that let's just call her
give me your phone this yours that's
India that's India India call us
that uh I would buy book but it's not
available anywhere in Poland but you can
buy it on like Amazon UK and ship it to
Poland right it's expensive but how do
you get the book
Carol you go to
Amazon I think that's a good one lots of
other places by the way Barnes & Nobles
how about eight books for zero minutes
of your time benwa benwa Beno you are my
man hello hello Chef hey what's up
things are good oh my God I'm so proud
of you this is just tremendous what a
fun day this is there thank you so much
what do you got for us I got whatever
you want my friend you know me you know
how I roll no but you said you you said
you had something specific of course I
have it
so I have two prizes exclusive to New
Yorkers and that is to have chefette
exclusively come and do a dinner for
four people at your house in New York in
New York so how are we gonna do that I
think they should email you Chef lazette
I think and then you should pull it out
so anybody in New York or willing to
come to New York Chef lazette will
exclusively cook for you for you and
three of your
guests and you and you've got to send uh
your request to Chef lizette's email
which is which is lazette l i z t
chef.com lazette chef laett.com and
let's spell lazette one more time Li i z
e
z so l y z
tte chef.com good uh everybody pick that
up in the streams spree cast get in
here I will don't worry I'm not going
anywhere let me just get you the emails
there that keep it calm let's go you're
going to take your of periscope I know
that but Facebook live um lazette Chef
laett.com
um okay and go ahead chefette what's the
second one the second one is to anyone
around the world and that is two dozen
of my exclusive the best signature
chocolate chip cookie that took me 18
years to come up with this original
recipe talking about ingredients from
around the world you have tasted them
the crew has tasted them the crew loves
them Stefan ate like 40 of them they're
literally the best CH know you guys have
had at another I know I know I'm kidding
I'm K I was kidding I was kidding
kidding so I'm talking about L thank you
two two dozen of the best chocolate chip
cookies two dozen of the best chocolate
chip cookies in the world around the
world and so I'm going to pull this one
Lizette the winner of the two dozen of
the best chocolate chip cookies in the
world and you've got an email lazette
Chef lazette uh lazette now they're
asking they're asking if they're
organic let me paint the story these are
ingredients from around the world I have
tested every vanilla from around the
world every sugar every flour every
chocolate I mean I cannot tell you the
ingredients let's put it this
wayette they're excited about the
ingredients but here are the questions
are they vegan are they organic neither
good that's fine listen I don't you know
me I don't care about animals or Mother
Nature so I'm not worried here we go the
winner of the cookies two dozen of every
ingredient reading from the world tested
and then picked for these chocolate chip
cookies
is Faith
Chipman
Faith congratulations faith faith
Chipman you need to email lazette and
that's that lazette thank you so much
darling yes hold on the is a whole
another thing I mean they got to buy way
more than 50 books are you kidding me oh
the dinner well the dinner they're
emailing you lazette you've got to you
set the rules for that anybody that's
trying to win the dinner in New York
they're emailing you listen I'm a baller
my friend I want you to make Bank on
this book so it's about the highest bid
and got it the bid starts at 50 books
minimum got it minimum got it so anybody
who's bought 50 books or more email
liette she's raising it oh what email
got it okay lazette thank you so much
darling my lazette coming through have
what are you looking for what oh for
Faith I'll search I'll search her faith
her name's Faith thank God thank God it
wasn't
rickette how did you meet Casey nead how
do I meet
Casey you we all look at dck no I met
dck I met Casey before drock I think or
no help me D Ro I really I'm not sure
like watch bun YouTube video found Casey
he's the best I don't remember exactly I
feel like I spoke to him like I feel
like I spoke to him before the whole
YouTube vlogging thing but I don't I'm
not sure but we we did we went to go
through an episode yeah I mean I was
already investor in beam like he know
Jerome like maybe through Jerome early
grape story good call all right I love
Casey too what's happening here who is
considering Gary I'll buy 800 books
Let's understand what bizar know is
saying stop me dead in my tracks um I
will fly you and I will meet with you
and I will spend an hour with you and
I'll talk about the Jets with you I will
work on your business with you I will
really Jam I will fly you anywhere in
the world uh this is why you want to get
your receipts in right now buy eight
books you get one entry buy 16 you get
two email me at Super Eight super the
number eight at Vayner
media.com uh no if you're in New Jersey
we can't fly somewhere we're just
meeting in New Jersey yes economy class
you can't buy it on Amazon UK yes you
can my books on Amazon UK been getting
receipts all day hour Gary is worth so
much more thank you Sheldon I like
Sheldon who like scam me for eight bucks
good job
Shel someone wants to I told him to
tweet dck and ask five five books for
five minute call with oh yeah that's
done GH I haven't even checked my email
Daye oh downloading
200 this is
bad the one book thing is insane yeah
people one
B yep we'll talk about that later
um
on what you got Flynn I got Flynn all
right Pat Flynn uh what's the password
get it in here real quick it's not
working it's where that is before you
put them
on
it's been a long
day last
hour
now last hour
Flynn how are you
brother looking good in your studio man
how are you thanks I app it good I got D
my book here with me have you had a
chance to start looking have you had a
chance to start looking at it yeah I
scan through it dude awesome I love your
show everybody who
watch
anything thank you brother you're chop
you're Pat you're chopping for me a
little bit am I yeah I'm not sure no
you're not chopping I'm sorry the audio
is not coming through as clean as I'd
like it
to that was actually the first question
I had for you why are you
onc
not I don't know I haven't played with
blab I I love spr cast we didn't really
we weren't even going to do anything
besides you were having trouble blab you
you guys didn't love it you know I
really wasn't involved these guys kind
of uh did their thing and um we've had
success with spr cast in the past but
not for a long time I don't think I've
been on for a year and change we weren't
even going to do like a main thing like
this it was all going to be kind of
Facebook live pariscope mircat and then
we wanted to have guys like you and
other people come on so that's what we
kind of did so that's why do
blab no I don't I think it's a weird
name excuse me you don't use blab
because you think it's a weird
name no I'm p on on Periscope y uh
mostly now snap yeah man that SnapChat
thing has just been so interesting to
watch how you been man why don't you
tell uh all the the vayer nation right
now uh that doesn't know you a little
bit about
yourself Fernando started I will wear it
go ahead go ahead
P I got laid off my
AR had about that
business and them
I really tough from there I started
smart pass.com which is where a lot of
people know from hey Pat real Pat real
quick before you keep going is is the
headphones you're wearing are is it the
audio is that the
audio oh the mic keep going I can hear
it much better but I I want it to be a
little bit better but keep going so you
started the podcast which is exactly
where how this how does this sound does
this sound better 7,000 times better my
my face just ripped off I'm so excited
go ahead okay good so I started
smartpassiveincome.com which comes with
a podcast and all this stuff we actually
just passed 25 million downloads which
I'm super super stoked about uh now I
get paid to speak like you do not quite
as obviously and uh writing books I just
uh very happy to have your support for
the book too I saw you tweet about it
the other day did um I don't know if you
know this but it became a Wall Street
Journal bestseller uh which I'm super
stoked about I mean this kid who
self-published a book from his own home
in San Diego California like it's
amazing to me that this this is actually
possible and I have you to than for that
you know crush it was a big inspiration
for me and now I'm actually stoked to
see how this all pans out for you
because uh I'm in the book world now and
I'm I'm very very closely paying
attention to to how you're running the
show here and this eight super live
stream thing is is genius like you and
your team I'm I'm following you guys
closely because you guys you guys got it
nailed down so kudos to you kudos to
your team for everything that you guys
are doing um this is this book is going
to be huge it's I I'm excited to see
where it lands thank you brother so Pat
what's uh what's been most exciting in
the last several months with the podcast
uh what did you learn from your book
launch your first one like what was
different uh what was different than you
thought what was exactly like you
thought give me some give me some
vibes well you know I went through a
little hacky sort of pre-sale process
cuz as a self-published author you don't
get access to some of the other things
that traditional Publishers would give
you access to um so in order to pre-sell
on Amazon for example I had to go
through Amazon advantage and I did this
whole hacky thing and uh I really got
lucky with how everything worked out
despite having working with like this
huge machine that could have broken at
any time uh but I was very surprised to
see how high it climbed actually got the
top 22 overall in all books on am just
this dude who writes a book out of his
own home in San Diego did you do did you
do did you did goodbye jelle did you do
a did you do a push on Amazon to get it
to 22 like did you kind of rally the
troops on One Moment One Day yeah yeah I
mean for a whole year I've been pushing
the fact that this book was coming out
you know marketing starts the moment you
start working on something not as soon
as it's done
obviously
100% oh I'm
listening Patty we're good there until
the last
second Pat just froze let's see what we
can do again Pat back on because he's
exactly right that marketing starts then
my son says what's up Mariah saying
what's up to your son Gary's book should
be a school curriculum I agree Super 8
email is down I'm not sure about that
Nar super the number8 vainer media.com
date with India for 32 books India you
want to help red Harbor wants to know I
think you're worth way more than 32
bucks thank you 8,000 books date with
India wow I'm just telling you right now
if somebody buys 8,000 books you're
going on that [__] date that
date
a uh we're working on Pat Gary Q for you
from
[Laughter]
India that was amazing yeah yeah second
thought you know what I'll take that day
for 30 I'll do you know 32 is not bad
now Frozen but I think you guys can see
me we can see you you're back uh yep we
can hear you see me okay yes see you
great uh so you're right marketing
starts long before you uh actually uh
have it come out oh he can't hear me he
can't hear me you can't hear me
Pat you can't hear
me where's the producer's chat there
used to be a producer's childn this
thing Andy's goingon to jam with you
while I uh wait for that Periscope talk
to me talk to me talk to me who wants
free askar book I've got seven to give
away Wendy maze you rock date with India
for 8,000 books that's right you guys
can't see can I get the book please when
can you come back to LA I can hear you I
can hear you and see you hey there's a
chat again cool feeling good I am
feeling good JP see you hear me great is
Gary still live too yes I am I have no
communication with Gary right now that's
bad that's bad so I'm probably talking
over him and being rude no you're not
being rude you're amazing I just get off
yeah let's try one more time yeah let's
try one more time um seven books are
gone thanks guys Julie thank you hi
India Chris Duncan India stop flirting I
feel like India's like closing dates
left and right now I'm kidding I'm
kidding I said
hi the barrier of my flirtation is so
low hi
hi Melbourne what's up Canada what's up
top 10 Snapchat advice Secrets Jason put
out content uh use your other channels
to get awareness um and uh and try
different styles filters things of that
nature but it comes down to the same old
thing it's content and distribution
content and distribution are you putting
out something interesting are you
getting people to find out about it by
using other people or other channels
that you have that have people's
attention blah blah blah Pat you hear
me I can hear you can you hear me yeah
this we're back so you're right it's
marketing before the book comes out
thank you Maria for buying eight uh What
uh so you were marketing for a year
around the
book yeah I guess you didn't hear the
whole rest of the 10 minutes CU I had
frozen out or something but anyway uh
markting the book getting people
involved having them help make decisions
of different parts of the book you know
book cover and all that stuff the more I
can inject people into my process the
more likely they are to be involved with
me when I actually sell it try building
that trust get involved it reminds me of
a story when I was in high school I was
super short I was 5 feet tall my junior
year of high school so I was like this
tiny kid yeah right um I also wet my bed
till 12 by the way bang and
bed that's me bed weathers unite dude we
should start a bed weather's unite you
know what I want to Andrew hat hold on
one second this is important Andrew I
need you to start designing right away a
t-shirt for my tea public that says bed
wers
unite I could definitely do that thank
you I need an ASAP Pat what size do you
wear medium t-shirts I wear medium yes I
grew out of the 5T tall thing you will
uh you will be getting a bed weet unite
t-shirt and I have a I have a weird
feeling that this is going to become a
huge huge
t-shirt you know when you said that on
anchor because I'm I'm I'm up on anchor
now um a lot of the reaction from your
your tribe was like wow you're so
transparent you're so authentic thanks
for that maybe TMI but despite that it's
awesome and I think that represents kind
of you and I think you and I align in
that way was just all about being real
right you had that uh video for the
people in the fitness industry who were
like show mole every once in a while
like just it doesn't in light you know
and so I love that you share that and I
think this is this is the start of a
great movement here of just authenticity
in business which is what it should have
been in the first place 100% but yeah
I'm looking for what's going what's
going on who who's coming up on the show
on the podcast everybody should be
listening to your podcast what's coming
up on the
podcast uh well you are coming on the
podcast Point what now pat pat since
I've been on the podcast before what's
your plan how many times have you had
two time
guests four what's your what's your
usual yeah what what's what's your plan
do you have a plan so my plan I mean to
talk to you about these things that are
hot now that I've never talked about
before Snapchat anchor and to get out of
your head why people should be paying
attention got it smart stuff that you
you talked about on before but you know
I never want to ask you the same like oh
how did you get started story yeah we
don't need to do that different yeah
you'll be right back I got to start
again I want to know Anor in your
thoughts of that and for Snapchat
specifically if you could give me some
advice which I think might help other
people too watching this you know I love
Snapchat but I'm just having a hard time
growing that following you know I've
kind of plateaued at the number of
people who who view each of my how how
many what number what number are you at
with uh your snap like 390
390 yes um so I I think first and
foremost you have to try as many
different styles as you've like
different [__] right like like bless you
India maybe things that you've never
shared before uh maybe you know like
what's your biggest hobby that is
probably not at the Forefront of your
audience that like I still think like
your sneaker collection or you know I
know that you're tremendously uh
involved in nonprofits and things I I
don't have a you know you know me I
don't consume so I suck so I don't know
exactly what you've been sharing or not
one thing to do is create your Snapchat
as a place you're putting out content
that you've put out nowhere else H if I
shared my family life on Snapchat I'd
have [__] 400 thou I'd [__] kill
it but I don't want to go there but like
I've been thinking about that um number
two you're going to have to do
collaborations you're going to have to
hustle if you really want to build it up
you're G to have to reach out to your
fellow podcasters and like go there and
have and take over their Snapchat for a
day they take over yours collabos
collabos collabos collabos okay I'm
going to save this for the for the
interview so I don't want to do this so
anyway Pat let's I got I got to do my my
pulling of my contest in a minute let's
spend one more two more minutes what's
uh besides me who's coming up on the
show end of the last three or four
months what's your favorite uh podcast
guest not F I mean like you love them
all they're all your kids but what has
really stood
out did he freeze oh son of a [__]
is you're back you're back
Pat Pat you're
back [__] he doesn't hear me Pat Can You
Hear Me Andy you there bro I think I
froze again Pat can you hear us hear
you you want me to come back on Andy
yeah same thing yeah same thing God damn
it all right Facebook hope you we were
just wrapping up too Facebook what's up
it's open up 11 can I get a can I get a
signed copy of the that's from before
all right
let's see eight bucks eight times books
for two entry level tickets to Sydney I
can't I can't do that Andrew I'm not in
control of that event so if I buy five
books on Amazon I find no Pete uh what
up Carlos Gale first time commenting
thank you so much Facebook live give it
to me give it to me give it to me give
it to me that comments uh I saw P for a
second all right would love to see
personal side I'm sure most people love
that I know I'm just keeping that to
myself thought of Kickstarter yeah I
think about it stand St Louis stand up
is right bro back tensan is back it's
good to see all right Pat the last three
months right we're going to wrap up with
this the last three months uh what's
been your favorite uh podcast interview
because I want to make sure people are
listening to your show obviously you
love them all they're your children you
don't want to call somebody out and hurt
feelings but this you know let let's
keep it dude like what's your favorite
your favorite show that you've had Iowa
what
up okay let me look this up right now
because I've had so many great ones um
got some great ones coming up too there
was one I
did in actually episode 200 with a guy
named Todd treser he runs Financial
mentor.com he tripled his website
traffic by deleting a third of his
content so he essentially audited his
blog and the cool thing that he said was
you know your blog as you grow it over
time you know you're pumping content
every day that content gets out a date
and it's almost essentially like a first
draft and when you when you come out
with a book you never publish the first
draft of a book but what essentially
everybody sees on your blog is a first
draft of everything that you've written
because it's there it's chronological
you don't go back and edit stuff and so
Google's looking into this now they're
they're looking at content and relevancy
and stuff so he's seeing this trend um
SEO Moos and all those guys who are big
in the SEO world are talking about how
companies are are crushing it now by
deleting old irrelevant stuff and I'm
actually going through this right now I
have website design that's coming out
with a lot of deleted content
interesting have to talk about so that's
been that's a great one to actionable
content I like that as well also
uh the one that I did with Daniel Decker
who led my street team my I had a launch
Team to help launch my book for about
500 people who were there with me right
a month before the process they they got
it uh they got access to the manuscript
early they were giv me a lot of great
tips and of of course on launch day they
just went ballistic with everything they
definitely helped shoot it up there
quite high in the rankings fast for me
that's awesome working with people again
before the thing comes out and giving
them special access special deals was uh
was was big so that's uh 198 of um
awesome the SPI podcast so on that share
that what's that charge my phone allow
me to share that bring me bring me the
charger okay can you find somebody with
a battery Pat I'm not going to let you
leave without this following right hook
everybody on Periscope everybody
watching Pat Flynn p a t f l y NN s p is
his Snapchat user handle let's come on
the man he really wants to go more he
doesn't want to see 390 [__] story
views anymore he really wants to see
600 I know those I know you guys can
help do it for him he's a great kid he's
a great dude how old are you Pat like 20
33 I know I'm kidding no I know I know I
know I Shing I Shing Pat I'm excited
about being on your show did we nail
down the time
yet uh yes I believe we did awesome oh
actually we were gonna we were gonna do
it today weren't we before I decided to
make this a super eight there yeah sorry
about that yeah which is cool so no I'm
happy to talk to you anyway and oh the
hustle I love brother stay well Pat take
care PE guys good kid 33y old kid Pat
Ying
33 uh all right so Pat Flyn SBI that was
great Pat gave some actionable item I
bought mine on Audible thank you so much
Pat's Snapchat was Pat Flynn
SPI SPI Gary the legend thank you Jay
Robinson I appreciate that love not four
I don't know what that is Gary hello
hello India Snapchat t-shirts not 40 I'm
not sure what that is let's keep looking
I feel for you India not sure what
that's in reference to no probably some
of the jokes before only 5,000 books to
come to Paris from one person can be
yeah be a huge group of people Mark put
together the whole thing 96 books
sequals wristband I need to figure out
what that means all right this is the
last push I'm going to make my hardcore
play here it is full pledge hardcore
hardcore
play I need more bucks
i' really appreciate it and I'm about to
give away a ton of stuff and they're
going to have to catch up to this
hardcore plea so we have to do it right
now I hateing said if I sing Wrecking
Balls they spy 24
bucks s just the chorus Jack just the I
never knew I don't even know the words
of any [__] song ever it up yeah
wrecking B fantastic I'll buy eight then
thank you signed book by team it was
nice seeing AJ you're right you should
have more often I agree I love AJ uh I
will sing Wrecking Ball tick tick tick
it hit me like
a oh wow what's that research on Pur a
pre lots of ceiling yes it is lots of
ceiling
sorry um but can you rap Gary I wish I
could man if I could rap you'd know it
by
now I can beat box um all right eight
more books guaranteed sign copy done
Jeff we'll figure it out
we claw we changed our hearts in vain we
jumped never asking
why we kissed I fell under your spell
love no one can
deny don't you ever say I just walked
away I will always want
you I can't live a li running for
I will always want
you I came
in I never sorry sorry sorry I got
excited got excited all right if that I
just heard I mean all I know is if that
didn't compel
everybody to
hit up to
eight I Don't Know Jack Chen 32 books
for that Jack Chen from he did that bang
Jack Chan I love you brother oh my God
that was the best I forgot Dr Rock was
found daily b 17 is going to be
different uh have much time left getting
the receipt I'm putting in my order now
we by the way I'm not joking with this I
I think a lot of people going to be
upset because the ton shuts down at
eight uh what does one do with 300 books
Fabian you give them away you sell them
you Leverage The 299 books to get to
other businesses by leveraging brand
Equity we talked about that earlier um
so there's a lot you can do this is it
guys it's coming in right now 8 minutes
left any more first edition sign know
those were sold out early um seven plus
one seven books plus an audio yes buying
eight now Joshua Lee I'm going to start
shouting out everybody that's confirming
this in MLM industry Peter most people
in that space I'm not very fond of a lot
of people selling people a dream it's
been a tough space enough to fully put
my stamp on it but it's tricky
Joshua Lee ordering now Eric Shields
bang if you're saying that you're
ordering in a we need a highlight reel
you'll get the Highlight Reel a right
hook from Russia I love bought another
eight Katrina I love you for that do I
get a sign copy if I order 24 yes Ryan
email Alex D Simone Oh there's action
over here right what's going on with the
chat here Zoom chat boom guys I'm going
to get you guys in here I'm sorry it
eight more hours eight more hours uh
French translation will come wait
already order 16 see you in London Daily
for a hard oh what's find out what
that's going I bought a Beth boom love
you bought another eight Katrina bought
another eight homie Mikey piff thank you
so much Beth nidi thank you so much just
bought eight give hi.com a shout out
brother I sure just did nicoo this is
the time to hit it now guys book me
ordering one book struggling college kid
Sean O'Brien I appreciate the one
ordering a now David only eight border
books though send in super eight just
bought five more copies to equal eight
that's what I'm talking about sending
both receipts uh these receipts are
about to come in let's get ready been on
with you all day thank you Dil I've
noticed you got a lot of questions in
got my eight and added a jab jab thank
you Jason buying eight and sending it to
eight current customers to add value to
them is the eight one just for the new
book yes Stephen but you can buy one of
the others got my eight earlier today
working on putting the blog to promote
it thank you so much just just got my
confirmation email thank you Benji
Andre's a done
turn the bucket upside down please will
you be coming to Singapore not
yet yeah I know book is$ 599 and overall
name damn you need to sell a lot of
books I think we sell a lot of books why
are we only $ 599 5.99 yeah I thought it
would have been way higher that is delay
the ranking
yeah I thought you were saying copies I
was like wait a second Jennifer P was
like this was fun I was glad it was sick
today that's funny
sick are you guys hanging out now why we
you guys
we over be for the you guys want to see
who wins it one book brought thank you
so much I'll translate into Spanish
gratus I'm Mar I'll take you up on that
give Thor give thoron a shout out Nick
there you go th h r o LS o n.com just
bought 10g thank you David but you
should buy you should have bought eight
or 16 but I'll take the time thank you
so much thank you so much exciting it's
a good been a good day thank you also
bought my eight earlier today thank you
so much buying eight more that makes 88
Russell oh Russell bear that's awesome
he's the best thanks Russell Jack Chen
32 yeah Jack Chen we heard about that I
ordered five we'll wait till next week
but you have my word thank you UL I have
a total of nine now eight to give away
thank you so much
Brian uh what dinners oh we got to get
back to dinners in a second eight
Affinity will help translate to Chinese
that's interesting toe we need to talk
about that uh bought another 56 hope for
that 10 minutes of time Harry 12 we'll
talk about that eth H Puck should be
changing its name to Vayner Middle
School I appreciate that Greg Glick um
Gary my 14-year-old is dying for me to
say hi to you Maria it's done I'll buy
eight now if you guarantee episode 101
of daily V just like Wine Library can't
do it Daniel Polish people are used to
it help translate in Portuguese people
we need to by the way we have a lot of
work to do over the like especially when
I go on tour I think one of the things
we have to do at scale is read all the
comments from these six or seven like
Facebook there's so much good stuff
there like find out if everybody got in
and like what do they want to translate
to Portuguese and they eight Nerd Chuck
they eight I like that we'll buy more
books for an answer Gary will you stream
the dinners Laura 3232 we will not H we
we're definitely going to podcast the
dinners we're going to film it it'll be
part of daily B we'll probably
Andy long
um so we'll see we'll see we may stream
we're going to stream it now cuz I want
to stick it the only reason I said don't
stream is because I wanted to be podcast
first yes I know you want to have people
go to the podcast it'll be fun to see
where can I buy some of your books well
you can go to Amazon local bookstores we
have a big local bookstore thing going
on we can't tell you how many books but
we we've rattled off all of that we need
some leaders for that we'll talk about
that we'll need that clip at some point
keep that in mind as you guys are
editing for that have you been so what
you filmed well you do that all time
um Jeff Lord's looking for a shout out
for his doc but I need to understand how
many books he's been in for Crush
propelled me to grow two businesses to
six figures can't wait to see ask scary
ve does I'm in for 16 thank you TJ TJ if
you have two businesses that have done
six figures because of crush it 16 is
great I want 24 come on right and
hundreds of thousands of dollars bought
eight earlier purchased by my startup
all we could afford but definitely in it
thank you so much Tim Vasquez I really
appreciate it whoa
what Dean Miller 300 bucks James Stella
thank I don't know how you do that on
Amazon but he's from my town which is
more
interesting call them email right now
how do you buy 300 Amazon I thought they
capped it at 30 do you think he's
editing I think your town is
shyy that's
likely ordering another four audio books
on Thursday that's
awesome definitely bought eight giving
them all to my friends thank you Kyle so
so so so so much uh where can I buy some
of your books a lot of places my boy 14
and he's listening to crush it I love it
the Honey Badger needs a birthday shout
out happy birthday honey badger that is
amazing I'm at eight books Bud my man
pots and pans thank you so much lar mon
Larch mon karate Big Ups to everybody on
mircat really appreciate all of you guys
so much Mighty CBU love it um what's
that um oh that people are buying for
others love it the V effect the greed
thank you guys so much we're wrapping up
here 5:30 now kind of shutting it down
do you have what's going on with
receipts just got a bunch in yeah a
bunch of people just bought them they're
going to be emailing them in so I'll let
you guys do your thing a little bit and
um I'll let you guys keep buying uh I
will take a copy giveaway okay
ni because of Gary and the impact Crush
made I have a career I do today thank
you Carlos Gill I always see the love
you give me g v got my Aid in thank you
David Emil Lombard thank you so much
Carlos re always with me appreciate the
one uh it's 9:30 a.m. on Wednesday in
Sydney will the book be on Audible it is
right now Obie go pre-order it love the
engagement today thank you Jennifer it's
11:30 p.m. in Germany G sharing my super
eight Super Eight on my social medias
thank you Super8 yep at bner media.com
Eric Shields you've got it
right for Amazon you can edit edit it
your cart oh for Amazon you can edit
your cart to get more than
30 I think that's right you just play
with that a little bit uh they told me
the email before I didn't see that great
[__] I'll get the audible version thank
you thank you so much we'll continue
sharing when do you spend time with the
family Laura vacations weekends uh other
random times some
who's somebody's birthday phone is on
fire been watching for two hours thank
you Romano what kind of books do you
sell business
business it's been an intense day yeah
it's been a good day you know what's so
funny I don't even feel like we've been
really doing it like I'm not even joking
like the seven and a half hours felt
super easy like right like can you
believe it's over yeah when it was like
3:30 I was like [__] seemed like an hour
and a half like when we were on for like
it was funny when I was saying like oh
here you go dag uh so we're now 7 and a
half 7 hours 32 minutes in um I really
appreciate so many of you hanging with
me all day it was a ton of fun Facebook
live rolling right now straight killing
it thank you Dan uh you're number one on
Amazon probably number one in business
like or new and noteworthy new and
noteworthy I'm not number one one unless
it updated and I got
crazy that would have been much
better that would have been fun yeah and
business probably right what do we
overall on Amazon right
it 211 211 that's a nice number jump
four something right I think it's going
to go up higher up number one in
business Katrina said it was four
something it's 21 211 is a nice jump and
what's interesting is we just did a big
push and it's usually quite delayed it's
not an hour delay it can get it can get
interesting didn't buy askary buo boo
yet book yet but just bought crush it on
Amazon Kindle for $3.99 Amazon crush it
is $3.99 on Kindle right now I'm about
to make crush it number one on
Kindle Kindle edition with AIO video 34
in business
a yep what's that how does that work
what's that Kindle edition with audio
video 3.99 well it came with audio and
video in the Kindle edition there's like
audio and video in it wait so crush it
is $3.99 on the Kindle right now
$3.99 who
wants how many of you read crushit yes
no rally time Facebook live uh Periscope
spree cast yes no how many of you have
read crush it yes no just went from 599
to 211 in the last 5 minutes right it'll
be that for a while wasn't yesterday's
episode there's a CLI dude MD Snapchat
man go watch Daily V16 where I'm
literally complaining about just the
five minute meeting my five minutes how
much are my how many books do you have
to buy for five minutes 75 75
right 75 times 20 bucks right [__] is
expensive times money oh look at this in
56 seconds my Facebook live video will
end cuz this one made it to an hour 30
really yeah oh wow I feel terrible
everybody on Facebook is going to miss
the drawing no I'm kidding I'm kidding I
love how you guys fell for
that he did you see I didn't go like I
know I know let's not be tough on it all
right
okay Kindles are dead need need Apple
Books for $3.99 I'll order a Kindle
version
2 I have no idea what this is Randall
sbot this is a live stream that I've
been doing for eight hours about my new
book askar ve wait should I give this
book
away yeah who wants this book
signed who actually I oh 6 seconds on
Facebook live four three I love you see
in a second I'm going to put it back on
now
wow boom it's over wow that's
wild
okay that's so
interesting what's
that
any
ENT all right who who here's the real
question man we're at 1,200 on Facebook
live is a nice number now it's just got
to start back all up uh you should be a
guest on Shark Tank agreed uh if I win I
buy eight more nice faan prizes all
right who can't afford a book and I
don't mean you desperately want to sign
copy but you straight up don't go with
me I'm going to go a different way uh
can't put in can't in the comment
section put in can't in the comment
section um and so I'm going to go with
Jenny Hansen boom she
won Jenny Hansen email
India India Banner media.com
Jenny enjoy Jenny
Hansen I need a new marker by the way oh
[__] that was funny all right Jenny
Hansen congrats Jenny let's clap it up
for Jenny thank you thank you thank you
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome uh Parker snare Greg Glick
throwing all sorts of high school and
Junior High and Elementary School
references at me I love that uh and
so uh congrats congrats congrats
congrats um I want the sign copy please
got one can't afford eight respect thank
you don't have much money deciding which
of your books to buy you just made my
day thanks
Jenny
um well done Jenny I agree all right so
let's see what's going on Facebook here
oh 1700 viewers in a heartbeat more than
before love it just hit the right
crochet out share it up Facebook we're
getting to the big point now share it up
hit the share button Periscope don't
don't make me Periscope don't make me I
I might kick you guys out of the the
drawing all together I need real shares
there we go St Louis no seriously like
I'm eight books in the Matt level I love
it Jenny Hansen just invited I'll keep
you on don't worry but nailed it all
right so how what's going on with
receipts can you get me an update can
you guys help actually see what they
need because we I need to wrap this up
and then like if you guys can help that
would be awesome
um this was a lot of
fun boy it feels like I sold a lot more
books than I've ever had before in a
short period of time and Amazon ranks
I've got gotten much higher I have a
funny feeling in 2 or 3 hours how many
of you screwed around with Amazon ranks
I have a funny feeling the number's
going to shoot the hell up I think it's
on a three to four hour delay I don't
know went no but I that jump from I
think that jump from 4 to two was speak
to that no I know that'll be interesting
me I'll do aie
spansion Alex what
he's always important oh here we go
there's still about a dozen PL around 10
to a dozen left but I wanted to get
those to
you that was a good stack some people
are saying to mix it up though cuz they
get worried about 100% don't worry I
will mix my ass
up no I'm really going to mix it like
really good like both ways I don't want
the new people to lose out either like
it's going to be
right here there's a lot
here I mean this is super
fun
uh that was pretty eight hours India 8
hours Andy K 2200 on Facebook live now I
love
it um my phone is about to die that's a
bad timing dump it he's going to invest
in Sharpie
nexts at the bathroom dump it I don't
want to dump it yet I may dump it at the
end save those receipts yeah I could do
other giveaways let's
see see all right see what's going on
with Facebook live comments need to
update this should be coming in oh
Facebook live comments are coming right
there going to do a show today I can't
believe it I can't believe we didn't do
an askar
show it was that one
dude it was
unbelievable can't believe that happened
really I
can't
away just bought 24
more I really appreciate everybody who's
stepping up right now means a lot to me
coming through for me like this it means
a lot seriously it's a big
deal TT people
buy your dad text if people are really
buying it he was watching people really
buying it buying it they're really
buying it you know who really bought it
there a thank you for this
person just a random thank
you huge thank you Karen Keir I love you
so
much thank you put it back in
actually can't wait to see you in April
can't wait to see oh that's what I want
to do I want that's going to be the
first thing I'm going to give away
that's going to be a pretty good prize
I'm going to fly you to a conference
that I'm speaking
at and which one do I want to do do I
want to do St Louis do I want to do
Atlanta maybe Atlanta going to get you a
good seat at a conference I'm speaking
at ready you guys ready for some serious
action it is action time uh get your
receipts in get your receipts in uh
email them to Super8 super the number8
Vayner media.com here's your action um
and I'm excited I'm excited I'm
excited uh fire up Aaron Bernardo Sue
Sue Zimmerman great to see you I would
love to go to St Louis with my man Andy
and you Wally that's going to be a good
event this is pretty exciting I think I
think this is pretty exciting let's see
ready we go ready Andy what are you
saying any 300 book deals for the group
any thousand book deals for the hour
1300 1300 yep very nice see you in
London good luck with all this here we
go we are going to go I don't think
there's any more VIP tickets in St Louis
all right here we go here's a good one
this person is coming to Atlanta
hopefully they live in
America ATA spr cast I didn't forget
about you good to see you bummed I'm not
into win but I'll gift eight copies for
newbook go go go time here we go what
about champagne David Thomas Moore Anna
good to see you good to see you good to
see you Alex you can edit quantities
order is that we confirm that I was able
to do it I didn't want but yes I had a
call with him yep yeah yeah amazing what
he do he wants to be part of the jam
session he's part of the jam session 300
good job love it you just add a car and
then you
go y true I wish fck yeah that could
have helped could have sold some books
next time next time Alex rips guys s you
know like amazing nine is going to be a
big
day I have an idea n hours nine hours of
live stream streaming nine book lot of
platforms we didn't hit you know YouTube
live blab yeah we could go YouTube live
blab only all right somebody's going to
Atlanta I'm flying you
in um this is a big new Prize Big new
prize I'm flying people into my Atlanta
keynote we're going to get them a great
seat and I'm going to meet them
backstage for five minutes cool yeah I'm
GNA fly them in and I'm going to fly you
out you're going to fly in fly out no
Hotel I'm going to save some bucks on
that please be in America we got really
we got really lucky last time with
Anaheim here we go it's for you guys
this is where this is where you know by
the way this is where I'm about to give
away all this stuff where the third like
the $4 I make on each book I'm G to give
I'm gonna lose like 50x like this is a
complete like the accountant would this
is where Scott would come in and be like
uh you lost $111,000 I'm like oh [__] I
did all right Periscope are you ready
I'm in Canada but I can fly from
Buffalo Facebook live are you ready Cody
Weisner are you ready Chad lafet are you
ready Andrew visic you ready Misty
Johnson you ready you ready adamc you've
been in there all day boss status I'm in
Florida Sherman I would love Sherman
Merricks to win
this um get your receips in for the big
prize get your receipts in for the big
prize and the winner for a trip to
Atlanta to meet me backstage at a keyote
this is a driving no what's the name of
the event rain makers rain makers big
digital event in Atlanta that's when is
it when is it the 9th the 9th March 9th
you're there from 11 to1 I'm there from
11 to1 here we
go the winner of a trip to Atlanta meet
me backstage in a great seat at digital
conference fly in and fly out to Atlanta
or hopefully drive in drive out to
Atlanta
is I know this is where I'm going to get
caught I so agree this person is going
to live in
China okay not horrible the person lives
in New
Jersey PR isna be should I switch it to
92nd Street wipe all right uh so
obviously I'm meeting with five minutes
you can go there we can we can all here
we go a lot of people are like out the
winner is John Raymond from Warren New
Jersey clap it up for
John
John is John here I'm from New oh a lot
of people are from New Jersey they got
excited John are you here John is he is
John here everybody look to see if
John's here John wins that oh that
should have been the big one I would
have been so pumped it would have been
like Drive I would have met him a
[__] Wine Library I would have been a
piece of
cake oh God John are you here John are
you here John are you here John Raymond
is John here John John John 6 yeah we're
doing it soon we got 13
minutes spr cast ends at 6 if we start
at 10 all right spree cast I highly
recommend all of you on spree cast uh to
uh make sure you're following on
Facebook live and Periscope because we
if we go over you you and John is busy
working good all right congrats John
very nice job on Facebook live
appreciate all of you all right Chad
Hammet Alan gr Ryan Mitchell David
Lombard Ryan oh he's on spree cast is he
John is here Gary all right John John
Raymond yeah is he in here yep get him
on the screen get him on the screen this
is awesome we're gonna get him on the
screen right now on spree cast spree
cast John seems longer than eight hours
can I go home
now it's not been longer than John one
he's in here that's awesome he's John
Raymond's on Twitter you getting trying
to get on that's amazing oh John here
you are watch this Facebook live let's
see his reaction Periscope I'm sorry
actually get over here scope near cat
I'm sorry actually Dr Ro can get let's
see John's reaction there he is
John all right dude how are
you doing great were you like what the
hell was like what the
hell right in between two trips so I can
actually make it so John on a on a
serious kick because we can hack with
this since we're so close do you want to
schlep to Atlanta or you want to come by
Vayner media and hang for a little bit
you want to kind of barter and trade it
out is it you want to meet me at Wine
Library and drink a bottle of wine and
talk for a little bit I'm only getting
five minutes of a selfie and you got to
slep all the way to [__] Atlanta do
you want to do 20 minutes at Wine
Library do you want to come to 92nd
Street Y in New York for the big opening
we can hang it grab or NYC would be
highly appreciated that would be awesome
I mean I mean that's a done deal and as
you can imagine it's good for me too and
we'll get to spend we'll we'll exchange
those dollars for time and I'll be able
to hang out with you I think I want to
do Wine Library send an email to India
right now and India we'll get into
rotation India Vayner media John how
long you been watching
today uh on and off I mean I I started
really early but I've been out and and I
just came back I've been literally
sitting here doing some work for about
15 minutes and that's so cool John I
can't wait to hang man awesome
congratulations thank you very much and
thank you for buying eight books what
are you doing with the other
seven uh giving them to my business
partner thank you brother thank you so
so much have you been to the Wine
Library John oh yes yes uh what is it
Brandon yes gave me a tour I love it
awesome can't wait to see you brother
send IND India Vayner media the email
we'll get connected soon gotta all right
brother take care that was unbelievable
and he was on spree cast
what an awesome day that's so cool guys
I got to admit one of the amazing things
going on right now is I'm super pumped I
mean Anaheim for Disneyland was crazy
the odds of that were nuts watch the
last one's be like I'm going to get
drilled on the big one aren't I it's
about the last one yeah India you were
positive I was in deep crap there and
um all right oh what's the uh here ask
me to what's that I hope all of the here
you
go that was super
fun uh yay Brandon agreed Thomas cool
ceiling sorry guys about the ceiling uh
so we're getting very close here nine
minutes to go to a complete nine minutes
you're sad right d Rock don't you wish
this was our actual career and job like
it's just what we did for a living
no all right what should we do what
should we do you want to ask how much
more you know what I definitely you know
what I want to do I want to give away
one of the so my barter page what is it
gary.com
bar Ask Gary vri.com
SL barter das4 the number four F oh f r
Dash Gary V search bar oh search barter
on my website perfect go to my website
Gary
v.com and uh and uh search barter on
there you'll see that if you buy 50
books I will make a personalized message
is it too late get your re seat in get
your re seat in real quick because we're
really close to like putting this down
I'm going to be pulling the big prize
for some of you that are just jumping in
the big prize is me flying you somewhere
in the world where I am London Australia
Hawaii New York La San Francisco we're
going to figure that out where you are
where I am if you buy eight books and
you sent in a receipt today during a
super eight um uh I uh I uh will pull
one name in a little bit and I will meet
you for one full hour where I will
consult on your business uh talk to you
about the New York Jets or do something
crazy but whatever it's going to be uh
your first your book is first in Germany
first overall Fabian or first in
business is there Amazon
do what would Germany be it's first in
like you
know in business which is pretty yeah no
I get
it here's a
stack check
it uh on there so tempted to buy the 50
to get my recorded ringtone a lot of you
bought eight today you're more than
welcome to email us at any time on the
barters if you want to buy another 42
cuz you got an event or give give away I
mean I I think it's really cool bunch of
people already buying it I'm going to be
their alarm clock I'm excited about some
of the ones I'm I'll record anything if
I'm okay with it I won't record like I
love the Patriots you know um I uh will
I'm recording things like get the [__]
up it's time to get up [__]
let's get this [__] Monday let's go
[__] like I got a lot of stuff that
I'm recording I'm excited about that uh
first in marketing on Ax very nice uh so
yes I'm excited about the 50 book thing
and I'm going to give away one of right
now I will personally record something
for you A lot of people buying it for
their friends and making me do some
funny things like like stuff I don't
even know like hey rooster The Booga
like like inside jokes I think are
pretty funny anyway here we go one of
you is getting a 50 a I do love te one
of you is getting a 50 barter book deal
right now which is a
recording uh which is a
recording finger typ H from which is a
recording of your choice that I will
send to you that you can use on your
phone number one in marketing in Canada
awesome here we go and the winner
is the winner is from
Tennessee Joseph
deliss Joseph
deliss congratulations well that's where
it's being addressed to billing is
different Joseph and a
Joseph d l i s i or haime chill cut j a
ymy chill cut
congratulations congratulations Joseph
or haime are you for Joseph May yeah I
don't know we got to figure it out but
India email India Bor media.com is
anybody claiming this in any of this
Periscope Facebook live I love the
congrats Joseph the congratulations I
love how everybody's is doing that can
we confirm Joseph deliss I guess it's
Joseph deliss cuz they highlighted
it is that it few more few more okay
fight cuz I want to do the grand priz
soon seven minutes stop five minutes
okay everybody on Periscope we're you're
gonna have to move spr cast excuse
Mees five all right so is anybody big
win for Joseph that's a nice one the 50
book deal all right do you need that
yeah I want to throw oh no that's I
guess they're out all right
it's getting interesting one last
question guys how to deal with the
business in Africa magazines are still
read a lot yeah I mean you got to play
to your Market Market in what 5,000
books uh so yeah you got to Market in
your market and so if your Market is 80y
olds you know Facebook's your only
chance but everything else is TV and
other things like that print but you
know the world's moving a lot quicker
than people think uh am I bringing drock
to Atlanta drock where are you traveling
with me we're doing a lot of daily bees
on the road all of March
Australia what are you going to do like
like are you going to like come to the
front first CL are you on my flight I'm
not going first class I know you're not
going [__] first class T Rock why
don't you just fly private to Australia
Dr Rock I'll meet you
there yeah Dr Rock's gonna Six Minutes
video me for me thanks um what's the
next part of deal so we gave away the
50 I do have some paper cuts already
it's a great question good luck everyone
thank you Vicky Stewart you're awesome
Misty Johnson again Ida I love you 50
it's your attention for 5 minutes for 75
what's that 5 minutes of your time for
75 bucks 5 minutes of my time for 75
bucks you know what I want to shut that
down because I have a funny feeling a
lot of people are about to buy that and
I don't really don't have the five
minutes but I will give one away giving
one away right now five minutes of my
time for free well not for
free phone Skype or in person five
minutes of my
time five minutes of my
time yes Jay I know it's five minutes it
may seem funny but I would be super
pumped for 5 minutes of Ryan
Fitzpatrick's time I'd ask him a couple
plays take a quick selfie I'd be pumped
I'll be like yeah
F here we go congratulations who wants
this anybody want it like I don't know
if you want it are you
interested nice I like it I like a
periscope let's see I'll do it me Bianca
wants it Petra wants it office pizza
party for five minutes I don't know
about that Paul here we go here we go
four minutes left for you guys on spre
cast slide over to Facebook live
facebook.com Gary super easy way to go
Facebook can you guys share this up
please please share this up what's the
prize five minutes of my time five
minutes of my time face uh phone Skype
or if you can get here in person New
York and here we
go four minutes of selfies for
Andrew
and the
winner is this person also bought
another book which is funny which I
like shmika n
Williams Shamika congratulations Shamika
are you here Shamika sh sh i m e Kaa n
Williams Shamika let's clap it up for
shamik
shmika bang shmika I hope shamika's here
is she I'll fly there crush it call me
Eric wants a phone call congrats
congrats congrats we are getting we're
down to two minutes for periscope I
think had a big day Gary ve chuckle Day
made you got me man um congrat sha
congrats shika hope you're watching
shmika what's crushed all about Jay was
my view on the world in 2009 and how you
could make money and live a better life
on the emerging internet World these new
things called YouTube and Facebook
they're going to be
big I was
right Andy I was
right who wants to go to
Vegas I love giving away Vegas trips
just because I think like people get
double happy with Vegas because they're
like that's so cool and it's going to
stay in Vegas
uh nah I always do Vegas Vegas off the
table I think it's time to do the big
the big Dr time I think it's
time let me see this dck somebody who
made this Andrew or some a fan this is
on Twitter right now looks like the
wrecking ball me on the wrecking ball
yeah this is me on the wrecking
ball me on the wrecking ball me on the
wre wrecking ball spre cast we're going
to lose you in a second in one minute
it's me on the wrecking ball should I
get it in in the last minute forcast
should we wrap it
up we have more receipts I need these
Reet receipts we got any receipts or we
done here for the hurry all right fre
cast if you want to see it live you're
gonna have to migrate
facebook.com
Gary
facebook.com Gary
um bro guy that was me on the rec I sang
it I actually sang it yeah you did that
was
weird what's his name bought who bought
Jeff chin I think his name bought 32 I
want to make sure he's in here comes
Garrett with some final
receipts Needs Some Ds that's it that's
it last
ones all
[Applause]
[Music]
in and here we go
for the trip somewhere in the world to
spend an hour with me where I will bring
serious value so that good to see you
hey there's eight seconds I love how I
love how I literally love how spr cast
is two
one it's going 801 Andy they might have
extended it for us they might have
extended for us amazing that's kind of
cool uh and here we go oh no it
ended put worse there here we
go can I get a follow on Snapchat how
many of you are following me on Snapchat
and actually use Snapchat so say yes or
no let's just do that while you guys do
Dr roll yes or no only yes or no it's
Gary VE for oh yes
is good
good wait is this it this is
it this is the
one
keep
going I'm so
nous Garrett this is you this this came
in today yep came in today I dug it
around a lot congratulations to the
winner thank you all so much before I
pull this off thank you all so so so so
so much for your support today I enjoyed
the last eight hours it was a lot of fun
um had a great great great time with all
of you really appreciate all your
support it means the world to me um it
was it's really a really good book I'm
really proud of it I really am and uh
and uh we did a lot of cool things today
and thank you so much and so the winner
of the grand prize of the Super Eight
what we were here to do good luck to
everybody everybody ready just want to
make sure everybody's
ready the winner the grand prize which
gets to meet me for an hour
you're excited I'm super
excited uh I will meet this is eligible
to anybody in the world
um here we go the
winner it's coming out of your pace to
F you Snapchat it yeah I want to
Snapchat it want me to Snapchat sure
yol's on you egg on your
face I'm about to pull the winner
this was a big big bucket of
receipts all right Spence is building
I'm getting
nervous the winner of Super Eight I will
see you somewhere in the world
is
oh I don't I can't tell where he's
[Laughter]
from I just posted that I don't know the
winner
is God this name's
familiar I'm funny with names you ready
yeah Greg
Flint greig Flinch let's call it
up clap clap
clap
Greg you at Greg Greg one hour I'm going
to give you my whole heart and soul I'm
gonna change your [__] game Greg
congratulations is where is Greg is Greg
here Greg Flint I'm trying to
find flint i n y
yep bought 22 bus he bought 22 24
because he bought crushit and thank you
economy you guys know where he's from
I'm trying to it's not in his uh yeah
congratulations Greg Greg are you here
are you in Facebook
or Periscope sounds pretty American me
cat what a day he made a little video he
made a
video well this isn't the show I knew
that he was familiar it is me show you
that I ordered 20 books well 22 books
per your request
um love what you do man glad to support
you I threw a little crush it in there I
got 20 Ask Gary V I got a good plan for
those version and you're like wait a
second that doesn't meet my request
that's not what I meant Oh wait a second
there's a Kindle or there's an audible
version too we got a little Ask Gary V
audible can't wait for that to come out
hear you killing he's from Minneapolis
and then you know Flint on Twitter Greg
Flint everybody you know what everybody
hit up everybody explode his Twitter
right now he's look can we can is it
definitely Greg Flint doesn't seem like
it there's some Gary B contact D give me
five I know give me two give me my coat
uh watching Periscope he's watching on
Periscope he's watching on Periscope is
he dude congrats so awesome Greg Flyn
let's all like I want all 20
five I want 3,000 people to tweet I want
3,000 people to
tweet Greg Flint right now congrats
congrats Flint not act Greg Flint
congrats because I want people in your
stream to say what's that about so go
congrats at Greg Flint because if you
start with you know at symbol you got to
follow both we've talked a lot about
that I want everybody right now I'm
literally going to go search this right
now everybody on Twitter right now
please everybody say congrats at Greg
flint and I adore all of you your
support means the world to me I'm not so
done with this bucket put this bucket in
my please put this bucket in my office
cool I am not done with this bucket this
bucket is not done my friends this
bucket is not done thank you
[Applause]
guys